AGAIN. DO I NEED TO BEGIN AGAIN.
OKAY THE PRIMARY PURPOSE OF
TODAY'S HEARING IS TO RECEIVE
PUBLIC COMMENT AT THIS LIKELY
WILL BE THE ONLY OPPORTUNITY
UNFORTUNATELY FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT AND I WANT TO BE CLEAR
WE'RE NOT TAKING ANY ACTIONS AT
TODAY'S HEARING. WILL HAVE
LIMITED TIME FOR MEMBER
QUESTIONS TODAY AND IF
QUESTIONS ARE NOT ABLE TO BE
ADDRESSED TODAY AND THAT-
UNFORTUNATELY MAKING THE CASE
WITH MANY OF YOUR QUESTIONS
MEMBERS STAFF CAN CONTACT
DEPARTMENTS DIRECTLY OR IF YOU
POSE THE QUESTION TODAY-%
DEPARTMENTS WILL BE ABLE TO GET
BACK TO YOU AT SOME POINT AFTER
THE HEARING. TODAY TO MAKE AND
PHYSICAL DISTANCING WE WILL BE
USING TECHNOLOGY TO TAKE
TESTIMONY FROM PANELISTS
REMOTELY AND PUBLIC COMMENT VIA
TELEPHONE THERE'S A- CAMERA OUT
IN THE PARK SOMEWHERE. THAT AND
A MICROPHONE- THIS IS A AN
EXPERIMENT NOPE A COMMITTEE HAS
USED THE SYSTEM BEFORE SO WE'LL
KEEP OUR FINGERS CROSSED AND
HOPE THAT IT WORKS WELL- BUT
WERE A- GOING TO BE THE GUINEA
PIGS FOR THAT SYSTEM TODAY. I
WANT TO THANK SPEAKER STEP
ASSEMBLY RULES THE ASSEMBLY
SERGEANTS AND THE LEGISLATIVE
DATA CENTER AND OF COURSE THE A
HARD WORKING GUY FOLKS WHO
STAFF THE SUBCOMMITTEE. FOR UP-
ALL OF YOUR WORK IN PROCURING
AND CONFIGURING THE NEW
TECHNOLOGY THE PROCESS IS AND
PUTTING THIS HEARING TOGETHER
AND MAKE IT POSSIBLE. I'VE BEEN
TO OUR READ SOME DIRECTIONS
REGARDING PUBLIC PARTICIPATION
IN TODAY'S HEARING TO HELP
ENSURE THE SAFETY A ROUTE HERE
TODAY WHILE ALLOWING FULL
PUBLIC ACCESS. TO THE TO. SO
FOR THE PUBLIC WHO WERE IN THE
ROOM AND- THERE ARE MANY. BUT
WE'RE HAVING A PHYSICALLY
DISTANT IN PERSON HEARING GUY
EVEN THOUGH THIS ROOM IS THE
LARGEST HEARING ROOM IN THE
CAPITOL WE CAN UNFORTUNATELY
ONLY ACCOMMODATE A FEW MEMBERS
A MINIMAL CONTINGENT OF STAFF
AND A LIMITED NUMBER OF THE
PUBLIC AND MEDIA SO THAT WE CAN
KEEP OUR SIX. FEET OF SPACING.
THERE ARE ALSO STRICT PHYSICAL
DISTANCING PROTOCOLS FOR THE
PUBLIC TO ENTER AND LEAVE THE
CAPITAL. AND FOR THOSE HERE
TODAY TO MAKE PUBLIC COMMENT AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME. I WILL
RESTATE THIS ONE PUBLIC COMMENT
BEGINS BUT IF ANY MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC IN THE ROOM WISHES TO
SPEAK. THEY WILL RAISE THEIR
HANDS AND I'LL ASK THEM TO
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE. I
WOULD ASK THAT THE PUBLIC
RESPECT PHYSICAL DISTANCE THING
AND NOT TOUCH THE MICROPHONE A
VERY DIFFICULT I'VE ALREADY
VIOLATED THAT INADVERTENTLY
ONCE THIS MORNING. HE BECAUSE
OF THE TIME RESTRICTIONS OF
THIS HEARING. YOU WILL HAVE
ONLY ONE MINUTE FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT AND THERE HAVE BEEN.
HEARINGS IN THE PAST WHEN I'VE-
BEEN A LITTLE BIT LUCY GOOSEY
ABOUT ENFORCEMENT OF- TIME
LIMIT RULES THAT WILL NOT BE
THE CASE TODAY- I- WILL ENFORCE
A STRICT ONE MINUTE JOB MAXIMUM
LIMIT. OF FOR EACH INDIVIDUAL
PUBLIC COMMENT. YOU CAN EXIT
THE HEARING ROOM ONCE YOU'RE
PUBLIC COMMET IS DONE OR YOU
CAN RETURN TO YOUR SEAT BUT
PLEASE OBSERVE PHYSICAL
DISTANCING UPON LEAVING THE
CAPITOL INCLUDING LIMITING
ELEVATOR USE TO ONE PERSON AT A
TIME. FOR OUR ANALYSTS- ALL OF
OUR PANELISTS ARE APPEARING
REMOTELY TODAY FROM REMOTE
WITNESS ROOMS- WITH STAFF
MODERATE IN THE CONVERSATION-
WITH THE MEMBERS HERE IN THE
ROOM. NOW UP WE ARE GOING TO
HAVE AS I MENTIONED REMOTE
PUBLIC COMMENT AS WELL WE'LL BE
USING A MODERATED TELEPHONE
SERVICE FOR THE PUBLIC COMMENT
PORTION OUR CALL IN NUMBER IS
ONE. EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE
TWO EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN. AND
THE ACCESS CODE IS TWO EIGHT
THREE FOUR THREE EIGHT LET ME
REPEAT THAT THE CALL IN NUMBER
IS ONE EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX
NINE TWO. EIGHT FIVE SEVEN AND
THE ACCESS CODE. TWO EIGHT
THREE FOUR EIGHT THAT NUMBER
SHOULD BE POSTED ON THE LIVE
STREAM SCREEN AS WELL. YOU CAN
FIND THIS- ON THE HEARING AGED.
ON THE SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER
THREE SIDE AND IT'S ALSO POSTED
AS AN ANNOUNCEMENT ON ON THAT
WEBSITE. EACH PERSON WILL HAVE
ONE MINUTE FOR PUBLIC COMMENT
AS I'M- I HAVE MENTIONED
EARLIER AND I'LL BE STRICTLY
ENFORCING THE LIMIT THOSE
WATCHING THIS HEARING REMOTELY
SHOULD KNOW THAT THE LIVE
STREAM HAS A SLIGHT DELAY FROM
THAT BROADCAST TO THE ACTUAL
THAT'S GOING ON IN THE ROOM. IF
YOU'RE CALLING IN PLEASE
ELIMINATE ALL BACKGROUND NOISE
I ANY OF YOU WHO BEEN USING
XOOM OR- ANY OF THE OTHER
SYSTEMS THAT ARE OUT THERE KNOW
THAT BACKGROUND NOR IS OUR
ENEMY SO PLEASE- ELIMINATE
BACKGROUND NOISE YEAH THE NEW.
ACT EXCEPT WHEN YOU'RE ACTUALLY
SPEAKING. YOU CAN CALL THE
COMMITTEE AT. 916-319-2099 IF
YOU'RE HAVING ANY PROBLEMS AND
MY STAFF WILL BE THERE AND TRY
TO HELP LET ME REPEAT THAT
NUMBER YOU MIGHT WANNA JOT IT
DOWN IN CASE THERE IS AN ISSUE.
NINE ONE SIX THREE ONE NINE TWO
ZERO NINE NINE. I WILL BEGIN
PUBLIC COMMENT AFTER MEMBERS
HAVE CONCLUDED THEIR COMMENTS
AND THE QUESTIONS. THE OPERATOR
WILL GIVE YOU INSTRUCTIONS ON
HOW TO BE PLACED IN Q. THE
PUBLIC COMMENT. I AM COMMITTED.
TO MAKING SURE THAT PUBLIC
COMMENT BEGINS NO LATER THAN
ELEVEN THIRTY AM. SO THAT THERE
WILL BE AT LEAST NINETY MINUTES
AVAILABLE FOR COMMENT AND I'M I
CALLED TO ALL HELP ME MAKE SURE
THAT WERE DONE WITH OUR- PART
OF THE COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS
SO- IN IT ELEVEN THIRTY SO THAT
WE CAN MEET TO. OF THAT DEADLY.
NO WE'RE EXCEPT READ WRITTEN
FEE BACK OUT OF THE FOLLOWING
EMAIL ADDRESS. BUDGET SUB THREE
NUMERAL THREE AT ASM DOT CA DOT
GOV AGAIN I'LL SPELL IT OUT
THAT'S B. U. D. G. E. T. S. U.
B. THREE. NUMBER THREE. AT ASM
DOT CA DOT GOV. ANY EMAILS SO
THAT WE RECEIVED BY THE CLOSE
OF BUSINESS TODAY WILL BE
COMPILED AND SENT TO ALL
MEMBERS SO I AM TO ALL MEMBERS
OF THE ASSEMBLY BUDGET
COMMITTEE- SO THEY'LL BE
AVAILABLE FOR ALL THE STREET
VIEW. AS I SAID BEFORE TODAY'S
HEARING WILL RESERVE MOST OF
THE TIME FOR PUBLIC COMMENT. I
WILL ALLOW ALL MATT WELL AT
LEAST HALF OF THE TIME I WILL
ALLOW ALL MEMBERS TO MAKE
OPENING COMMENTS- THEN WE'LL
TURN TO OUR PANELISTS. WE HAVE
ONLY ONE I'LL TODAY WHICH WILL
DISCUSS OF COURSE THE REASON
THAT WE'RE HERE AT THE MAY
REVISION PROPOSALS. WE HAVE
ASKED THE LATE NIGHT OF
ANALYST'S OFFICE TO WALK US
THROUGH ALL OF THE PROPOSALS
AND THEN THE ADMINISTRATION
WILL PROVIDE SOME BRICK.
SPONSORED THAT PAT HAS CAN.
WE'LL HAVE QUESTIONS AND
DIALOGUE WITH THE PANELISTS
FINALLY- ONCE THE MEMBER
QUESTIONS HAVE CONCLUDED I WILL
OPEN UP THE HEARING- FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT. FIRST TAKING PUBLIC
COMMENT FROM THOSE IN THE ROOM
AND THEN OPEN IT UP TO PUBLIC
COMMENT FROM THOSE WHO ARE
CALLING IN. AND WE HAVE ONLY
FOUR PEOPLE HERE SO WE'RE NOT
READY TO TAKE A ROLL CALL YET-
WILL WAIT TO DO THAT. BUT I DO
HAVE SOME OPENING COMMENTS AND
TO- THEN IF- ANY OF YOU HAVE
OPENING COMMENTS WILL TAKE
THOSE AND THEN WILL PROCEED TO
THE PANEL. SO TODAY WE WILL
HEAR IN MORE DETAIL ABOUT THE
GOVERNOR'S REVISED BUDGET WHICH
INCLUDES DIFFICULT CUTS AT
LOWER LEVELS OF FUNDING TO
PROGRAMS THAT THIS SUBCOMMITTEE
CARES DEEPLY ABOUT. AS OF THE
CORONAVIRUS SHUT DOWN AROUND
THE WORLD WITH- IT'S
INTERESTING THAT WE'VE SEEN
LEVELS OF POLLUTION AND CO TM
CO TWO EMISSIONS DROP
EVERYWHERE AND THE RESULTING.
TAX ARE OBVIOUS BLUE SKIES AND
CLEANER AIR. GOALS THAT WE HAVE
BEEN TRYING TO ACHIEVE WITH OUR
CLIMATE RELATED ACTIONS WELL
THE ECONOMIC IMPACTS OF
SHUTTING THE WORLD DOWN-
TERRIBLE BEFORE US THANK LIES
AN OPPORTUNE EIGHTY TO FIND THE
DEMAND FOR JOBS AND GROWTH. OF
WHICH SURE IT UP ALONG WITH.
COVERAGE. TODAY'S HEARING IS
FINAL FUNDAMENTALLY ABOUT
HEARING FROM THE PUBLIC SINCE
THIS MAY BE OUR ONLY
OPPORTUNITY FOR PUBLIC COMMENT
ON THESE ISSUES THIS IS
DEFINITELY NOT AN IDEAL
SITUATION AND SO I WOULD WANT
TO ENCOURAGE YOU ALL. A
CONTINUE TO EXPRESS YOURSELVES
OUTSIDE OF THE HEARING PROCESS
BY SENDING EMAILS AND
CONTACTING US AND- OTHER WAYS-
THE THAT YOU MAY HAVE TO VOICE
YOUR CONCERNS AND YOUR OPINIONS.
NOW I'VE HAD A LOT OF QUESTIONS
AND CONCERNS ABOUT WHAT IS
BEING PROPOSED FOR RESOURCES IN
THE MAY REVISION AND I'M SURE
OTHERS TO TWO. OF I UNDERSTAND
TOUGH SIX RP DID I THINK WE ALL.
AND WE ALL HAVE TO DO. PLUS BUT
THERE ARE MANY INCONSISTENCIES
THAT I FIND CONCERNING FOR
EXAMPLE THERE ARE PROPOSED
ONGOING BASELINE REDUCTIONS
ALONG PROGRAM ALONGSIDE PROGRAM
EXPANSIONS. I'M ALSO CONCERNED
WITH THE ROLLBACK OF THE
HABITAT CONSERVATION FUND WHICH
AIR MARKS THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS ANNUALLY FOR A VARIETY
OF CONSERVATION EFFORTS. THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL WOULD
SHIFT EIGHTEEN POINT NINE
MILLION DOLLARS ON AN ONGOING
BASIS FROM THE WILD CONSERVE IT
WILDLIFE CONSERVATION BOARD. TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE. AND WHILE I-
CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND THAT- DFW
NEEDS ADDITIONAL FUNDING TAKING
FROM ANOTHER SISTER AGENCY
CONDUCTING COMPLIMENTARY WORK
IS IN MY OPINION NOT THE RIGHT
APPROACH AND TO TOP IT ALL OFF
THE EXT OF THE HABITAT
CONSERVATION. WHAT'S THE
NEGOTIATED BUDGET DEAL FROM
ONLY A YEAR AGO. THIS PROPOSAL
WOULD BASICALLY UNDO THAT DEAL
AND THE AT IT JUST SEEMS SO ODD
TO ME THAT IT THIS IS NOT THE
WAY WE SHOULD BE OPERATING-
BETWEEN THE ADMINISTRATION AND
THE LEGISLATURE IF WE CUT A
DEAL. AT A MINIMUM IF THE
ADMINISTRATION FEELS THAT THERE
NEEDS TO BE A CHANGE TO A DEAL
THAT WAS JUST CUT LAST YEAR. I
WOULD THINK THAT THE BETTER
APPROACH WOULD BE TO COME TO
THE LEGISLATURE- THROUGH THE
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE. AND
DISCUSS THAT AND SEE IF THERE
ISN'T. A BETTER WAY- OTHERWISE
WHY ARE WE MAKING DEALS. SO I
AM ALSO VERY FRUSTRATED WITH-
MANY TRANSFERS- TO OFFSET THE
USE OF THE GENERAL FUND. MOST
NOTABLY- THERE'S A TRANSFER OF
NINETY MILLION DOLLARS FROM THE
AIR POLLUTION CONTROL FUND. I'M
CONCERNED THAT THESE FUNCHESS
WILL HAVE AN OVERALL REGRESSIVE
IMPACT ON ALL OF OUR
ENVIRONMENTAL EXPENDITURES AND
EFFORTS. HOWEVER TO ENSURE
ADEQUATE TIME FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT- I'M NOT CONNECT- ASK
THE QUESTIONS AT ALL WITH HOLD
ANY OTHER COMMENTS AND DISCUSS-
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION
DEPARTMENTS OFFLINE. ON THE
WHOLE I THINK GIVEN THE
CIRCUMSTANCES THE- THE-
DEPARTMENTS HAVE PRESENTED US
WITH- THERE- BEST CASE
SCENARIO- AND HAVE DONE A
REASONABLY GOOD JOB IN DOING
SO- GIVEN A VERY VERY SHORT
PERIOD OF TIME AND THE- REALLY
CALAMITOUS DROP IN REVENUES WE
ARE- DEEP. WITHIN THE STATE.
I'M HOPE THAT TODAY'S SPEAKERS
WILL BE CONSCIOUS OF OUR GOAL
TO MAXIMIZE TIME FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT AND KEEP INTRODUCTORY
REMARKS AND QUESTIONS TO A-
THAT TO A MINIMUM BUT TO A
REASONABLE- LENGTH SO THAT- WE
ARE ABLE TO TIME WE GET TO
PUBLIC COMMENT. AGAIN WE WILL
BEGIN PUBLIC COMMENT NO LATER
THAN ELEVEN THIRTY AM AS WE
HAVE A HARD STOP FOR THIS
HEARING AT ONE PM AND LET ME
REEMPHASIZE. THAT DATA POINT OF
WE WILL NOT HAVE THIS FROM AS
OF PM AND SO WE HAVE TO FINISH
OUR BUSINESS- UNFORTUNATELY. IN
THE OF THREE HOURS THAT HAVE
BEEN ALLOCATED TO US- WITH THAT
SAID TO. DALY OF MY LOOK LIKE
TO MAKE OPENING REMARKS. AND
YET WE DO HAVE- ENOUGH PEOPLE
HERE TO TAKE ALSO THANK YOU
WELL TAKE ROLE AND BECOME A
FORMAL. FORMALIZE BODY. BLOOM
HERE FONG HERE GARCIA MULLIN.
PATTERSON RAY YES RIVAS. AT
THE- MS GARCIA HAS SAID.
EXTENSIVE DESIRE TO MAKE A
BRIEF COMMENT AT THANK YOU AND
I WILL BE BRIEF AND ALSO-
REALLY MY QUESTION THAT AFFECT
OTHER CHANNELS FOR THAT PUBLIC
CAN PARTICIPATE BUT I DID WANT
TO POINT OUT A COUPLE OF THINGS
MYSELF AND THE PROPOSAL I
UNDERSTAND WE HAVE. TOUGH
CHOICES TO MAKE AND I JUST HOPE
AS WE'RE MAKING THESE. THINK
ABOUT A MORE THAN EQUAL SOME
PEOPLE TALK ABOUT 10% ACROSS
THE BOARD BUT I THINK WE NEED
TO BE THINKING ABOUT EQUITY.
ALONG THAT WAY AND WHAT THAT
MIGHT MEAN TO SOME OF OUR MORE
AFFORDABLE COMMUNITIES- AND SO
WITH THAT WHEN I THINK ABOUT
THAT THIRTY PIECES AND- THAT
MAY REALIZE THAT I. WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT ONE- IS- POLLUTION
CONTROL FINE AND THE MONEY
THAT'S BEING PULLED OUT THERE-
IT IS WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
THINK ABOUT THE IMPLICATIONS SO
WHAT THAT MEANS OUR CLEAN AIR.
OF WORK THAT WE STILL NEED TO
DO IN A LOT OF THESE
COMMUNITIES WELL WE POPULOUS
GUY THINK COMMUNITIES LIKE MINE
I. HAVEN'T SEEN IN. MANY MANY
YEARS WE KNOW THAT THIS IS A
TEMPORARY THING AND WHATNOT
THERE'S A LOT OF WORK TO BE
DONE COMMUNITIES WHERE. ARE OUR
QUALITY HOT HAS BEEN. SOME OF
THE WORST MISTAKE OUT FOR MANY
MANY YEARS AND SO JUST WANT TO
MAKE SURE WE'RE MAKING. WHAT
WE'RE THINKING THAT THROUGH.
ANA ALONG THE WAY THE MONIES
ARE IN YOU JUST HAVE. TO FIND.
SOME STRUCTURAL DEFICITS WITH
THE DEPARTMENT AT T. AND T.
WHICH- THIS LAPTOP THE CLEAN UP
OUR- REMOTE. THE ASIAN OVER
THAT ALL. IT DISTRICTS AWHILE.
THE NURSE. ALLOWED TO LET OUR-
I. FIVE AND A CONTAMINANTS IN
MY WATER AND- HAVING A-
CONTINUE TO PLACE AN- THERE.
I'M INCLUDE EXCITED AS WE AT
HOW USE THOSE. FOR THE HOME. AT
OUR- MEETING. AND WERE BORN
MONEY SITE WE- THAT. EXCESSIVE
BACK. ON ALTHOUGH THE TO FIGHT
CHAPTER ELEVEN. OUR EARLIER
THIS WEEK AND SO NOT SURE IF
THAT HAPPENS WHAT DOES AS WE'RE
DOING THIS MOVEMENT IN THIS.
LOCAL TIME AND I JUST WANNA
MAKE SURE WE'RE THINKING LONG
TERM. AS WE'RE DEALING WITH THE
SHORT TERM PROBLEM- ALONG THE
WAY AND THEN FINALLY ABOUT AB
SIX SEVENTEEN. HAS BEEN A
PROGRAM THAT'S BEEN AROUND FOR
A COUPLE YEARS THAT IDENTIFIES
HOT SPOTS AROUND THE STATE. AND
WORK HAS BEEN A- GROUPS UP MORE
ADDING THREE ADDITIONAL
COMMUNITIES THIS YEAR. BUT WE
ARE CUTTING THAT KIND OF BIT.
ALONG THE WAY AND SO AS WE LOOK
AT HOW THAT AFFECTS.
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES WE
DON'T HAVE TO DEAL WITH LUCIA.
LIKE IT ARE TEMPLE. IN DEAL
SELECTING BUT IT EXCEPT MARK.
IS EVEN MORE AND- AS A
STRUGGLING FROM TO SEE A- THE-
ONE WAY ADDING THE- CAN. THERE
AND SO. THE THAT. I'M TO. FORM
FOR. FIFTEEN FIVE EXTRA WAY.
THANK YOU CHAIR BLOOM AND THE
SPEAKER STAFF- FOR SETTING UP
THIS HEARING. OF YOU KNOW. OF I
AM VERY CONCERNED OF HOW. ARE
BUDGET AND THE CUTS THAT WE ARE
PROPOSING WILL AFFECT
DISADVANTAGED. COMMUNITIES IN
LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES. THAT
RIGHT NOW ARE ALSO THE MOST
AFFECTED. BY THE COVERT CRISIS
AND- CONSIDERING THAT- OUR
STATE IS EXPECTED TO HAVE AN
EXCESSIVELY HOT SUMMER- I HAVE
CONCERNS. ABOUT INCREASE STATS
BECAUSE PEOPLE- FINANCIALLY
CAN'T AFFORD. TO TURN ON THEIR
AIR CONDITIONERS- AND- THEY
BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE THE
MONEY THEY ARE BEING AFFECTED
BY THE PRICE. AND I THINK. STAY
HOME SO I THINK SOME. WE COULD
BE MAKING FOR DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES ARE. TO CONNECT
THEM TO ENERGY EFFICIENCY
PROGRAMS THAT THE STATE ALREADY
HAS- AND SO. I JUST WANNA I
LOOK FORWARD TO THIS HEARING
AND- AND TO SEE WHAT WE CAN ALL
DO TOGETHER- FOR LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISTER PATTERSON. THANK YOU
MISTER THANK FOR A- THAT TO ME
JUST TO HELP MAKE ONE QUICK
COMMENT- I AM PARTICULARLY
CONCERNED ABOUT THE D. T. T. A
STRUCTURE SHORTFALL- THERE'S
SOME I THINK RATHER- LARGE
EXPENSIVE- FEE INCREASES
COMING- WE ARE SEEING A LARGE
NUMBER PERMITTED FACILITIES.
DECLINING PASSED THE GOING OVER
THE LAST TEN YEARS BECAUSE OF
INCREASED REGULATORY AND COST
BURDENS. AND I'M NOT REALLY
CONVINCED THAT THIS IS GONNA
CHANGE OR REVERSE THAT COPIED.
HAVING SAID THAT I HOPING
SOMEWHERE IN THE PRESENTATION
AND. THE TWENTY TWO A- THIS
CALL WITH PROPOSED A JETS
MISSED IN THE SNOW FEES WE ARE
SO. WHAT KIND OF PERFORMANCE
BASED METRICS ARE GOING TO BE
INCLUDED IN THIS AND OTHER
WORDS WERE ASKING LOTS OF
AND HE'S REGULATORY COSTS. HOW
DOES THE DEPARTMENT HOLD ITSELF
ACCOUNTABLE AND BE TRANSPARENT
WITH RESPECT TO THE USE OF
THOSE FUNDS AND THE LIKELIHOOD
THAT THE PROCESS WILL BE MUCH
IMPROVED SO THAT WE ACTUALLY
SEE. PERMITS IT'S TIME APPROVE
FOR THE PURPOSES OF HANDLING
THESE HAZARDOUS- MATERIALS I
HOPE THAT THAT WILL BE
ADDRESSED SOMETIME IN THE
PRESENTATION IF NOT I'D LIKE TO
FOLLOW. SURE NO PROBLEM. ALL
RIGHT WELL WE WILL BEGIN WITH
OUR TOP PANEL DISCUSSION NOW WE
HAVE- AS INTENTIONALLY ONE
PANEL AND WE WILL BEGIN- BY
HEARING FROM BRIAN BROWN DEPUTY
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S. GOOD
MORNING CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES
ALL RIGHT GOOD MORNING. AND WE
CAN SEE CHAIRED MEMBERS BRIAN
BROWN WITH THE LA- I A- DO YOU
HAVE THE INTENTIONHAND OUT
WHICH I HAVE PROVIDED TO THE
COMMITTEE CONSULTANTS AND
HOPEFULLY YOU HAVE A COPY- I
WILL ALSO UPDATE THEIR HAND OUT
IS AVAILABLE ON THE LA-
WEBSITE. AS WELL AS ASSEMBLY
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE WEBSITE FOR
THE PUBLIC- IN THE INTEREST OF
TIME I WILL TRY TO MOVE THROUGH
THIS FAIRLY QUICKLY- HOWEVER IF
THE COMMITTEE DOES HAVE
QUESTION I AM AVAILABLE AT THE
END. OF THE- IF YOU TURN TO
OKAY. THIS IS A HIGH LOW
OVERVIEW OF THE MAY REVIEW FOR
TO REACHED AGE. RELATIVE TO THE
JANUARY BUDGET PROVIDES FOR THE
THIRTY THOUSAND FOOT OVERVIEW
AND I THINK THAT YOU KEY TAKE
AWAYS FOR THE COMMITTEE THE
FIRST IS THAT IF YOU LOOK AT
YOUR LOCATION SPENDING IT IS
DOWN OVER TWO MILLION DOLLARS
IN THE MAY REVISION RELATIVE TO
JANUARY. THIS IS LARGER THAN BY
A REDUCTION IN PROJECTED. IN
PROJECTED- TRANSPORTATION
REVENUES FROM DIESEL SALES TAX
AND- EXCISE GASOLINE TAXES THIS
PRIMARILY AFFECTS TO PROGRAMS
THAT OUR FORMULA FUNDED FOR
LOCAL AGENCIES. THAT IS THE
STATE TRANSIT ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM AND THE LOCAL STREETS
AND ROADS PROGRAM. THE SECOND
MAJOR TAKE AWAY FROM THIS PAGE
IS THAT IF YOU LOOK ACROSS THE
OTHER AGENCIES THE LEVEL OF
SPENDING IS NOT DRAMATICALLY
DIFFERENT ON NET FROM THE
JANUARY BUDGET HOWEVER
UNDERLYING ALL OF THAT IS A
SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF
ADJUSTMENTS BOTH MOSTLY
DOWNWARD BUT ALSO SOME UPWARD
AS WELL THAT THAT EACH OTHER
OUT INTO THOSE ARE WHAT ALL
TALK ABOUT. THE NEXT FEW. IT
TURNED AND- EACH ITS TITLE
GONNA FUND. EXPENDITURE A- THIS
IS A LISTING OF ALL OF THE
EXPENDITURE REDUCTION PROPOSED
IN THE MAY REVISED RELATIVE TO
THE JANUARY BUDGET. I WON'T GO
THROUGH ALL OF THEM OF COURSE
BUT IF YOU DO LOOK THROUGH THE
LIST I THINK WHAT YOU'LL SEE IS
THAT THE MAIN THEME IS THAT
MOST OF THE REDUCTION WITH SOME
EXCEPTIONS. ARE NOT ONES THAT
ARE CUTS TO BASELINE FUNDING
FOR RESOURCES AND
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAMS INSTEAD
MOST OF THEM ARE- SOME
COMBINATION OF WITHDRAWAL-
PROPOSAL MADE IN JANUARY. FINE
SHIPS- FOR EXAMPLE REFERENCE
EARLIER THE USE OF A PC ACT TO
BACK FILL A GENERAL FUND
SPENDING PROPOSED IN JANUARY.
OR THE REVERSION OF PRIOR YEAR
EXPENDITURES APPROVED SO VERY
PARTICULAR FOR CAPITAL OUTLAY
PROJECTS THAT WOULD NOW BE
EITHER PAUSED OR- OR STOPPED-
ON ON AN ONGOING BASIS. NOT
JUST TO HIGHLIGHT A COUPLE OF
EXCEPTIONS TO THOSE- THAT THAT
SORT OF GENERAL THEME. THE
FIRST IS WITH RESPECT TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
IS THE FIFTH ITEM DOWN ON. THE
LIST- TRIGGER CUTS TO
BIODIVERSITY CONSERVATION
PROGRAM I HAD LIKE THIS BECAUSE
THIS IS ONE AREA WHERE THERE IS
A BASELINE REDUCTION PROPOSED
FOR FISH AND WILDLIFE. TOTAL
THIRTY THREE POINT SEVEN
MILLION HOWEVER THE PROPOSAL TO
OFFSET THAT IN PART BY ABOUT
NINETEEN MILLION DOLLARS IN THE
HABITAT CONSERVATION FUND. THE
OTHER EXCEPTIONAL POINT OUT IS
FOR THE FROM THE BOTTOM ON THE
LIST THE RELATIVELY SMALL
AMOUNT OF FUNNY PROPOSED IN THE
MAY REVISED FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS. FOR A NEW STATE PARK-
THIS IS A REDUCTION FROM A
TWENTY MILLION DOLLAR PROPOSAL
IN JANUARY- IN THIS CASE WE
RECOMMEND A REJECTION OF THE
PROPOSAL PARTLY DUE TO THE
GENERAL FUND CONDITION YEAH.
BUT ALSO BECAUSE THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS NOT PROVIDED
THE LEGISLATURE WAS SUFFICIENT
INFORMATION ABOUT WHAT PARK
WOULD BE OUR WEBSITE WOULD BE
REQUIRED TO CREATE THIS NEW
PARK. IN PERSON- THE
IMPLICATION READING PARK IS
THAT THERE WOULD BE FUTURE
CAPITAL COST FOR IMPROVEMENTS
AS WELL I'M GOING OPERATIONS
AND MAINTENANCE COSTS AND IT
SEEMS. AT THIS POINT PRUDENT TO
THE CHRIS **** PROJECT WE DON'T
KNOW WHAT THE SITE IS. IF YOU
TURN TO THE THIRD PAGE. THIS IS
A OF THE- FINE LOAN ENTRANCE.
PROPOSED TO THE GENERAL FUND.
AS YOU CAN SEE ONE POINT
BILION. IN TOTAL. AND THIS IS
THAT MAKE UP THE BIGGEST.
SOURCE OF SOLUTIONS FOR THE
GENERAL FUND. IN THESE PROGRAM
AREAS. IN GENERAL WE THINK- THE
PROPOSALS ARE REASONABLE AND
GIVEN THE GENERAL FUND
CONDITION HOWEVER JUST A COUPLE
OF NOTES FOR OF ALL THEY ARE.
ONE TIME SOLUTIONS AND
THEREFORE- THEY'RE NOT BUT-
THEY ARE LOANS- THEY ARE NOT
AVAILABLE FOR USE. IN NEXT YEAR.
THERE ALSO DID YOU A FUTURE
GENERAL FUND ABA. TO REPAIR
THOSE COSTS WHILE WE GENERALLY
HAVE NO CONCERNS WITH THE LOANS
AND TRANSFERRED AND ONE JUST A
HIGHLIGHTED THE POSSIBLE
EXCEPTION IS THE FIRST ONE ON
THE LIST THE TRANSFER FROM THE
STATE HIGHWAY CAL. THE ISSUE
HERE THAT THIS IS GENERALLY A
FUN DAY IS A PROTECTED BY
ARTICLE NINETEEN OF THE
CONSTITUTION AND IS NOT
AVAILABLE FOR NON
TRANSPORTATION PURPOSES
INCLUDING TRANSFERRED ALONE.
HOWEVER THE INITIATION HAD
IDENTIFIED A POSSIBLE EXCEPTION
TO THIS- BASED ON. THIS AND
THIS PROPOSAL THE TRANSFER OF
INTEREST EARNINGS ON THE
ACCOUNT WHICH IS NOT EXPLICITLY
PROHIBITED AND- IN THE
CONSTITUTION WORK CURRENTLY-
CONSULTING WITH LEGISLATIVE
COUNSEL TO SEE- IF THEY SHARE
THAT SAME INTERPRETATION OF
WALL. CIRCLE BACK WITH
COMMITTEE ON ON WHAT WE LEARN.
YOU TURN TO PAGE FOUR THERE ARE
REAL FEW. GENERAL AUGMENT.
PROPOSED AND THE NEIGHBOR
VISION OR RETAIN FROM JANUARY
OF THIS HIGHLIGHTS THE- THE
LARGER ONE MORE THAN FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS. I JUST A
COUPLE TO HIGHLIGHT HERE THE
FIRST TWO FOR PARKS AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE- IN THIS CASE NEEDS
ARE. COMBINATION CURRENT YEAR
AND BUDGET YEAR AUGMENTATION
MEANT TO ADDRESS ON GOING AND
IN SOME CASES NEW COST- BUT
THAT ARE NOT ABLE TO BE FUNDED
BECAUSE OF THE REDUCTION
REVENUES FROM REDUCE VISITOR
SHIP AND AN ASSOCIATE AND SHE-
AND THE INABILITY TO HOLD. AS
MANY EVENTS. AS WE CAN BE
REASONABLE ALTHOUGH EXACT.
ESTIMATE ARE ARE SUBJECT TO
SOME UNCERTAINTY. THE THIRD
ITEM ON THE LIST THE CALIFORNIA
RELEASE BACKING FACTOR
PROPOSAL- THIS IS A PROPOSAL
FROM JANUARY- IT IS RETAIN FROM
THEN ON ALTHOUGH THE SOME OF
THE SPECIFICS OF THE PROPOSAL
ARE MODIFIED. YEAH IN THIS CASE
WE SIMPLY HIGHLIGHT THAT THIS
IS. THE MOST SIGNIFICANT THE
GENERAL FUND AUGMENTATION
PROPOSED IN THE MAY REVISION
ARE RETAINED IN THE MAYOR
VISION AND WE THINK THIS WILL
BE A TOUGH DECISION FOR THE
LEGISLATURE ON THE ONE HAND
THERE IS- I THINK A REAL
INTEREST IN. CONTINUING TO
SUPPORT WILD FIRE EFFORTS OF
WILDFIRE OF PROTECTION AT THE
SAME TIME THIS IS IT AND IN
ADDITION TO THAT OF COURSE
THERE IS CONCERN THAT THIS
COULD BE A PARTICULARLY BAD
FIRE YEAR HELLO PRECIPITATION
GOAL THAT'S THIS IS A LARGE
IMPORTANT. I'M GOING GROWING
PROPOSE IT RIGHT THE ENGINE
THEIR FIVE. IN OUT HERE IN
THEIR FULL YOU'LL HAVE TO WEIGH
THAT YOUR GENERAL FUND. HE'S
I'M ACTUALLY ABLE TO THE FINAL
I. FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF FISH
WHILE. THIS IS A RELATIVELY SO
FOR FIRST MILLION DOLLARS IS TO
EMPLOYEE. HOWEVER SOME. ACTIVE
IN THE DEPARTMENT AND WE SIMPLY
NO IN THIS CASE THAT- WELL WE
DON'T HAVE ANY CONCERN WITH THE
SPECIFIC ACTIVITY PROPOSED. IT
IS A BET ON INCONGRUOUS WITH
THE IDEA OF ALSO CUTTING BASED
FUNDING FOR THE DEPARTMENT. AS
MENTIONED EARLIER. IF YOU TURN
TO PAGE FIVE OF THE HAND OUT A
COUPLE OF HIGH LEVEL COMMENTS
BUT LOOKING AT THE OVERALL
GENERAL FUND ARCHITECTURE OF A
PROPOSED IN THE NEAR VISION FOR
THESE AGENCIES. OTHER PERSON
OVERALL WE THINK THE- NATURE OF
THE PROPOSAL A REASONABLE GIVEN
THE LOSS IN GENERAL FUND
REVENUE PROJECTED. BUT WE DO
NOT AGAIN THAT MOST OF THESE
INCLUDING THE SPECIAL FUNDS
LOANS TRANSFERS- AND FINE SHIPS
ARE ONE TIME IN NATURE AND OUR
OFFICE IS PROJECTING THAT THIS
WILL BE A MULTI YEAR. GENERAL
FUND- PROBLEM. BUT WITH REGARD
TO THE BASS LINE BECAUSE I
ALREADY NOTED THE ONE FOR FISH
AND WILDLIFE THE OTHER ONE TO
MAKE SURE YOU'RE AWARE OF IT IN
THE DEPARTMENT OF PARKS AND
RECREATION. THIS WOULD BE A
THIRTY MILLION DOLLAR GENERAL
FUND REDUCTION BUT NOT IN THE
BUDGET YEAR PROPOSED FOR. THE
FOLLOWING YEAR IN BOTH THESE
CASES WE YOU YOU MIGHT
ULTIMATELY FIND THAT THEY'RE
NECESSARY TO ENACT IN ORDER TO
BALANCE THE BUDGET GIVEN
LIMITED GENERAL FUND REVENUES.
I THINK OUR MAIN CONCERN AT
THIS POINT WITH BOTH OF THESE-
IS THE LACK OF SORT OF SPECIFIC
INFORMATION ABOUT HOW TO THE
EMPLOYMENT AND THAT MAY BE
SOMETHING THE COMMITTEE WANTS
TO. CONTINUE TO FOLLOW UP WITH
THE DEPARTMENT ON. ON PAGE SIX-
JUST ONE MORE COMMENT ABOUT THE
GENERAL FUND EIGHT IS THAT WITH
RESPECT TO THE AUGMENTATION
PROPOSED AGAIN WE THINK THERE
ARE REASONABLE RATIONALE
PROPOSED BY THE MINISTRATION-
IN GENERAL FOR THE- HOWEVER.
THEY DO REFLECT THE GOVERNOR'S
SPENDING PRIORITIES AND SO WE
SIMPLY ENCOURAGE THE CANADIAN
THE LEGISLATURE TO ENSURE THAT.
YOU SHARE THE SAME PRIORITIES-
GIVEN THE LIMITED GENERAL FUND
REVENUES AVAILABLE THIS COMING
YEAR. IF YOU TURN TO PAGE. I
WANT HIGHLIGHT A FEW ISSUES
RELATED TO SPECIAL FUNDS AND
BOND FUNDS- THIS BECAUSE IN
FACT IN THIS PROGRAM AREA.
THOSE WHO MAKE UP MOST OF THE
REVENUE SOURCES FOR PROGRAMS.
THE FIRST ISSUE TO HIGHLIGHT IF
THE CAP AND TRADE EXPENDITURE
PLAN AS THE COMMITTEE MAY WELL
NOW THE THERE IS SIGNIFICANT
AND UNCERTAINTY ABOUT WHAT
BUDGET YEAR REVENUES ARE GOING
TO LOOK LIKE. FROM THE CAP AND
TRADE OPTIONS GIVEN THE DECLINE
IN ECONOMIC ACTIVITY AND REDUCE
DRIVING- THE MAIN REVISION
INCLUDES ESSENTIALLY THE SAME.
FUNDING PLAN AS PROPOSED
ANYWHERE AND NINE HUNDRED SIXTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
FOR THE CALL THE DISCRETIONARY
PROGRAM- HOWEVER THE NEAR
VISION DOES ALSO INCLUDE.
ADDITIONAL LANGUAGE WHICH
UPRIGHT CLEARLY PRIORITIZE IS
THE- PROGRAM THAT WOULD RECEIVE
FUNDING FIRST SHOULD REVENUE TO
BE LOWER THAN PROJECTED WE
THINK ULTIMATELY THAT IS A STEP
STRATEGY TO SET EXPLICIT
PRIORITIES IN THE BUDGET- WE
SIMPLY NOTE THAT. THE PROGRAMS
PRIORITIZE ARE THOSE THAT ARE
THE GOVERNOR'S PRIORITIES
INSTANTLY THE LEGISLATURE MAY
HAVE DIFFERENT PRIORITIES-
BASED ON AS INTEREST AND- HOW
IT WANTS TO BALANCE- DIFFERENT-
POLICY GOALS SUCH AS- REDUCING
GHG EMISSIONS- CLIMATE
ADAPTATION AND- IMPROVING AIR
QUALITY NEXT- IT IS BORN TO
NOTE THAT THE MERRY VISION
WITHDRAWALS TO. WITHDRAWS TO
MAJOR CLIMATE PROPOSALS A FOUR
POINT EIGHT BILLION DOLLAR
CLIMATE BOND AS WELL AS THE
PROVISION OF TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION FROM THE GENERAL FUND
FOR NEW CLIMATE CATALYST FUND.
WITH REGARD TO TRANSPORTATION
RATHER I ALREADY MENTIONED THE
DECLINE IN ANTICIPATED
REVENUES- FOR CERTAIN PROGRAMS
AND PARTICULARLY THOSE- LOCAL
PROGRAMS THAT ARE FUNDED
THROUGH. THE DIESEL SALES TAX
AND- GASOLINE EXCISE TAX ALSO
WERE NOTING IS- THE MOTOR
VEHICLE ACCOUNT. AND BASED ON
PROJECTED DECLINE IN
REGISTRATION- REVENUES THOUGH
FUND IS NOW PROJECTED TO GO AND
SOLD IN TWO YEARS SOONER THAN
HAD BEEN PREVIOUSLY PREVIOUSLY
PROJECTED. IN TWENTY TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE NOW- AND SO THIS
IS GONNA BE AN AREA THAT IS
IMPORTANT FOR OUR OFFICE IN THE
COMMITTEES CONTINUE TO MONITOR.
IF YOU TURN THE LAST PAGE PAGE
EIGHT JUST- VERY QUICKLY A
COUPLE OF OTHER I THINK ON A-
FISCAL POLICY BASED IMPORTANT
ISSUE THE NO ALREADY
REFERENCED- IN THE DEPARTMENT
OF TOXIC SUBSTANCES CONTROL.
THE MAYOR REVISION CONTINUES TO
PROPOSE TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
THAT WOULD ESTABLISH A NEW
OVERSIGHT BOARD INCREASED. AND
ESTABLISH A NEW FEE STRUCTURE-
THAT WILL BE AN IMPORTANT
POLICY OR A FOR THE- COMMITTEE
TO CONSIDER. ALSO IMPORTANT NO
PRETTY SIZEABLE INCREASE IN
PROPOSITION SIXTY EIGHT FUNNY
PROPOSED IN THE MAY REVISION
RELATIVE TO JANUARY- A COUPLE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IN
ADDITIONAL FUNDING THERE. AND
THEN LASTLY- WOULD KNOW THAT
THEIR MAYOR VISIONING PROVIDE
AND A LITTLE BIT MORE THAN WHAT
WAS INCLUDED IN JERRY BUDGET
BUT FOR TOTAL ABOUT THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS- FOR THE PUBLIC
UTILITY COMMISSION AND TO
IMPLEMENT. THE NINE OH AND
OTHER RELATED WILD HAIR OF
LEGISLATION IT TO DO OVER. OF
WILD. AND AN IMPORT. CENTRE
RECENTLY ENACT. FOR DIALOGUE.
SO WITH THAT THAT CONCLUDES MY
REMARKS HAPPY TO. ADJUST
ADDITIONAL BUT AS YOU CAN ON.
THANK YOU I'VE JUST LEARNED
THAT APPARENTLY THE PHONE A OR
CODE TO THAT I GAVE A EARLIER
IS. I READ THE ONE FROM THE
AGENDA BUT A PAIR THAT'S NOT
THE- MISS CHANCE. THERE'S AN
ISSUE WITH THAT OKAY I'M
READING TO SEPARATE TO- EMAILS-
I WILL IF IT IF IT THERE'S AN
ISSUE WITH THE NUMBER IF IT
NEEDS CORRECTION I WILL GIVE
YOU AN UPDATE JUST AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE BUT FOR THOSE OF YOU
WHO ARE TRYING TO- GET IN THE
QUEUE FOR PUBLIC COMMENT AND
HAVE BEEN STYMIED THAT'S WHAT
THE PROBLEM IS WERE ADDRESSING
IT AND HOPEFULLY WE'LL HAVE
THAT RESULT IN SHORT ORDER. ARE
THERE A WILL WANT WE- HOLD
QUESTIONS- UNTIL ALL PANELISTS
OF SPOKEN SO NEXT WE HAVE MARK
MONROE. THE ASSISTANT PROGRAM
BUDGET MANAGER WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISTER BROWN
YOU'LL STICK AROUND FOR
QUESTIONS. YES GOOD MORNING-
THIS IS MARK ONE ROW WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- AND-
WANTED TO THANK THE LA FOR YOU
KNOW. GOOD REPRESENTATION OF
WHAT'S IN THE BUDGET SUMMARY
THERE. THE ONLY THING THAT I
THINK- I WOULD ADD IS- JUST A
REFERENCE TO THE- THE FEDERAL
CARE ACT WHICH DID PROVIDE AN
ADDITIONAL THREE POINT SEVEN.
BILLION DOLLARS FOR LOCAL
TRANSIT- AND THAT FUNDING DOES
NOT GO THROUGH THE BUDGET THAT
GOES DIRECTLY TO. LOCAL TRANSIT
AGENCIES. AND SO- WITH THAT I
THINK I JUST SAY THAT THERESA
CALVERT ON MY AND MY OTHER
COLLEAGUES ARE HERE TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE.
THANK YOU- MISS CALVERT. HI
GOOD MORNING F. THREE TO COVER
IT WITH ALSO WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND HERE
TO PARTICIPATE AND THAT THE
QUESTIONS AND ANSWERS AND- AS
MENTIONED EARLY ON IF THERE'S
ANYTHING THAT WE NEED TO FOLLOW
UP ON WE WILL DO SO WITH BUDGET
COMMITTEE STAFF BUT THANK YOU
FOR HAVING US ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU SO NOW WE WILL MOVE TO.
ADDITIONAL MEMBER COMMENTS IF
YOU HAVE THEM- AND TO OR
QUESTIONS. MR FONG. I'M THIS IS
A QUESTION FOR THAT TO THE LA
L. BUT- I'M I'M SURE THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE MAY WANT
TO CHIME IN HERE BUT- CERTAINLY
I WANTED TO DELVE INTO- WHAT
WAS HIGHLIGHTED THE
PRESENTATION ABOUT THE
GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISED PROPOSAL
TO TRANSFER- A HUNDRED SIXTY
TWO MILLION FROM THE ROAD
PROJECTS TO THE GENERAL FUND-
THE TRANSFER OF A HUNDRED
THIRTY MILLION OF THAT IS FROM
THE STATE HIGHWAY ACCOUNT.
WHICH YOU MENTIONED RAISES SOME
LEGAL ISSUES SPECIFICALLY- I
PROP TWENTY. WHICH STATES THAT.
THAT THE FUNDS- PROVIDED SHOULD
BE PROHIBITED FROM BEING SEIZE
DIVERTED SHIFTED BORROWED.
SUSPENDED AND SHOULD BE
DEDICATED TO- FUNDING FOR LOCAL
SERVICES ARE DEDICATED TO
TRANSPORTATION IMPROVEMENT
PROJECTS- CAN YOU CUT A DELVE
INTO THE MORE THE LEGAL ISSUES
OF. AND IS THIS- BUT IT IS THIS
DIVERSION SOMETHING THAT DOES
VIOLATE- THE STATE CONSTITUTION.
CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES YEAH OKAY-
YEAH SO YOU'RE RIGHT THAT THE-
YEAH STATE CONSTITUTION DOES
PROHIBIT. THE USE OF-
TRANSPORTATION NEEDS TO
TRANSPORTATION FUNDS TYPICALLY
FOR NON TRANSPORTATION RELATED
PURPOSES WHICH I TRANSFERRED TO
THE GENERAL FUND WOULD OF
COURSE QUALIFY AS- YOU YOU MAY
WANT TO ASK FINANCE FOR HOW
THEY'VE INTERPRETED THIS BUT-
OUR UNDERSTANDING IN TALKING TO
THEM IS THAT THE- THOUGHT IS
THAT THEIR INTEREST EARNED. ON
SOME OF THE FUNDS IN THE STATE
HIGHWAY ACCOUNT AND THAT THAT
IS NOT EXPLICITLY PROHIBITED
FROM BEING USED FOR NON
TRANSPORTATION PURPOSES. NOT
BEING A I'M NOT ONE TO PROP. TO
OPINE ON WHETHER THIS IS IN
FACT LEGAL OR NOT WE HAVE OUR
BEST UNDERSTAND IS THIS WOULD
BE THE FIRST TIME THIS
INTERPRETATION IS IN USE. SO
WE'VE GOT WE ARE CURRENTLY
CONSULTING WITH COUNSEL AND
WILL- CHARLIE REALLY WHATEVER
WE LEARN TO THE COMMITTEE STAFF.
SO MAYBE THE QUESTION TO
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THEN IS
HOW IS. HOW IS AS JUSTIFICATION
ARE YOU LOOKING FOR. DID YOU
CREATE THIS JUSTIFICATION TO DO
THIS OR- IT SEEMS PRETTY CLEAR
TO ME THAT. WAY AND THE GAS TAX
TO BE WHAT'S HAPPENING. THAT IT
WAS PRETTY CLEAR AT LEAST FROM
THE ARGUMENTS IN SUPPORT OF IT
THAT THE- THE DOLLARS WOULD BE
GOING TO. ROAD PROJECTS AND
THAT. THIS PROPOSAL BY THE
ADMINISTRATION. BREAKS THAT
PROMISE MADE TO THE PUBLIC THAT
HE WOULDN'T DIVERT THE GAS TAX
DOLLARS SO MAYBE DEPARTMENT.
CAN I HEAR FROM THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. CERTAINLY AND TO BE
CLEAR PROBABLY TWENTY PROTECT
THE FUEL TAX REVENUES.
ATTRACTED A NUMBER OF
TRANSPORTATION RVENUES THE
ACTION BUT BUT IT'S IT PROTECTS
ACTUAL REVENUES THAT COME IN-
AND IT DIDN'T EXPLICITLY
PROTECT THE INTEREST EARNED ON
THOSE WHILE THEY WERE IN THE
ACCOUNT. AND SO THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE TRANSFERRING HRE. IT'S
YOU KNOW IF THE INTEREST STATE
IN THE- THE PHONE LONG ENOUGH
THAT- THEY WOULD. BE
TRANSPORTATION PROJECTS WITH
THESE THESE FUNDS IN PARTICULAR
I THINK WE'VE HAD A GENERAL
UNDERSTANDING INTERNALLY AT
LEAST THAT- THESE WERE NOT
SUBJECT ARTICLE NINETEEN
PROTECTIONS AND SO WHEN WE
FOUND OURSELVES IN THIS-
BROADER BUDGETARY DILEMMA-
SWEET. BUT THAT WE DECIDED TO
USE THEM FOR THIS PURPOSE. OKAY
IT SEEMS TO ME AT LEAST THAT.
YOU YOU'RE VIOLATING THE SPIRIT
OF WHAT THE PURPOSE OF THE
PROTECTIONS WORD THAT. YOUR
PROTECTING THE FUNDS BUT THEN
ANY INTEREST EARNED OFF THAT
FUNDS YOU'RE NOW DIVERTING- IT
SEEMS TO ME THAT THAT'S NOT
WHAT- CALIFORNIA. RESIDENTS
EXPECTED OF- THE PROTECTION OF
THE STATE HIGHWAY ACCOUNT BUT
DOES THE STATE PLAN ON PAYING
BACK THESE TRANSPORTATION FUNDS
AT A LATER DATE AND IF SO. WHEN
WOULD THAT BE. SO NOW- THE
PROPOSAL IS TO- TO TRANSFER
THESE FUNDS PERMANENTLY- THAT
FROM THE STATE HIGHWAY ACCOUNT-
AND- IT YES. THE LA MENTIONED
THERE'S ALSO FUNDING FROM THE
TRAFFIC CONGESTION RELIEF FUND
WHICH ACTUALLY WAS TRANSFERRED
FROM THE GENERAL FUND- BACK IN
THE EARLY TWO THOUSAND. SO BOTH
OF THOSE ARE TRANSFERS- WE DO
HAVE- ONE PROPOSAL FOR TWENTY
TWO MILLION DOLLAR LOAN FROM
THE- OF INNER AERONAUTICS
FUNDING. AND THE LOCAL AIRPORT
ON ACCOUNT. SO JUST TO BE CLEAR
THE ADMINISTRATION DOESN'T
PROPOSED. PAYING BACK ANY OF
THOSE TRANSFERS FROM THE STATE
HIGHWAY COUNT. THAT ONCE IT'S
BEEN TRANSFERRED THE GENERAL
FUND. YES THAT IS CORRECT WE DO
NOT. OKAY IT'S VERY TROUBLING-
TO HEAR THAT AND I JUST THINK
THAT- THAT SOMETHING THAT I
THINK BREAKS THE PROMISE THAT
THAT THE LEGISLATURE MADE TO
TAKE IN THE ADMINISTRATION THE
PREVIOUS ADMINISTRATION BATES-
TO- CALIFORNIANS WHEN THEY SAID
THEY WOULD. WOULDN'T DIVERT I
GUESS SIX DOLLARS- MOVING TO
THE TO- MAYBE TO RESET CAN
ANSWER THIS IN REGARDS TO-
THOUGH THOSE IN TODAY THE WATER
THE WILL THAT THE STATE WATER
PROJECT- AND- THE WATER BUDGET-
I KNOW. THAT THERE WAS A I
REQUEST TO. SHE ALLOCATE A
MILLION DOLLARS FOR COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH SUING THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT ON THE
BIOLOGICAL PINIONS- THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL IS SUING THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT OVER THAT
AND THEN IN AND NOW I GUESS
YOU'RE ASKING. FOR ADDITIONAL
FUNDS IT SEEMS TO ME THAT
THERE'S THE STATE'S ASKING FOR.
IT STATES SUING DEVELOPMENT
TWICE IS A POSSIBLE TO SAVE THE
MILLION DOLLARS- BUT I'M CENTER
STAND WHY. THE STATE'S ASKING
FOR MILLION DOLLARS TO SUE THE
GOVERNMENT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AND THEN THEY TURN
GENERAL ALSO IS SUING THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO AND IF I
IF I COULD ASK YOU TO PAUSE
BEFORE YOU ANSWER THAT
QUESTION- WILL GIVE YOU TIME TO
CHECK ABOUT YOUR RESPONSE FOR A
MOMENT- I'M GOING TO UPDATE THE
PUBLIC WITH THE- INFORMATION.
THE PHONE NUMBER THAT- HAD THAT
I HAD DOES STATE BEFORE IS THE
CORRECT PHONE NUMBER SO
877-692-8957 IS THE NUMBER YOU
WANT TO CALL IN ON. BUT THE
ACCESS CODE MAKE A NOTE OF THIS
IS. ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR TWO
ZERO TWO. AGAIN ONE THREE ONE
FIVE. FOUR TWO ZERO TWO AND-
HOPEFULLY THAT'LL RESOLVE ANY
PROBLEMS THAT FOLKS WERE HAPPEN.
THANK YOU SORRY FOR THE
INTEREST. THANK CHAIRMAN. THANK
YOU THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION
YES THE ONE MILLION DOLLARS IN
COST IS RELATED TO THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S COST- THAT ARE AT.
BEATING HEARD GIVEN THE AG'S
OFFICE IS WORKING ON BEHALF OF
THAT CALIFORNIA NATURAL
RESOURCES AGENCY AS WELL AS
KELLY. SO NOT AT A DUPLICATION
OF COSTS THAT NEARLY EIGHT THAT
THE PROCESS IS VERY FOR THOSE
AGENCIES TO WORK WITH THE OJ ON
THIS MATTER OKAY SO THE MILLION
DOLLARS IS FOR THE FOR THE
LITIGATION TO FORD AND FORT
FORCE ENTIRETY REFERRED. TO AND
TO TELL THE- I DON'T KNOW THAT
I CAN SAY IN TOTALITY IS OUR
OUR ESTIMATE IS THAT THE
LITIGATION BUT IT IS FOR BOTH
OF THE AGENCIES OR ALSO
COORDINATING ON THIS SO IT IS
A- COORDINATED EFFORT SURE. I
MEAN. I JUST TO BE CLEAR I MEAN
I BELIEVE THAT THIS. WHOLE
LITIGATION ON THE BIOPSY IS
UNNECESSARY THAT. THE THAT THE
STATE AND THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT SHOULD BE WORKING
TOGETHER- TO DEVELOP- SOME TYPE
OF STRUCTURE THAT ALLOWS THE
FEDERAL BIOPSY BE INCLUDED AND
AN OPERATIONAL. I MEAN SO. IT
SEEMS TO ME THAT THIS IS A
WASTEFUL COSTS IF WE CAN HAVE
THE STATE AND THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT WORK TOGETHER. TO
FINALIZE THE BIOLOGICAL PINIONS
ME IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION OF
WITHDRAWING THE LITIGATION- SO
THAT THE MILLION DOLLARS COULD
BE SAVED. BUT THERE'S NO
PROPOSAL AS OR THIS DOES NOT
REFLECT ANY PROPOSAL TO
WITHDRAW THE LITIGATION IT.
LITIGATION INVOLVES MULTIPLE
STATE AND FEDERAL AGENCIES- AND
SO IT IS EXPECTED TO BE PRETTY
PRETTY TECHNICAL. AND INVOLVED
MASSIVELY NOTICE ON THEM AND
DISAPPOINTED THAT WE DON'T HAVE
THE AGENCY HEADS- TESTIFYING IN
AND SO I UNDERSTAND YOU'RE NOT
IN A TOUGH POSITION TRYING TO-
EXPLAIN I'LL A NUMBER OF THINGS
THAT THE AGENCIES ARE DOING
BUT- THIS CAN YOU. IT MAY AND
IN DISCUSSINGTHE THIS TOPIC
WITH THE AGENCIES CAN YOU EXT.
KIND OF EXPLAIN TO ME OR TO THE
TO THE COMMITTEE WHY THE STATE
CHOSE TO ABANDON. THE
COLLABORATIVE APPROACH TRYING
TO- GET TO VOLUNTARY AGREEMENTS
TRYING TO FIND A WAY TO-
DEVELOP A COLLABORATIVE OF
BIOLOGICAL OPINION IN IN STAG
GOING WITH LITIGATION. LET ME
TRY T GET BACK TO YOU ON A
LITTLE BIT MORE OF AND PERHAPS
WHAT BACKGROUND OR HISTORY LED
US TO THIS PART OR TO THIS
POINT SO I CAN. WORK WITH THE
AGENCIES TO FOLLOW UP AND SEE
WHAT WE CAN GET TO BUDGET
COMMITTEE STAFF TO. YEAH WE CAN
DO TO ADDRESS THAT QUESTION
OKAY I MEAN I CERTAINLY WOULD
SAY THAT THE VOLUNTARY
AGREEMENTS AND- OF. A BETTER
COLOR. PROCESS AND- OF
APPROVING THE FEDERAL OF
FEDERAL BIOLOGICAL OPINIONS AS
WELL AS- A CLEAN INCIDENTAL
TAKE PERMIT. WOULD HAVE.
PROVIDED A MORE LASTING AND
COMPREHENSIVE SOLUTION TO THE
WATER CHALLENGES OF CALIFORNIA
AND WE WOULD TO BE SOMETHING WE
WOULD BE SAVING A MILLION
DOLLARS TO SO- IF THAT
SOMETHING THAT. YOU COULD KIND
OF SHED SOME LIGHT ON WHY THE
GOVERNOR CHANGES PRIORITIES- I
CERTAINLY WOULD APPRECIATE
THAT. I AND LASTLY AND I KNOW
THAT WORD BUT WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE'RE ON SINCE AT THE
TIME. I IN TERMS OF THE PARKS-
BUDGET. I NOTICED THAT. THAT
WOULD BE. THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND ITS ANALYSIS
SAYS THAT THERE IS A BILLION
DOLLARS IN DEFERRED. PARK
MAINTENANCE COSTS AND MAYBE
THIS IS A QUESTION FOR THE LA
SO- AND THEN FOLLOWED UP BY THE
DEPARTMENT AS IF THEY WANT TO
FOLLOW UP. SO IT SEEMS
INTERESTING TO ME THAT. FROM
BUDGETARY PRIOR STANDPOINT. THE
ADMINISTRATION IS PROPOSING TO.
NOT DEAL WITH THE DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE BUT THEN AT THE
SAME TIME EXPAND GENERAL FUND
DOLLARS TO. PUT A NEW PARK IN
AND TO EXPAND EXISTING PARKS-
AT A TIME WHEN WE PROBABLY NEED
TO FOCUS ON THE FOR PAYMENTS
AND AT THE SAME TIME- THE
GOVERNOR'S INDICATED THAT THEIR
TRIGGER CUTS TO TEACHERS AND
FIRST RESPONDERS I WOULD THINK
THAT YOU WOULD. TAKE THAT THOSE
FUNDS AND EVEN PUT IT TO THAT
CAN CAN DALY ARE KIND OF TALK
ABOUT THAT. THAT'S RIGHT THE
BUDGET THE NAY REVISION
INCLUDES FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
FOR THE ESTABLISHMENT OF A NEW
PARK- RIGHT NOW WE DO NOT HAVE
A PROPOSAL SPECIFIC PROPOSAL
FOR WEBSITE THAT WOULD BE- OR
WHAT THE ONGOING OPERATIONS AN
IMPROVEMENT COST WOULD BE. FOR
ANY SITE- AS THAT WE'RE
RECOMMENDING REJECTING IT AND
AS YOU KNOW MISTER FONG THE-
PARKS DEPARTMENT DOES HAVE A
LONG LIST OF DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE. THAT HAS NOT BEEN-
COMPLETED CRUDE OVER NUMBER OF
YEARS. AND THE LETTER. AND
YEARS OF THE MORE FOR THE AND
IN A- PROPOSITION SIXTY EIGHT
INCLUDES FUNDING TO ADDRESS-
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE IN STATE
PARKS AND SO THAT MAY REVISED
DOES IN FACT INCLUDE SOME
FUNDING FOR THAT- BUT
ULTIMATELY- IT WILL NOT ADDRESS
THE MAJORITY OF THAT ON GOING.
PROBLEM. YEAH I DID IT. DOESN'T
QUITE MAKE SENSE IN OUR MY- TO
ESTABLISH A NEW PARK WITH A
ACOSTA SHE WE THEY'RE OTHER
CUTS BEING PROPOSED OKAY WHAT I
AM. HI THAT ON I THINK THAT
THIS IS AN EXAMPLE OF MAYBE
SOME PRIORITIES AND TO BE A
RIPPER REAR- REEVALUATED- IF
WE'RE GOING TO. MAKE THE
PROBLEM WORSE YOU PROBABLY
SHOULD STOP TAKING THE WHOLE
AND MOVE THE MONEY INTO MORE-
CORE CORE FUNCTIONS LIKE
TEACHERS FIRST RESPONDERS-
WE'RE DEALING WITH KIND OF THE
STRUCTURAL PROBLEMS THAT WE
HAVE. I WILL- JUST MAYBE CAN
YOU TALK ABOUT THE TO THE LA
OKAY TALK ABOUT THE- CAPTURE.
AS YOU GOES AND JUST GIVE
REVENUE TO THE CAPTURED BROKE
COMES IN LESS DOES THAT MEAN
ALL THE OTHER PROGRAMS AFTER
THE TOWARD THE END OF THE
PRIORITY LIST DO THEY GET NO
MONEY OR LESS MONEY OR HOW DOES
THAT HOW DOES THAT FUNCTION.
MAYBE THAT AND MAYBE DEPARTMENT
FINANCE CAN SHED SOME LIGHT ON
THE TWO. THANK YOU GEN. YOUR SO
THE WAY THE BUT LANGUAGES. DRY
THEREFORE. THAT ARE PRIORITIZE
FIRST FOR FINDING AS IT COMES
AND- FORCING WILDFIRE
PREVENTION. LOCAL AIR POLLUTION
REDUCTIONS THIS EIGHTY SIX
SEVENTEEN PROGRAMS THE SAFE AND
AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER
PROGRAM AND AGRICULTURAL
EQUIPMENT UPGRADES AND
REPLACEMENT THOSE FOR PROGRAMS.
WOULD BE THE FIRST TO RECIEVE
FINDING AS IT COMES IN FROM THE
AUCTION. AS IS THOUGH AND
THEY'VE AND THE FUNNY BE
PROVIDED PROPORTIONALLY ACROSS
THOSE FOR PROGRAMS. ONCE THOSE
ARE FULLY FUNDED THEN THE OTHER
PROGRAMS ON THE- LIST ON THE IN
THE EXPENDITURE PLAN. WHICH
START RECEIVING FUNDING AND
AGAIN. THOSE WOULD RECEIVE THEM
ON UP ON A PROPORTIONAL BASIS
AS- WITH AVAILABLE- SO GIVE ME
THINK PRIORITIZATION OF SOME
KIND REALLY MAKES SENSE GIVEN
THE HIGH DEGREE BUT OF RATHER.
UNCERTAINTY HERE HM OUR MINDS
ARE OF. HE'D LIKE. MEAN AS A
LEAD. WHAT PROGRAM. ARE IN IN-
WE CAN SURELY HELP YOU
STRUCTURE IT IN WHATEVER WAY.
MAKES MOST SENSE WHETHER IT'S
SIMPLY TO TEAR LIKE THAT WERE
MORE TEARS OF FUNDING- THAT
MAYBE I THE FIRST. TIER OF
PRIORITY SECOND HERE THIRTY
EIGHT NUMBER. DIFFERENT LIKE
YOU COULD STRUCTURE IT. OKAY
THE VERY MUCH CHAIRMAN. THANK
YOU FOR I WANT TO THE IS RANTS
WHO IS ON AVOID DELAYED AND-
GETTING HERE THIS MORE WE HAVE
JUST HER FROM LA AND TO. OF
FOR. AND A BRIEF PRISON EACH
MEMBER HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO
MAKE AN OPENING STATEMENT- IF
YOU WANNA DO THAT NOW OR AFTER
YOU GET SITUATED- OR IF YOU
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS. NOW IS THE
TIME. IF I MAKE. PLEASE THANK
YOU. I THINK IT'S DURING THESE
TIMES. I'M PREDICTABLE TIMES
QUITE FRANKLY THE WE HAVE TO
CONTINUE TO ADVOCATE FOR
COMMUNITIES IN COMMUNITIES LIKE
SAN BERNARDINO AND THERE ARE
OTHERS LIKE SO MY COLLEAGUES
ARE HERE ON THE WHICH CHAIR OF
THE AIR THAT I BREATHE IN MY
COMMUNITY WE REALLY HAVE TO DO
SO MUCH MORE. IN THAT REGARD.
IN TWENTY TWENTY SAMBAR DINO
COUNTY RANKED NUMBER ONE FOR
OZONE POLLUTION. AND NUMBER
FIVE FOR PARTICULAR MATTER
POLLUTION. PEOPLE POINTED OUT
THAT WE'VE NEVER SEEN CLEANER
AIR DUE TO THE STATE HOME
ORDERS. BUT MY CONSTITUENTS ARE
STILL BREATHING THE SAME. SOME
OF THE DIRTIEST AIR IN THE
COUNTRY WE NEED TO BE DOING
MORE TO CLEAN THE AIR FROM THE
DIRTIEST SOURCES AND THAT
INCLUDES LOOKING AT DIFFERENT
FUNDING SOURCES. INSTEAD OF
RELYING ONLY ON. D. G. R. F.
FUNDS DIRTY ERROR IN A PUBLIC
HEALTH IS A IS A PUBLIC HEALTH
HAZARD AND NOW THAT WE ARE
DEALING WITH THIS TEN DE MIKE
IT'S BECOME AN EVEN GREATER
THREAT. STUDIES ARE BEGINNING
TO SHOW THEIR POLLUTION
EXACERBATES THE PROBLEM FURTHER
LEADING TOWARDS INCREASED
DEATHS LINKED TO COBIT NINETEEN.
THIS ISN'T HAPPENING EQUALLY
LATINOS MAKE A 53% OF ALL
POSITIVE TEST CASES IN
CALIFORNIA AND ARE DYING
DISPROPORTIONATELY MORE
COMPARED TO THEIR DEMOCRAT TO
OTHER DEMOGRAPHICS. WE ALSO
NEED TO DOUBLE DOWN ON CLEANING
UP OUR AIR. ARE CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAMS ARE THE
STATE'S TOP CLEAN AIR PROGRAMS
THEY REDUCE EMISSIONS FROM THE
LARGEST SECTOR IN CALIFORNIA
TRANSPORTATION. THE SECTOR
MAKES UP 50% OF ALL THE
MISSIONS IN CALIFORNIA WITH THE
MAJORITY OF THESE EMISSIONS
CONCENTRATED MAINLY. IN
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES AND
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR SUCH AS
THE ONES IN MY DISTRICT. WE
NEED TO CONTINUE TO INVEST IN
REDUCING EMISSIONS AT THE
SOURCE. CLEANING UP THE
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR WOULD
OUGHT NOT ONLY EXCUSE ME CAN
GET MY. CLEANING UP THE
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR WILL NOT
ONLY HELP OUR MOST
DISADVANTAGED BUT ALSO BRING
ECONOMIC ADVANTAGE. TO OUR
ECONOMY. EACH DOLLAR OF PUBLIC
INVESTMENT IN CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION LEVERAGES SIX
DOLLARS AND PRIVATE CAPITAL AND
EVERYONE MILLION DOLLARS
INVESTED BRINGS APPROXIMATELY
SIX TO TEN HIGH WAGE JOBS.
THESE PROJECTS ARE SHOVEL READY
AND ARE WORTHWHILE INVESTMENTS
FOR THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. WE
NEED TO PRIORITIZE THESE
PROGRAMS. WE ALSO NEED TO
PRIORITIZE OUR CURRENT PROGRAMS
LIKE AB SIX SEVENTEEN WHICH I
WAS PROUD TO CO AUTHOR WITH MY
FELLOW COMMITTEE MEMBER
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CRISTINA GARCIA.
THE MAY REVISION PROPOSES A
PRIORITY LIST OF PROGRAMS TO BE
FUNDED FROM THE G. G. R. F.
WITH A NEGLIGIBLE POTENTIAL FOR
ALL OTHER PROGRAMS TO BE FUNDED
PROPORTIONALLY. UNLESS EXCESS
REVENUES ARE REALIZED DURING
THE QUARTERLY OPTIONS. GIVEN
THE TRAGIC CONSEQUENCES THAT
ARE QUALITY HOUSE ALREADY HAD
ON THE HEALTH OF THESE
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES
COMMUNITIES LIKE MINE. AND THE
CORRELATION BETWEEN POOR AIR
QUALITY AND IT INCREASE IN
COVERT DEATHS IT IS ESPECIALLY
CLEAR THAT FUNDING AB SIX
SEVENTEEN AND CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAMS OR MORE
VITAL THAN EVER. I AM HOWEVER A
HAPPY TO SEE THAT THE REFORMS
OF THE DEPARTMENT OF TOXIC
SUBSTANCE CONTROL HAS BEEN KEPT
IN THE MAY REVISE. THESE ARE
REFORMS THAT HAVE LONG BEEN
DISCUSSED AND ARE LONG OVERDUE.
WITH ROBUST AND GET ENGAGEMENT
FROM THE LEGISLATURE IN THE
COMMUNITY. THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL MAY REVISE REFLECTS
NECESSARY STEPS TO ENSURE THE
FISCAL SOLVENCY OF THIS AGENCY.
WHICH IS CRITICAL AS WE LOOK AT
SEVERAL MORE YEARS OF LIMITED
GENERAL FUND RESOURCES.
CONTINUE TO WORK TO CLEAN UP
TOXIC SITES ISN'T JUST GOOD FOR
THE HEALTH OF NEARBY
COMMUNITIES. IT COULD ALSO
PROVIDE MEANINGFUL JOBS IN THE
ECONOMIC RECOVERY. I WILL HAVE
SOME QUESTIONS LATER BUT I
WANTED TO JUST GIVE MY OPENING
STATEMENT AT THIS TIME. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- JUST TO BE CLEAR
WE'RE GOING TO BE COMPLETING
OUR QUESTIONS BY ELEVEN THIRTY
MINUTES RARE SO- GET YOUR
QUESTIONS READY. ALL RIGHT OF A
LOT OF TIME LEFT- ANYONE ELSE
HAVE QUESTIONS AT THIS TIME. IS
GARCIA. THANK YOUNG TO SOMEONE.
QUESTION FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF.
FIND I APPRECIATE THAT WE ARE
AT OR IF THEY- PRIEST REFER FOR
THE SEE TO. LONG TERM DEAL WITH
STRUCTURAL DEFICIT THAT WE HAVE
A TOUGH GUY AND HAS OR IS
CONTROLLED. FUNDS BOB. IN THE
GRADE STEPS. NOR ANY ROOF THAT
ADVICE. INDUSTRY ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE WITHOUT ASK FOR TO
ENSURE THAT WE NOT ONLY CLOSE
THE STRUCTURAL BUT THAT WE HAVE
A DEPARTMENT THAT'S MORE
RESPONSIVE. AND BETTER PROTECT
IN OUR PUBLICS HOW AND SO
WANTED TO KNOW HOW WE JUSTIFY
THE LEVEL INCREASES THAT WE'RE
HAVING WITHOUT THE AN
ADDITIONAL REFORMS TO THE- WHEN
THERE ARE PROPOSALS OUT THERE
THAT HAVE BEEN WORKED ON AND
BETTER FOR THE LAST FOUR YEARS.
THANK YOU MISTER MULLIN
QUESTIONS. THE THREE OF US. I
JUST WANTED TO EXPRESS AN ADD
ON TO THE CONCERNS THAT- MY
COLLEAGUES- DISCUSSED ABOUT AB
SIX SEVENTEEN IMPLEMENTATION-
YOU DON'T I HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT
THE LACK OF IMPLEMENTATION
FUNDING AND I ALSO OBJECT TO
THE GOVERNOR PROPOSING TO TAKE
POLLUTION CONTROL FUND MONIES
AND- THEM. FROMAIR POLLUTION
PURPOSE THIS WAS A SOURCE
THIRTY MILLION IN AND FUND FOR
A BI SEVEN LAW YEAR. AND A
SHOULD BE A THE. FOR THE
PURPOSE AND THIS YEAR SO WANTED
TO ADD ON A. I DO WANT TO KNOW
WHAT CRITERIA THE
ADMINISTRATION USED TO DECIDE
WHICH AIR QUALITY PROGRAMS TO
PRIORITIZE. GIVEN THE
DISPROPORTIONATE EMISSIONS FROM
THE TRANSPORTATION SECTOR IT
REMAINS CONCERNING AS I
MENTIONED IN MY OPENING
COMMENTS THAT LOW CARBON
TRANSPORTATION ISN'T IN THAT
CATEGORY. MS MS RICE I WANT TO-
CLARIFY THAT WE MAY NOT BE
GETTING ANSWERS AT THE HEARING
TODAY THEY MAY COME TO US- IT
THERE THERE MAY BE A AN ANSWER
TO QUESTION SO WE CAN SEE BUT-
YOU MISSED MY OPENING STATEMENT
WHERE I LAY DOWN SOME OF THE
GROUND RULES THAT UNFORTUNATELY
WE'RE OPERATING UNDER TODAY.
AND DOES THAT IS- THE STAFF IS
PRESENTING TO US TODAY. FRANKLY
DOESN'T HAVE ALL THE ANSWERS
BECAUSE THEY DON'T REPRESENT
THE INDIVIDUAL DEPARTMENTS
THERE'S- OVER FORTY
DEPARTMENTS- THAT THAT WE
OVERSEE AND- BUDGET SUB THREE
AND SO THEY COULD ALL BE
AVAILABLE- AND COORDINATED TO.
MAKE IT HAPPEN TODAY BUT THEY
WILL GET BACK TO YOU WITH
ANSWERS IF THEY'RE NOT ABLE TO
STAY.IT DEPENDS ON THE ENEMY
BUT NO ONE I WANT TO HELP THIS
DEPRIVE. THAT MS REYES AND
FINISH I JUST WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE. WHEN WE HAD HAND
UP. IT IN THE MAY OCT. I
UNDERSTAND THE GOING TO IN HOW
MUCH CAP AND REVENUE THE
LEGISLATURE WILL BE ABLE TO
APPROPRIATE BUT I WANTED TO SEE
IF WE NINE HOW MUCH CAN AND
TRADE REVENUE KERR OF A NOW. I
ASK THIS BECAUSE- EVEN BEFORE
KOBE THE GOVERNOR'S JANUARY
BUDGET PROVIDED WOEFULLY
INADEQUATE FUNDING FOR CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION LEAD LIKE TO
KNOW. IF WE ARE ABLE TO RELY ON
TEACHER R. F. FOR THESE
PROGRAMS. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR. THANK YOU MISTER
PATTERSON SURE IN THE INTEREST
OF SORT OF MOVING ALONG- AB ONE
QUICK. COMMENT THAT ALONG WITH
THE MEMBER- OF THE FONG WITH
RESPECT TO- THE UP THE ROAD
FUND AND- SWEEPING OUT THE
INTEREST. AND I FIND THAT I
FIND THAT REALLY TO BE A- KIND
OF THE LOOPHOLE CREATING
SOMETHING- THAT I THINK IS A IS
A TERRIBLE PRECEDENT- THE
INTEREST EARNINGS ARE THE
DIRECT FRUITS OF. THE FUN AND I
THINK IT IS IF NOT EXPRESSLY-
SOMETHING THAT THAT THAT THAT
THE ENTRY SHOULD BE USED FOR
ITS CERTAINLY HAS IMPLIED. WITH
THE WAY THAT IT IS A DIRECT
FRUITS UP OF THE ORIGINAL
DEPOSITS SO I WOULD I WOULD
HAVE SOME OBJECTION. WITH
RESPECT TO THE MY QUESTIONS
ABOUT THE DTC H. WE DON'T HAVE-
THE DIRECTORS HERE OR
AVAILABLE- WHAT I'D LIKE TO DO
IS GET A COMMITMENT. THAT I IN
MY OFFICE WILL BE ABLE TO MEET
AND HOWEVER HE TO IT WITH THE
DTH PEOPLE SICK PEOPLE MY
COUNTY IS VERY CONCERNED WE
HAVE A LOT OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
STILL TRYING TO GET PERMITS IN
ORDER TO HANDLE. ROSS THESE
HAZARDOUS WASTES AND THE A
STRING OF CONCERN THAT I DO
THINK OF BEING ADDRESSED AND I
WOULD LIKE TO RAISE THEM
DIRECTLY WITH THE- DEPARTMENT
CAN I GET A COMMITMENT. TO THAT
END. HELLO IS THERE ANYBODY
THAT CAN GIVE ME. AN ANSWER HI.
THERESA CALVERT WITH DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. I AM ON THE
DIGESTIVE YES I JUST SPOKE WITH
A REPRESENTATIVE FROM THAT
CALIFORNIA BERMAN PROTECTION
AGENCY SO WE WILL MAKE SURE TO
CONNECT AND MAKE SURE THAT YOUR
OFFICE IS- SPECIFICALLY WITH
THE TNC. WHAT DEPARTMENT TOXIC
SUBSTANCE CONTROL YEAH YES WE
HAD NOT BEEN WITH. ENOUGH TIME
RESERVE FOR ME BE ABLE TO GO
THROUGH. THE SPECIFICS OF THIS
AND GET SOME. SPECIFIC KINDS OF
ANSWERS. YES I MEAN WE WILL
MAKE SURE AND I KNOW THE AGENCY
WILL MAKE SURE TO COORDINATE
THAT AS AS NEEDED- TO SUIT YOUR
NEEDS AND TO BE ABLE TO ADDRESS
OUR QUESTIONS I'LL I'LL LOOK
FORWARD TO THAT THEN THANK OKAY
I IF I IF I MAY IT'S GOING BACK
TO ONE OF EARLIER FOR ON YOU
FROM US AND MEMBER GRAY. AND WE
DO HAVE THE GOVERNANCE
COMPONENT OF THE DETAILS HE
REFORM PROPOSAL THAT DOES- HAVE
THE NEW PROPOSED BOARD
PROVIDING STRATEGIC GUIDANCE TO
THE DEPARTMENT DIRECTOR AS AS
AN- COM. AT INPUT FROM OTHERS
AND OUTS OF THE DEPARTMENT
WANTED TO ALSO. A POINT THAT
OUT RESPONSE QUESTION. THANK
YOU I'M AWARE THAT I MY WAS
THAT NOT A- AND THEY MADE MORE
ASK THAT WE NEED TO REFORM AND
APPROVAL FOR THAT BEEN BETTER
FOR THE LAST FOUR YEARS THAT WE-
HOPE. WE LOOK AT AS YES US TO.
FEES ON CLOSE THE STRUCTURAL
DEFICIT. VAGUELY AB. NINE NINE
FIVE. THANK YOU ARE I WON TO
READ THE THOSE OF YOU WHO. IN
OR NEAR THE CAP THAT HAVE SET
UP OUT IN CAP PARK A MICROPHONE
FROM WHICH YOU CAN- GIVE UP ALL
YOUR PUBLIC COMMENTS AND WILL
BE TURNING TO OF VERY SHORTLY
I'M WEARING CAPITOL PARK IS
THE- MICROPHONE AGAIN. SOME OF
THE- ART BY THE EAST STEPS. SO
IF YOU'RE OUT. THAT'S AN EASY
WAY AND- A LITTLE BIT OF AN
EXPERT HERE THE MORNING WOULD
LIKE TO SEE HOW IT WORKS-
PLEASE FIND YOUR WAY TO THE
EAST STEPS IF YOU'D LIKE TO
GIVE. PUBLIC COMMENT AT THAT
TO- MICROPHONE STATION. I HAVE
FOR- JUST A COUPLE OF-
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS- THAT I'D
LIKE TO ADD TO THOSE THAT I
MADE EARLIER- I AM CONCERNED
ABOUT THE- SIX POINT TWO
MILLION DOLLARS THAT IS-
EXPANDING- THE LAND. AT THIS
FOR LAND MANAGEMENT EXPANSIONS
AND I'D LIKE MORE INFORMATION
ABOUT THE RATIONALE BEHIND THE-
OF THE BUDGET PROPOSAL. AND IN
ADDITION THE FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS. OF THAT IS PROPOSED
FOR ACQUISITION OF A NEW PARK
THIS REMAINS SO. SOMETHING
THAT- I FIND A BIT TROUBLING
BECAUSE THE- INFORMATION ABOUT
WHAT THAT MONEY WILL BE USED
FOR OTHER THAN THE FACT THAT
IT'S- GENERICALLY ACQUISITION
OF A PARK- IS. BASICALLY
NONEXISTENT- THIS IS A-
OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE IT IS OUR
RESPONSIBILITY TO LOOK AT THESE
PROPOSED ALLOCATIONS AND
UNDERSTAND WHAT THEY'RE FOR AND
WHAT THEY'RE ABOUT I WITHOUT
HAVING THE LEAST INFORMATION
ABOUT- WHERE THIS PARK IS GOING
TO BE WHAT THE PLAN FOR THE
PARK IS WHAT THE TOTAL
ACQUISITION COST IS GOING TO
BE- THERE ARE SO MANY
QUESTIONS- WE MIGHT ASK AND WE
HAVE LITERALLY- ZERO
INFORMATION. OTHER THAN THAT
EVERYBODY WANTS NEW PARKS SO I
DON'T QUESTION THE- THE INTENT
BEHIND THE- OF THIS A BUDGET
ALLOCATION BUT I DO THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE HAVE MORE
INFORMATION AND HOPEFULLY THAT
WILL BE FORTHCOMING AND I'M-
WITH TO. MAKE THAT REQUEST ON
THE PART OF THE ENTIRE
COMMITTEE. OF THAT SAID IF
THERE ARE NO ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MEMBERS OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE FOR- ALLOWING US
TO- WRAP UP THIS PART OF THE
HEARING ABOUT TWENTY MINUTES
EARLY ALLOWING MORE TIME. FOR
THE PUBLIC TO BE HEARD AND SO
WE WILL BEGIN THE FIRST HEARING
PUBLIC COMMENT FROM- FROM I
THINK I ANNOUNCED EARLIER FROM
INSIDE THE ROOM HERE SO IF YOU
ARE. HERE IN THE ROOM AND WOULD
LIKE TO MAKE A COMMENT PLEASE
MAKE YOUR WAY TO. THE
MICROPHONE THAT I THINK YOU
KNOW WHERE THERE IS. A DEAL. WE
HAVE. THAT ON. IT IS WE MR MR
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MARK SMITH
ON BEHALF OF A RIDE OF CLIMB ON
A OF TOPIC. I'LL TRY TO GET
THIS BRIEF IN A NEW FORM YOU
HAVE TO KEEP IT BRIEF BECAUSE
WE'RE TO LIMIT YOUR ONE MINUTE
CORRECT AND I'M TAKE THAT TIME
SO MY CLIENTS ARE TO THE EIGHT
A FUN WOULD YOUR ADDRESS
EARLIER I WANT TO READ OFF TO
THE NO OTHER WILL BE SPEAKING
ABOUT THAT IN MORE DETAIL- ALL
POSTS THE SIGMA CUTS PROVIDE BY
THE- SEGMENT TATIAN. IS MOVING
FOR THERE ARE STILL SOME
PLANNING FOR OTHER GSA SO WE
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO KEEP
THAT PROCESS MOVING FORWARD TO
THE GREATEST EXTENT POSSIBLE
CALIFORNIA WATERFOWL
ASSOCIATION PARTICULAR HAS
CONCERNS ABOUT PROPOSITION
NINETY NINE ALLOCATIONS WHICH
GO TO BOTH PARKS IN CDS W. THE
EQUITABLE ALLOCATION OF THAT
FUNDING IS OF CONCERN TO US WE
TALKED SUSAN TALK SERGIO. TO
STATION. BOB ON THE FUNDS THAT
ARE. BE SPENT ON WATER FOR
PROUD. IT'S NOT ALL AND DOOM
THERE ARE TWO THAT WE SAW. THE
WHY JUST WOULD LIKE TO LET YOU
KNOW ABOUT IT THERE SO FOR THIS
WATER. CONTROL BOARD'S B. C. P.
ON THE WATER RESILIENCE
PORTFOLIO. THIS DIRECTLY
IMPACTS OF WATER STORAGE
INVESTMENT PROGRAM AND
PROPOSITION ONE. IT'S IMPORTANT
TO KEEP THOSE PROJECTS MOVING
FORWARD AS WELL. THE COASTAL
CONSERVATION ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA WOULD LIKE TO
EXPRESS THEIR SUPPORT FOR CITY
OF DOUBLE BC. PARTICULARLY
RELATED TO THE OCEAN RESOURCES
ENHANCEMENT HABITAT PROGRAM.
FINALLY I'D LIKE TO CLOSE BY
SAYING ALL OF MY CLIENTS.
UNIVERSALLY SUPPORT ONGOING
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT SOME SORT
OF A BOND. I KNOW THAT THAT
DYNAMIC IS CHANGED. BUT WE
APPRECIATE THE MISTER GARCIA
CONTINUES TO MOVE IS PROPOSAL
FORWARD THANK YOU DON'T KNOW
WHETHER THAT YOU COME A
STIMULUS OR SOME COMBINATION
BUT THERE ARE SHOVEL READY
PROJECT TIME IS EXPIRED AND I.
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS THANK
YOU. YOU'RE GONNA CAN
EXPERIENCE THE STRICT RICHARD
BLOOM TODAY. WELCOME GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE LARA KNOWING TJ
ON BEHALF OF VARIOUS
AGRICULTURAL ASSOCIATIONS AND
COMMISSIONS FIRST ONE TO POINT
OUT THE STATE WATER RESOURCES
CONTROL BOARD HAS THREE BC
PIECE THAT WOULD ADD TWENTY SIX
NEW POSITIONS THAT THEY WERE
NOT REQUESTING IN THE JANUARY
BUDGET TO THESE THAT HAVE ADDED
TO EIGHTEEN PERMANENT POSITIONS
WHAT BE FUNDED BY AN INCREASE
IN PERMIT FEES AS YOU KNOW
AGRICULTURE AS WELL AS OTHER
BUSINESSES HAVE BEEN SEVERELY
IMPACTED BY KOBE IT ACTS ALSO
LOOKING AT YOUR IMITATION IT'S-
THAT. MIGHT SHOW UP TO A
MILLION WITH A OF THESE TWO.
WITH DROUGHT WITH CUT IN WATER
SUPPLY WE DON'T THINK IT'S
APPROPRIATE FOR THE STATE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD TO
INCREASE PERMIT FEES. ON
INDUSTRY THAT MAYBE SHRINKING-
ALSO- SUPPORT THE
PRIORITIZATION OF ACTING SO
REPLACEMENT AND SAFE DRINKING
WATER- MORE FUNDING IS NEEDED
SO WE WILL BE WORKING WITH YOU
IN THE ADMINISTRATION ON THAT-
BUT WOULD LIKE TO ALSO POINT
OUT THE STATE WATER BOARD IS.
LOOKING AT FORTY EIGHT NEW
POSITIONS TO SAFE DRINKING
WATER. BECAUSE OF THE PAGE YOU
GO WE JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THAT'S NOT TAKING TOO MUCH
OF THAT SAFE DRINKING WATER
FIND. THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ANYONE ELSE. WHO WANTS
FOR. CUSTOMER FROM INSIDE. THE
ROOM. PUBLIC COMMENT FROM
INSIDE THE ROOM LIKE SEEING NO
ONE NOW ARE WE- TO THE- HI
WELCOME SIR. OUT IN THE WEEK
SEE. AT THREE BEHIND YOU. HOW
YOU. TAKE GOOD MORNING CHIU AND
MEMBERS. MICHAEL PAYMENTS WITH
THE CALIFORNIA TRANSIT
ASSOCIATION THE MAY REVISE
PROVIDES AND FORTUNE USE FOR
TRANSIT AGENCIES AS FALLING
SALES TAX RECEIPTS A ROAD THE
FUNDING STREAMS AVAILABLE FOR
PUBLIC TRANSIT TO BE CLEAR
THESE AREN'T FUNDING REDUCTIONS
PROPOSED BY GOVERNOR NEW SOME
BUT RATHER THE NATURAL RESULT
OF DECREASED ECONOMIC ACTIVITY.
AS AN INDUSTRY WE CONTINUE TO
ADVOCATE FOR JUST NO
SUPPLEMENTAL FUNDING FROM THE
FEDERAL FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO
ADDRESS TRANSIT FUNDING NEEDS
THAT WAS OUR PAST MERGES THE
FUNDING CONGRESS ALREADY
PROVIDED TO PUTTING CAR TAX THE
LA. KOBE AREA ANTICIPATE THREE
MEAN DOLLARS IN ADDITIONAL NEED
AND THE STATE FIGURE IS LIKELY
MUCH HOT. GEN THE FEDERAL AND
IS FAR SURE AND YOU IF IT DOES
THAT. CALIFORNIA TRANS AGENCIES
MAY STILL FACE HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN
OUTSTANDING NEEDS IT MAY BE
SOME SOON IMPERATIVE THAT THE
STATE TAKE ADDITIONAL ACTIONS
TO SUPPORT. TRANSIT AGENCIES
AND TO SUPPORT ECONOMIC
RECOVERY WE KNOW THAT YOU'VE
GOT MANY COMPUTING NEEDS
HOWEVER WE JUST WANT TO REMIND
YOU THAT TRANSIT HAS ALWAYS
BEEN A TRIPLE BOTTOM LINE
INVESTMENT. IT CREATES GOOD
PAYING JOBS IT SUPPORTS
ENVIRONMENTAL AND AIR QUALITY
GOALS AND IT BUILDS  MORE
EQUITABLE CALIFORNIA AND IT'S
HERE I JUST WANT TO RECOGNIZE.
THAT TODAY TRANSPORTATION SEES
ARE EXCLUSIVELY MOVING. FROM
EMPLOY WHO LACK OF THEM A ARE.
SAID SHOW THAT MOST OF THESE
EMPLOYEES ARE PEOPLE OF COLOR.
VERY FINALLY WE WAIT FOR
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES WE HAVE
SUBMITTED A SERIES OF STEP
TOWARD RELIEF MEASURES. THAT
WILL SURE THAT TRANSIT AGENCIES
CAN USE THE RESOURCES THE
ARREST HAPPENED A PURPOSES.
HAVE KEEPING SERVICE. THANK WE
THESE CAN BE INCLUDED IN JUNE.
THANK YOU CONSIDER. THANK YOU
AND- YOU JUST MADE HISTORY
YOU'RE THE FIRST PERSON TO.
FIVE WORK. AND THEY WILL ELSE
OUTSIDE IN THE PARK. WELL IT'S
NOT YET THE MOST POPULAR OPTION
FAIRLY WE DO HAVE ANOTHER. GO
AHEAD SIR. HELLO MY NAME IS TOM
STATUS I AM A MEMBER OF THE
SCREEN ACTORS GUILD UNION I'M
JUST HERE TO THANK YOU GUYS
OFFER YOUR SERVICE TO WORK
DURING THIS DIFFICULT TIME AND-
CONTINUE TO DO A GREAT JOB SAYS
ONE TO SAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WHAT YOU GUYS ARE DOING AND
CONTINUE TO DO A GOOD JOB. IT
KIND OF YOU THANK YOU. BECAUSE
WE HAD TO IN ACT APPEAR. OF
ANYONE IN QUE PARK. ALL RIGHT
SO WE'RE GONNA MOVE TO THE-
OTHER PHONE NINE ZERO. AGAIN
THE NUMBER IS. 877-692-8957 AND
THE ACCESS CODE IS. ONE THREE
ONE FIVE FOUR TWO ZERO TWO.
EVERYONE THERE. I FEEL LIKE
THAT- THAT'LL THE TV SHOW
DIALING FOR DOLLARS LESS FOR
WAITING FOR CALLER NUMBER ONE.
HELLO HELLO YES WOULD YOU LIKE
TO GIVE TESTIMONY PLEASE STATE
YOUR NAME AND A PROCEED TO MAKE
YOUR COMMENTS ANY AFFILIATION.
THANK YOU DOCTOR ON BEHALF OF
EVENTS ENERGY ECONOMY IT DOUBLY
STRONGLY SUPPORTS THAT THE
THINKING HERE I FIND ON THE
STATE TRANSPORTATION PROGRAMS
WHERE MAIN CONCERN AT THE
PROGRAMS WILL BE SEVERELY
UNDERFUNDED OR CUT IT A
PRIORITIES LAY OUT IN THE MAIL
REVISED. WE ARE THE LIKE TO
WORK WITH THE GUY OFFICE UNDER
A FUNDING A SOLUTION THAT WOULD
THESE CORRECT INTACT. AS A
PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS RAGES ON
AND IN OWN MISSION AND
INFRASTRUCTURE WILL BE MORE TO
LEAVE YOU EATING RIGHT ENOUGH
FOR WHAT YOU NEEDED AND PUT
EVERY DAY. I YOU KNOW AND THAT
IN CLEAN BUT ARE ALL INVESTED
AN ACTOR BECAUSE- I THINK
RELATING. ECONOMIES AND GROWING
JOB OR RELIEF THE MOST MAN WE
DO SUPPORT THE FIFTY ONE WE
APPROPRIATIONS TO THE INNER
COMMISSION FOR EITHER IMPRESSED.
AT THE IN THE GOVERNMENT
FINALLY WE ENCOURAGE THE LETTER
TO COMPARE ACOSTA A TO. ON THE
I THINK THAT AND SO WITH THAT
TO BUY AND THE POTENTIAL IMPACT
A PRINTER CONNECTED ON PETER
FINE BELIEVE IN THE. TIME
FASTER LIMITED STATE DOLLARS
ARE SPENT WISELY MAXIMUM IMPACT
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU FOR
YOUR COMMENT. NEXT. NEXT WE
WILL GO TO LINE AT THIRTY TWO.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. SOVIET SO SHOCK ON
BEHALF OF THE CAMERA VALLEY AIR
CONTROL DISTRICT SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY BASIC ONE OF THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT AIR QUALITY
CHALLENGES IN THE COUNTRY THE
VALUE COME TO TWENTY OF THE
THIRTY MOST DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES IN THE STATE. WE
GREATLY APPRECIATE THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION HAD CRARY TIED
GIGI FUNDING FOR CLEAN ADD
PEOPLE EQUIPMENT TO THE FARMER.
WE ARE SENDING FOR THE PROGRAM
THE- AT THE FIFTEEN DOLLAR
LEVEL AND XP THE WE ALSO THAT
CAN DO FINE AT THE AB SIX HAVE
PROGRAM ON WE RESPECTFULLY THAT
FIFTY MILLION BE PRIOR TO IN
ALLOCATED FOR LOCAL IMPLEMENT.
OF THE EIGHTY SIX PROGRAM WE I
LOOKED TO CAN THE WITH THE LEAD
TO PLAY AND THE ADMIN THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR CALL THANK
YOU. NEXT LEVEL THAT A LOT
FORTY FIVE. GOOD MORNING MR
MEMBER THIS IS APPEARING FOR
THEM OUT MY FOUND ECHOING THE
CHAIR THAN LIKE CAN AND URGING
IT OVER AGAIN THE HABITAT
CONSERVATION FUND BILL AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF FISH ALLOW DATA.
BUDGET C. P. AND ALSO TO PRO
SUFFICIENT FUND OR SPECIAL
FUNDS TO AVOID FURTHER
HAMPERING THE ABILITY OF THE-
TO ME THAT'S A POOR WHILE
PROTECTION JACK. OUT HALF OF
THE COMMITTEE ALLY WITH FOR AND
THAT'S FOR THE SAFETY WANT TO
FLY JUST HOW CHALLENGE THIS
QUITE THAT HAD BEEN FOR
CALIFORNIA IN ME SCALE FAMILY
FOR. AND HOW THE FEDERAL AND
RELIEF PROGRAM HAVE WORKED SO
HARD TO THE. AT AND- FOLLOWING
PROVISIONS IN THE MAYBE THE
TIME DOLLAR FIRST FARM OFFICE
IN PART OF PROBE THE TWO POINT
SEVEN MILLION FOR ENABLE NORM
DON'T REALLY PROGRAM IS PDF A
ONGOING WORK. BUT ALL TECHNICAL
ADVICE FOR SMALL FARMERS AND WE
WOULD RECOMMEND THAT TO PULL
DOWN MAXIMUM FEDERAL FUNDING
YOU ALLOCATED MILLION DOLLARS
IN EMERGENCY ONE TIME FUNDING
FOR A CALIFORNIA FARM CRISIS
INITIATIVE TO HELP SMALL AND
MEDIUM SCALE FARMERS NAVIGATE
THE COMPLICATED AND FEDERAL
FUNDING PROGRAMS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU. NEXT WE WILL
GO TO LINE. SIXTY NINE. GOOD
AFTERNOON YOUR MEMBERS- TRITON
ON BEHALF OF CLIMBERS ALL WITH
NEARLY 89% OF ALL CALIFORNIANS
LIVING IN URBAN AREAS RESPECT
COMPOUNDING EFFECT FROM WE ARE
BATTLING HELP IMPACTS THIRTY IT
WOULD COVER. IN EXTREME HEAT
ABOUT. THEY NEED TO BEGIN FOR
DEBBIE HEAT WAVE IN THE COMING
MONTHS WE ALSO YOU COMMIT TO
CONSIDER FUNDING FOR THE-
CLIMATE WITH THIS YEAR. SO
YOU'RE NOT CAUGHT FLAT FOOTED
WERE TACKLING A WITH WARTIME
CLIMATE. IT HERE FOR BAYERN
DEFENSE. WE APPRECIATE IF
SOMEONE WILL GOMEZ LOOKING
COMMENTS ABOUT THE IMPACT WE
CAN MAKE BY TURN. THE TREND.
INDUSTRY AND THE IMPACT THAT
HAVE JOB. THREE BY RESIDUAL
CAUGHT. ALL TO CREATE JOBS AND
STIMULATING THE ECONOMY. YES
THE ANYBODY STRATEGY BE
PRIORITIZED BASED ON IMPACT A
CALIFORNIA CAN EMERGE FROM THIS
MOMENT STRONGER THAN EVER THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. BACK
WE WILL THAT ONLINE. SEVENTY
SEVEN ZERO. YEAH HELLO BUT OF
MORGAN KEEN ABOUT HALF OF THEM
THE CAN AND FOR REGIONAL OPEN
SPACE DISTRICT I IN SUPPORT OF
THE GOVERNOR WELCOME TO STAY IN
THE FOUR MILLION FOR GIFT OF
USE CUTTING THE GREEN TAPE
INITIATIVE. IN ADDITIONALLY
ALTHOUGH I RECOGNIZE THAT- CAP
AND TRADE OPTION REVENUES MAY
NOT BE COMING IN AS EXPECTED I
WE ARE CONCERNED ABOUT THE
DIFFICULTY AGING PEOPLE FACE AN
IMPORTANT PROGRAM AND
ORGANIZATIONS WILL FACE A
CLINIC PROJECT. UNDER A PAY AS
YOU GO MORE MODEL AND I ALSO
LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT AND BEACH
YOU'D GATHERED PROJECT FUNDING
FOR W. C. B. THE STATE COSTA
CONSERVANCY DFW. KLAY WE ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE GOVERNOR
DECISION TO WITHDRAW LOCAL. FOR
THE- WORDS TO BOMB THIS YEAR.
DESPITE IS STILL AT ADVANCED
MAGNUM TO BE BONTA YEAR I THINK
AN EXAM. THAT COULD NOT AND
JOBS AND PRODUCE THROUGH THIS
CLUB SECTOR I'M- I WANTED
HIGHLIGHT THE- BY. IN TOGETHER
BY. HOW ARE PORT CALLED THE
ALLOW PEOPLE AND CON IF NOT
TIGHT LIPPED UP. FOR GREEN. I
WOULD HAVE BEEN DELIVERED TO
ALL OF YOU BALANCE MORE THAN
TEN THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED NEW
GREEN JOBS THAT COULD BE
IMMEDIATELY CREATED IN THE BEAR
ALONE BY INVESTING IN READY TO
GO KIND OF BENEFICIAL. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT
WE WILL GO TO LINE THIRTEEN. A
QUORUM ON THE BALLOT CALIFORNIA
ARE WE SUPPORT SAFE AND
AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER OFF
ON THE PHONE FROM PROPOSAL WE
ALSO SUPPORT THE APPROPRIATION
FOR THE SALTON SEA IN THE NEW
RIVER VALLEY SUPPORT THE
FUNDING FOR THE MULTI BENEFIT
FLOOD RECRUITMENT PROJECTS- AND
WE WOULD LIKE TO REQUEST A NINE
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE GENERAL
FUND TO FUND. THE W. R. AND B.
F. W. FOR STOPPING TO PULL THAT
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND LOCAL
AGENCIES OFFICE IS A CLEAN AT
THE F. W. DOES NOT HAVE ANY
STOCK TO REVIEW ANY SICK ON THE
PATIENT PLANS AND- THE
POTENTIAL IMPACTS OF THE PUBLIC
LANDS IN STATE WETLANDS-
LASTLY. WE AGREE ARE WHOLLY
AGREE WITH OTHER CHAIRS OPENING
COMMENTS ON HOW TO CONSERVATION.
OP FIND. WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION'S BILL THAT THE
HAVE COUNTRY PLAN WE SHOULD NOT
BE UNDERMINING TERM THE
AQUACULTURE AND IN SHORT TERM
THANK YOU. NEXT WE WILL GOT
ONLINE. SEVENTY FIVE. IN
SEVENTY FIVE ARE YOU I'M UNIT.
IT. IF YOU HAD BEEN. HELLO GO
AHEAD CHECK I HAD ERIC RARE FOR
THE LOOK AT ME LOOK AT A
COMPANY THAT IMPERIAL COUNTY
AND WE'RE CALLING IN SUPPORT OF
THE FILM THREE AND YOU RIVER
IMPROVEMENT PROGRAM OR
RESIDENTS WHO HAVE BEEN-
RELEGATED TO THE BACK IN OF
THESE ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
ISSUES AND IMPERIAL COUNTY WHAT
THE WORST AIR QUALITY AT LOW AT
COMIC ELEMENT PROGRAM. I THANK
THE GOVERNOR AND THE NAME AND
GOT TO SEE. OR OTHER SUPPORT
AND WE HOPE IT CONTINUES IN THE
BUDGET TO MAKE IT EQUITABLE FOR
OUR COMMUNITY AT LEAST
THROUGHOUT THE REST CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AT. NEXTBOOK ADELINE TWENTY SIX.
HI THERE. YESPERCENT THANK YOU
THANK YOU SO MUCH CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE FOR
HOLDING THIS IMPORTANT HEARING
TODAY DESIREE JONES
REPRESENTING THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY METRO WHERE THE PLANNER
OPERATOR AND BUILDER FOR LH
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE
NETWORK LA METRO CONTINUES TO
PROVIDE TRANSIT SERVICE THE TEN
MILLION PEOPLE THAT LIVE IN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY TRANSIT AGENCIES
ACROSS THE STATE WE NEED TO SEE
SIGNIFICANT OFTEN FAIR REVENUE
AND SALES TAX REVENUES SUPPORT
OUR NATION AND FUNDING. CHECK
YOUR PROJECT. LA METRO IS. A
ONE POINT EIGHT BILLION DOLLAR
LOSS OVER THE NEXT FISCAL YEAR
WE WANT TO URGE THE LEGISLATURE
TO CONTINUE ITS COMMITMENT TO
FUND PUBLIC TRANSIT. BECAUSE IT
IS VITAL TO THE STATE'S ECONOMY
WE'D LIKE TO KNOW CAN YOU TO
INVESTMENT IN INFRASTRUCTURE
WILL REINVIGORATE THE ECONOMY
PROVIDE JOBS FAMILY
IMPROVEMENTS TO THE MOST
CONGESTED REGION IN THE STATE
WHILE MEETING THE STATE CLEAN
AIR GOALS. LASTLY WE FORMALLY
SUPPORT LEAF MEASURES AND
POLICY REFORMS PROPOSED BY THE
CPA THE CALIFORNIA TRANSIT
ASSOCIATION AND THE CONTINUE
PROTECTION OF STATE FUNDS THAT
ARE GETTING THIS. SPECIFICALLY
TO TRANSPORTATION THANK YOU.
AGUIAR-CURRY ALIGN EIGHTEENTH
AT EIGHT ZERO. THANK YOU MISTER
SURE MEMBERS DON CAP KEY WITH
MCCUE CAPTAIN ASSOCIATES ON
BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA COUNCIL
FOR ENVIRONMENTAL AND ECONOMIC
BALANCE. SHE OPPORTUNITY TO
RAISE CONCERNS WITH PROPOSED
GOVERNANCE OF PLANTS TO SCHOOL
REFORM TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
TOXIC SUBSTANCES CONTROL. SB
YOU SPECIFIC POINTS OF CONCERN
INCLUDE AMONG OTHERS TO AVOID.
THE POLITICIZATION OF ANY
PROPOSED BOARD APPOINTMENTS TO
THE BOARD SHOULD BE ASSOCIATE
WITH MORE SPECIFIC EXPERTISE
AND EXPERIENCE ASSOCIATED WITH
HAZARDOUS WASTE HI REMEDIATION
CLEAN UP AND REGULATORY
PERMITTING. ADDITIONALLY THE
FISCAL REFORM PROPOSAL
COMPLEXES. INCREASES FEES FOR
MANY GENERATOR AND COMMITTEES
HE WAS CONCERNED THAT THESE
CHANGES WILL RESULT IN FURTHER
DECLINE A PERMITTED FACILITIES.
THERE IS A DISINCENTIVE TO
RECYCLING USED OIL AND
DIMINISHED CAPACITY OVERALL FOR
CALIFORNIA TO MANAGE ITS OWN
HAZARDOUS WASTE FOURTEEN
GREATER RELIANCE ON EXACTLY HOW
THIS WITH OTHER STATES. FINALLY
WE URGE GREATER SPECIFICITY BE
INCLUDED TO ENSURE COMMITMENT
OF THE BOARD AND APARTMENT TO
ADDRESS DUPLICATIVE REGULATORY
REQUIREMENTS WITH OTHER
AGENCIES. ESTABLISH METRICS FOR
IMPROVED ACCOUNTABILITY AND
TRANSPARENCY AND- DEMOCRACY ONE
TO SCULPT FOR PROTECTING THE
PUBLIC HEALTH AND THE
ENVIRONMENT. WE APPRECIATE THAT
MISS GARCIA AND HER AYE TEAMS
WERE ON. EIGHTY NINE NINE FIVE
IN THE SURE WHAT THEY MEANT.
AND YOU ALL IN ON ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TODD FURTHER FOR AT THE-
THANK YOU. YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT
WILL A LINE EIGHTY. HI IT'S
JOHN KENNEDY WITH THE WORLD REP
THE CALIFORNIA WE ALSO REGRET
COOLEY OPPOSE PTSD IS BECAUSE
GORE FORM PROPOSAL WERE
STRONGLY SUPPORTIVE OF DTS
THESE EFFORTS TO MANAGE
HAZARDOUS WASTE AND UNDERTAKEN
OVERSEE CLEAN UP OF
CONTAMINATED SITES WE
UNDERSTAND THE DUTY AT THE BASE
OF THE SIGNIFICANT STRUCTURAL
BUDGET DEFICIT. BUT AT THE SAME
TIME LOCAL GOVERNMENTS THEY
DIDN'T HAVE CAN FINANCIAL
STRAINS RIGHT NOW AS A RESULT
OF COVERT NINETEEN AND MANY
OTHER NEW STATE PROGRAMS THAT
MITIGATION OF PSP US WHEN WILD
VIRUS WE FEAR THAT THIS
PROPOSAL WILL SIGNIFICANTLY
INCREASE COSTS FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO NOT ONLY DISPOSE
ACOSTA DISPLACED. BUT
ESPECIALLY TO ADMINISTER
EXISTING PROGRAMS FOR THE
COLLECTION AND MANAGEMENT OF
HOUSEHOLD HAZARDOUS WASTE AND
USED OIL ESPECIALLY IN RURAL
COMMUNITIES WE HOPE TO HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK WITH PTSD
TO CREATE A BETTER PROPOSAL
THAT AVOID JEOPARDIZING LOCAL
PROGRAMS AND ON A BETTER AND
HAPPIER NOTE I WANTED TO
EXPRESS OUR SUPPORT FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION'S MAINTENANCE OF
GENERAL FUND AND BOND FUNDING
FOR NEW RIVER IMPORTANT
PROJECTS. TO ADDRESS IT REALLY
REALLY LONG LEGACY OF CROSS
BORDER CONTAMINATION. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TIME TO
THEIR- THANK YOU. NEXT BILL
BOTTOM LINE. EIGHTY ONE. THE
ONE THING IN THIS ACCOUNTABLE
FOR JUST THE COMPATIBILITY
SOCIAL AN ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
ORGANIZATION WORKING WITH
COMMUNITIES AND THE CAN WALKING
AND YOU COULD TELL A VALLEY'S.
THE LETTER EARLY THIS WEEK WITH
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR JEFF
ECONOMIC RECOVERY MAY REVIVE
PROPERLY RECOGNIZES THE NEED TO
PRIORITIZE BOTH PARTIES MICHAEL
THE NINETEEN AUTUMN BEST
PROGRAM CRITICAL THINKING IT
BUT THIS YEAR'S BUDGET MUST BE
MORE AGGRESSIVE IN ITS. VERSION
OF IT JUST AND EQUITABLE. I
HAVE A RECOMMENDED OUR-
IMPACTED THINKS WATER AND PUT
AND ALIGNMENT THE COMMENT MADE
BY MEETING WATERSENSE AND CA
WATER ACT. THE OTHER THE
GOVERNOR FOR PRIORITIZE TEACHER
FUNDING. TO I THANK MAYBE AT
THE TRACTION AND FEATURED
WATER. AND ADDITIONALLY REQUEST
PRIORITIZATION OF THE LOW
INCOME AUTHORIZATION AND
TRANSFORMATIVE. I MAKE MOVIES
PROGRAM. I REQUEST INCREASE
INVESTMENT INTO THE COMMUNITIES
ADVANCED ACTIVE AND BARELY
MSSION TRANSPORTATION CLEAN
ENERGY AFFORDABILITY. AND
EMISSIONS REDUCTION. HE ALSO
BANNED BY THE COMMENTS MADE BY
FAMILY MEMBERS GARCIA I REQUEST
AND RANTS ABOUT CLEANING UP OUR
AIR IN THE IMPACT THAT
COMMUNITIES AND CREATING DAY
FOR FUNDING FOR THAT IN
ADDITION TO FIGURE OUT. LASTLY
WITH THE COURT FUNDING FOR THE
THOUGHT HE FOCUSED ON AIR
QUALITY IN NEARBY COMMUNITIES.
THANK YOU FOR CONSIDERATION
LOOK FOR TALKING LOOK AT
COMMITTEE CONTRACTS AFFECT MY-
THANK YOU. NEXT WE WILL ADELINE
EIGHTY SIX. A GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS KIM DELFINO ON BEHALF
OF DEFENDERS OF WILDLIFE I WANT
TO THANK YOU CARE BLOOM FOR
YOUR EARLIER COMMENT OBJECTING
TO THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSAL REGARDING THE HABITAT
CONSERVATION FUND. THE HABITAT
CONSERVATION FUND- HDF PROVIDES
CRITICAL FUNDING FOR HABITAT IN
PUBLIC ACCESS PROJECTS TO
BENEFIT LOCAL COMMUNITIES AT A
TIME WHEN THOSE COMMUNITIES
NEED ADDITIONAL INVESTMENTS AND
JOB OPPORTUNITIES IF ANY FUNDS
ARE SHIFTED FOR ENOUGH BUDGET
TO FROM THE HABITAT
CONSERVATION FUND IT SHOULD BE
BACK FILLED WITH OTHER FUNDING
SOURCES TO ENSURE THAT WE GOT
CUT OFF POURTANT CHECK FUNDING
FOR THE- COMMUNITY. WERE ALSO
VERY CONCERNED ABOUT THE
SIGNIFICANT REDUCTIONS IN THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF FISH
AND WILDLIFE GENERAL FUND THAT
WILL IMPACT PROGRAM WORK UNDER
THE ALREADY FUNDED AND
UNDERSTAFFED BIODIVERSITY
CONSERVATION PROGRAM WHILE
IMPOSING YOU MANDATED WORK
WITHOUT ANY EXPLANATION HOURS
AS TO HOW THIS FITS INTO THE
OVER ALL SERVICE BASED BUDGET
EFFORT. WE ASK THAT YOU WERE.
THE ADMITTED. EIGHT THE AFTER
BILL. REJECTED THE
ADMINISTRATION DEPARTMENT
OFFICIAL WHILE LIKE TO DATE
OPERATION PCP THAT RELY
CONCERTS. PHD HAPPENED I'M
DOING THE EXTENSION PASSED BY
THE LEGISLATURE LAST YEAR.
APPROPRIATE TWENTY FIVE POINT
ONE MILLION FROM THE GENERAL
FUND TO THE DEPARTMENT FISH AND
WILDLIFE AND ENSURE THAT THE
EIGHTEEN POINT NINE MILLION IS
PROVIDED TO THE HABITAT
pSPECIAL FUNDS WERE SAID. AND
FINALLY DEFENDER STRONGLY
SUPPORTS THE APPROPRIATION
ANIME REVISED FOR THE SAKE
MANAGEMENT PLAN. AND THE NEW
RIVER IMPROVEMENT PROJECT- EACH
TO IT NEEDS TO INVESTMENT
SUPPORT THE IMPLEMENTATION TO
WALK STANDING PROJECT DESIGNED
TO IMPROVE THE PUBLIC HEALTH
ENVIRONMENT AND ECONOMY OF THIS
REGION. AND FURTHER WATER
SECURITY FOR CALIFORNIA THANK
YOU. FILLED OUT ONLINE SEVENTY
THREE. GOOD MORNING STACEY
HEATING RURAL COUNTIES RC RC
AND- WE WOULD LIKE TO OFFER
SUPPORT FOR CONTINUED
PRIVATIZATION OF FUNDING FOR
WILD FIRE MITIGATION OF
PREVENTION ACTIVITIES AND
PARTICULARLY JDRF ALLOCATIONS
PERCENT SB NINE A ONE- WE'RE
ALREADY A DECADE BEHIND IN OUR
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT FIRE
PREVENTION EFFORTS IN
CALIFORNIA AND WE FEEL WE JUST
CAN'T AFFORD ANY DISRUPTIONS
TERM MITIGATION ACTIVITY
PROTECT OUR RESIDENTS OUR WATER
OUR AARON OUT OF LIKE HABITAT
SH AND- WE HOPE THAT. WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO
PRIORITIZE THOSE FUNDS OUT OF
GPRS AND ALSO FOR A BI CAL
FIRE- FUNDING AND- I THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU. WE
ALL GOT A LINE EIGHTEEN THAT'S
ONE EIGHT. GOOD MORNING SHARON
MEMBERS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA NATIVE PLANT SOCIETY
CALIFORNIA REALLY CALIFORNIA
TROUT ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE
FUND YOU KNOW MY LANCASTER I'M
LIMITED IN THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY WE WANTED IT HERE I
THANK THE CHAIR FOR HIS
COMMENTS ON EIGHT YEAH I SHOP
AT THE BEGINNING OF THE HEARING
AND ALIGN OURSELVES. WHAT OTHER
COMMENTS MADE BY DEFENDERS OF
WILDLIFE- YOU TO RETRACT BOTH
IDIOTS CHECKED OPPOSE OLD- AND
ON BEHALF OF A QUORUM LOOKING
OUT OR IS MEMBERS OF THE PARK
NOW COALITION WE WANTED
EXPRESSED AS WE OUTLINED IN A
LETTER SUBMITTED. EARLIER THIS
WEEK BACK WHILE WE DO
APPRECIATE THAT CREATES AND
PROPERTY FIND A LOCAL PARK
PROGRAM YOU. PUTTING THE AN
EIGHTY TWO OH NINE PROGRAM
SUPPORT PROGRAMS ANY WHAT A CO
PROGRAM WE ENCOURAGE ALL I JUST.
CAME THAT I ACT. CONTINUED TO
BE A PRIOR. GIVEN IN PART OF
ALL THAT HASN'T. RESPONSE YEAH.
MEANT HEALTH. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. WE WILL PUT A
LINE FOR. THAT'S ONE FOR. GOOD
MORNING MR OF FOR A LONG LONG
BE HAPPY THE NATURE AND ALSO
INCLUDING COMMENTS ON THE CAL
TROUT TROUT LIMIT SO FIRST
WANTED TO YOU KNOW YOU'VE HEARD
FROM FROM JANUARY H. THE ISSUES
SKIP ONE- WITH REGARDS TO THIS
DESPICABLE GROUND WATER
MANAGEMENT ACT I'M SICK MENTAL
INDIGENOUS CAN IT'S CRITICAL
POINT AND- WE CONTINUE TO BE
HORRIBLE PORTION OF THE JANUARY
PC P. ON SIGMA. THAT WOULD HAVE
DID NINE POINT SIX MILLION FROM
THE GENERAL FUND TO W. R. IN
ORDER FOR STAFFING NEEDS TO
MEET THE STATUTORY OBLIGATIONS
OF SICK MOM AND PROVIDE THE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO LOCAL
AGENCIES SO VERY MUCH TO
SUPPORT THAT HOPEFULLY BEING
ABLE TO MAKE IT BACK TO THE
BUDGET AS WELL. WE ARE VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF THE FIVE NO
DOLLARS THAT WOULD STILL HELD
ON TO IN THE MARRIAGE AND FOR
THE NEW PARK POSITION- I THINK
IT'S STILL STANDS A REALLY
STRONG SIGNAL FOR THE ABILITY
TO- TO EXPAND- OUTDOOR SPACES-
EVEN IN IN LIGHT. OF THE
CURRENT ECONOMIC SITUATION. AND
LASTLY ON BEHALF OF ENERGY
CONSERVANCY CAL TROUT AND
TRAVEL LIMITED. WHAT OFFER OF
OUR SUPPORT FOR THE GREEN TAPE
INITIATIVE- BUT IT MAINTAINED I
MEAN REVISION- IN SUPPORT OF
THE FOUR MILLION DOLLARS- FOR
COULDN'T GREEN TAPE INITIATIVE
THAT'S DESIGNED TO ACCELERATE
THE SCALE AND RESTORATION AT
AT. W. WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH
THE DEPARTMENT FOR YEARS AND
ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT THIS
INITIATIVE MOVING FORWARD- TO
REALLY PUT A FINE POINT ON THAT
YOU KNOW THE- SALMON AREN'T
STEEP DECLINES AND CURRENT.
RATIONS ARE NOT FAST ENOUGH
BECAUSE THE FUNDING PREPPING
MONITORING REGULATORY PROGRAMS.
ARE SIMPLY TOO STYLISH SO
PROJECT LIKE LIKE A GREEN TAPE
INITIATIVE ARE REALLY MEANT TO
IMPROVE EFFICIENCY. SELECT LET
THEM IN ECONOMIC BURDEN ON
AGENCY THE NONPROFIT. WHILE
MAINTAINING THE COMMITTEES TO
AMBER MOST PARTS AND CAN NOW
MORE THAN EVER- DESCRIBE. THE
NEW PRO. THE FRENCH ALL REALITY
THAT BETTER STATES FACING THANK
YOU FOR THE TO PLAY COMES THANK.
NEXT WE WILL GO TO EIGHTY FOUR.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR BLOOM IN MY
OF THE MY IS NOW ABSENT WITH
THE AREA QUALITY MANAGEMENT
DISTRICT IN ALL OUT BY
EXPRESSING MY APPRECIATION FOR
THE PRIVATIZATION OF AB SIX
SEVENTEEN INCENTIVE FUNDING I
IN THE G. G. R. F. BUT I WANT
TO NOTE THAT DEBT FOR INCENTIVE
FUNDING. AND AB SIX SEVENTEEN
IMPLEMENTATION FUNDING IS NOT
CONSIDERED A PRIORITY FOR
FUNDING IN THE G. G. R. OUR APP
IMPLEMENTATION FUNDING FOR
EIGHTY SIX SEVENTEEN
ACCOMPLISHES SEVERAL THINGS IN
OUR MOST- IMPACTED AND
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
PROVIDES MONITORING EQUIPMENT
AND SUPPORT. IT PROVIDES FOR
ACTUAL WORK WITH COMMUNITY
MEMBERS TO LOOK AT AIR
POLLUTION IMPACT IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES AND ALSO FUNDS
EMISSION REDUCTION PLAN AND
THEN LONG TERM- FOLLOW THROUGH
ON- ON GETTING REDUCTIONS FROM
THOSE PLANS BUT ONE THING THAT
ALSO CONCERNING YOU IN THE PAST
IMPLEMENTATION ENDING IS NOT.
BEEN HAS COME OUT OF A
PARTIALLY FROM THE AIR
POLLUTION CONTROL FIND PARK
FROM THE GREENHOUSE. REVENUE
FUND AND WITH THE EIGHT. BEING
TO FUND UP PROGRAM IN THE TNC
THE WATER BOARDED CONCERNING
THAT THAT THIS MAY NOT TO GO TO
ACTUAL WILL ACTUALLY REDUCING
THAT- AIR POLLUTION IMPACTS IN
OUR COMMUNITIES THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU. NEXT WE WILL
ADELINE SIXTEEN THAT'S ONE SIX.
GOOD MORNING WELL WHAT THE
CALIFORNIA CLIMATE IN
AGRICULTURE NETWORK- WE'RE
CERTAINLY GLAD TO SEE THE
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION FUND
FOCUSED PRIMARILY ON CLIMATE
CHANGE INVESTMENT WE JUST HAD
THE HEALTHY SOILS PROGRAM THE
CLAIMS MANAGER CULTURE PROGRAM.
CLOSE AFTER RECEIVING NEARLY
SIX HUNDRED FARMER APPLICATIONS.
OF THE BULK OF WHICH CAME IN
DURING THE PANDEMIC- I AM
CONCERNED THAT THERE MAY
REVISED PROPOSAL ON FUTURE A
LET LET THAT FUN BUT NOT ALL OF
THE CLIMATE CHANGE INVESTMENTS
AND KEEP OUT CRITICAL PROGRAMS
LIKE HEALTHY SOILS. AND OTHER
CLAIMANTS MORE THEIR CULTURE
PROGRAM. WE HOPE THAT THE
LEGISLATURE TAKE THE TIME
NEEDED TO GET THE TEACHER ASKED
SPENDING PLAN RIGHT. AS WE
CAN'T AFFORD NOT TO MAKE THESE
INVESTMENTS. THEIR MEANINGFUL
IN OUR COMMUNITIES AND LOCAL
WAYS INCLUDING REAL ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT THANK YOU. NEXT TO
ABOUT A LINE NINETEEN THAT'S
ONE NINE. THANK YOU TURN UPPER
BODY WITH A NATURAL RESOURCES
DEFENSE COUNCIL IN LINE WITH
WHAT WHAT WHAT ASSEMBLY REYES
SAID RICK STREAMING CONCERNED
ABOUT THE DRASTIC REDUCTION IN
FUNDING FOR CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION INCLUDING
INCENTIVES FOR THE REMISSION
VEHICLE THE INFRASTRUCTURE THAT
HAVE A STRONG TRACK RECORD OF
PEOPLE MONEY CREATING JOBS.
LEVERAGING PRIVATE CAPITAL
CLEANING UP OUR AIR AND
SUPPORTING OUR HARDEST HIT
COMMUNITIES SECOND WE'RE VERY
PLEASED TO SEE THAT THE
STOPPING AND FUNDING FOR
EXPEDIA FACE SPARKLE PROGRAMMER
MAINTAINS A REVISED WE
SUPPORTED INVESTMENTS AND
HEALTHY SUSTAINABLE SCHOOL
FOOD. BUT I MOST VULNERABLE
CHILDREN DON'T AGREE AND THAT
CALIFORNIA'S FALLEN THE
TRANSFORMERS THE RIDE THE
CRISIS AND GAIN ACCESS TO
STABLE MARKETS IN THE LONG TERM
FINALLY TO THE CHURCH BUT IN
THAT OPENING REMARKS WE BELIEVE
THERE'S A REAL OPPORTUNITY HERE
FOR SUSTAINABLE RESILIENT AND
JUST RECOVERY. COMING HEARD
LEGISLATURE TO WORK WITH US AND
THE COMMUNITY IS AT THE
FINALIZED YOUR BUDGET DEFICIENT
THE FEAR THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AND IF WE COULD DROP PAUSED A
MOMENT WITH THE- TELE. GOTCHA
TESTIMONY WE HAVE WE- PER IN
THE- WHO IS. WAITING TO TESTIFY.
YOUR COMMENTS. YOUR COMMENT
THANK YOU MISTER CHAMBERS OF
COMMITTEE- BRANDING GARCIA ON
BEHALF OF CAL STAR I WANTED TO
MAKE TO OVER ARCHING COMMENTS
FIRST IS- YOU KNOW LIKE MANY
OTHER INDUSTRIES WE ARE ALSO
BEING IMPACTED BY CHO BAD- AND
WE FEEL THAT THE NEED FOR AN
ECONOMIC RECOVERY PACKAGE THAT
IS INCLUSIVE OF OUR INDUSTRY-
TO THAT EFFECT WE THINK THAT
DISCUSSIONS AROUND THE CAP AND
TRADE PLAN SHOULD BE DELAYED
UNTIL AUGUST WE SUPPORT THOMAS
MADE TO THAT EFFECT- SECOND- IS
THAT WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE- A-
DIFFERENT KIND OF FUNNY
PROPOSALS BE CONSIDERED- IN
REGARDS TO CLEAN TRANSPORTATION
AND WHETHER THAT BE. ARE GEN
THE MOTHER SAID WE THINK THAT
IT'S TIME TO THINK CREATIVELY
FOR THIS INDUSTRY CONSIDERING
THAT WE DO PROVIDE A LOT OF G.
SHE WITH AN EVENT AS WELL AS
HIGH QUALITY JOBS. AND IT
THAT'S ALL I'D SAY THANK YOU SO
MUCH THANK YOU FOR YOUR- THANK
YOU FOR HAVE NOW WILL READ TURN
TO THE PHONE LINE. NEXT CALL
THAT A LINE THIRTY SIX. WELL
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS THE
COMMANDING LOUIS BROWN TODAY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA FAIRS
ALLIANCE I WANT TO BRING TO
YOUR ATTENTION- THAT WE ARE IN
SUPPORT OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL TO START LOOKING AT A
TRANSITION STRATEGY FOR THE-
ADJUSTER TAG ASSOCIATIONS IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO A
MORE SUSTAINABLE- GOVERNANCE
STRUCTURE MOVING FORWARD. A WE
pOF THE EIGHTEEN POINT SIX
MILLION- FROM THE JANUARY
BUDGET THAT WAS CREATED BY THE
A. B. FOURTEEN NINETY NINE
FORMULA. THAT WAS CREATED BY
REVENUES GENERATED BY ALL FAIRS
AND GO TO THE BENEFIT OF ALL
PLAYERS. IN ABOUT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED FORTY IN
GENERAL FUND US. THE BEST A
DISTRICT I GUESS TO AGENCY
FAIRS I'D LIKE TO BRING TO YOUR
ATTENTION THAT THERE ARE NONE
OF COUNTY MISSED. OF THE CASE
SO IN FISCAL ISSUES AS A RESULT
NOT HAVING ANY ACTIVITIES ON
THE GROUNDS THERE FOR
GENERATING THEY'LL REVENUE. IN
TWENTY TWENTY WE THINK THAT
THAT FORTY MILLION SHOULD BE
UTILIZED AS WELL. SOME OF THOSE
FEARS THAT FIND THEMSELVES. IN
DIRE SITUATIONS. I ASKED TO-
LET YOU KNOW THAT THE RURAL
COUNTY REPRESENTATIVE
CALIFORNIA ARE IN LINE OF OUR-
ARE IN LINE WITH OUR THINKING
ON THIS ISSUE- AND THANK YOU
FOR YOUR ATTENTION. HAVE A GOOD
DAY. MAX LUCADO LINE THIRTY
NINE. GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS ADAM ROBIN WITH THE
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA WATER
ASSOCIATION CONFLICT WITH A
LETTER THAT WAS SUBMITTED TO
THE COMMITTEE EARLIER THIS WEEK
WOULD LIKE TO VOICE OUR STRONG
SUPPORT FOR THE WATER STORED
INVESTMENT PROGRAM RELATED
ELEMENTS OF THE STATE WATER
BOARD WATER RESILIENT PORTFOLIO
BPP. THE PROPOSAL HELP ADVANCE
THE PUBLIC BENEFITS THAT'LL BE
FUN THROUGH TWENTY FOURTEEN
PROPOSITION ONE INCLUDING
ECOSYSTEM WATER QUALITY AND
FLOOD CONTROL BENEFIT AS WELL
THE GROUP THE OPERATION STATE
WATER SYSTEM THANKS FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU. WELL ABOUT A
LINE NINETY ONE. GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS THIS IS
CHIU MALINOWSKI BALL
REPRESENTING ME CALIFORNIA BY A
MASS CALIFORNIA ELECTRIC
TRANSPORTATION COALITION-
ASKING THE COMMITTEE TODAY TO
NOT ZERO OUT THAT YEAR AT
FUNDING FOR YOUR ADMISSION
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAMS IT WE
DO RECOGNIZE THE CHALLENGING
ECONOMIC TIMES IN THE LIMITED
YEAR AFFINE PROJECTION THATWE
GOT TODAY NECESSITATING CHANGES
TO THE GOVERNOR'S JANUARY G.
GEAR AT SPENDING PLAN. HOWEVER
THE LEGISLATURE HAS SEVERAL
OPTIONS AVAILABLE TO IT TO
ALLOCATE LIMITED G. JEROD FUNDS
INCLUDING SETTING STRATEGIC
PRIORITIES THAT SUPPORT
ECONOMIC RECOVERY WHILE
CONTINUING CALIFORNIA'S
LEADERSHIP IN THE THEIR
EMISSION TRANSPORTATION FUTURE
SO WE ENCOURAGE YOU TO CONSIDER
TAKING ADDITIONAL TIME. TO
BETTER UNDERSTAND THE POTENTIAL
IMPACT ON JI EUROPE FUNDS IN
THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE- BY
POSTPONING DECISION NINETY
EIGHT EUROPE FORMULAS UNTIL
LATER THIS SUMMER IT WOULD
ALLOW THE LEGISLATURE TO THEIR
ASAP. HOW ANY NECESSARY CUTS
DID YOU DIRECT FUNDED PROGRAM
PROGRAMS CAN BE MADE MORE
QUICKLY WELL BENEFITING YOUR
ECONOMIC RECOVERY AND PUBLIC
HEALTH. OBJECTIVES THANK YOU.
NEXT WE WILL GO TO LINE. ONE OH
FIVE. GOOD MORNING VALERIE
NARAL FOR THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE. ONE MY
COMMENT TODAY RELATE TO THEB.
C. P. THAT TO PROVE ALL OVER
ONE MILLION DOLLARS FROM THE
GENERAL FUND FOR A ONE TIME
LITIGATION COSTS. ASSOCIATED
WITH THE FEDERAL BIOLOGICAL
OPINION. THE G. P. AND THE
STATE'S MEDICATIONS THAT THE
POINT THAT OLY. INTERRUPTING A
VOLUNTARY AGREEMENT PROCESS IS
AN UNFORTUNATE CHOICE BY THE
NIXON ADMINISTRATION THAT
PUSHES STAKEHOLDER AWAY FROM
COLLABORATION AND BACK TOWARD
CONFLICT IN LITIGATION. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. NEXT WE WILL GO
TO LINE. ONE NINETEEN ONE ONE
NINE. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
NATALIE NEXT. BUT DISTRICT AND
IT COULD COUNTY CALIFORNIA
HABITAT CONSERVATION COALITION
HOW. LOCAL CONSERVATION CORPS
OF THE ECHO THE STATE THE
BLOOMBERG YEAH. THE PROPOSAL
THAT THAT THE HABITAT. ALSO ON
BEHALF OF THE CAL HABIT
CONSERVE LIST. THANK YOU YOUR
HONOR IF YOU WANT A BUT WE LIKE
TO IF I THINK AFTER. I HAVE
CONSERVATION FUND. OR ABOUT AT
THE- MEETING IN FOR. DEVELOP
JUMP STARTING THE ECONOMY. BY
THE WAY I'LL BE HAPPY TO
PROVIDE. THAT. THE BUDGET FOR
THE P. BE REDUCED BUT BILLION
THIRTY AND FISCAL YEAR TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND
GOING. OUT WE HAVE DEVELOPED A
LOT OF. GOOD YOU TO PROTECT
PARK. BUT THEY'VE CLEARLY THE
TIME OF GREAT PUBLIC DEMAND FOR
OUTDOOR. THANK NEXT WE'LL GO TO
LINE TWENTY THREE. HELLO AGAIN
YOU INTEREST YOUR- ON OF THE
CALIFORNIA OF COUNTY CORPS
THANK YOU NAY CONNECT.
CALIFORNIA ARE GOING TO NEED
YOUR HELP GETTING THEM BACK TO
WORK THE MOMENT THEY ARE
LEGALLY ALLOWED TO DO SO WE
KNOW THAT HIS DOCTOR
PREPAREDNESS AND RESPONSE AND
CLIMB IN GREEN JOBS- BUT SHE
NEEDED AND GROWING WORKFORCE
OPPORTUNITY I WOULD IMPLORE YOU
ALL TO RECOGNIZE AND THEN BACK
IN PARALLEL TOOLS THAT ALLOW
THE STATE TO ATTRACT BUT
GROWING CLIMATE WORKFORCE
NEEDS. AND ON BEHALF OF
COMMUNITY NATURE CONNECTION
NATURE FOR ALL LA NEIGHBORHOOD
LAND TRUST IN ASKING ITO CREEK
CONSERVANCY I'D LIKE TO REFLECT
OUR DISAPPOINTMENT IN THE
GOVERNOR'S WITHDRAWAL OF TWENTY
NINE DOLLARS IN GENERAL FUND TO
SUPPORT OUTDOOR. AND REQUEST TO
DATE RECONSIDER AND DIVERSIFIED
TO INCLUDE INVESTMENT IN ONE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOOK ABOUT
DIRECTLY GRANT PROGRAM HILL NEW
GRANT PROGRAMS SUPPORT THAT
FIRST COMMUNITY ACT PROGRAM
THREE OUTDOOR EDUCATION. AT
PUBLIC SCHOOL DISTRICT GATHERED
THESE WOULD PROVIDE EQUITABLE
OUTDOOR ACCESS TO EDUCATION AND
CAREER OPPORTUNITIES THAT HAVE
BEEN IMPACTED BY CO THAT ARE
BOTH COMMON IN ECONOMIC
STIMULUS BONTA PACKAGE BE A
VIABLE TOOL TO FIND THESE
CRITICAL INVESTMENT. WITH A
LINE MONDAY COULD. DEPLETE
THANK YOU. BACK WE WILL GO LINE
NINETY. GOOD MORNING STEVEN
MYERS ON BEHALF OF THE MARIN
AGRICULTURAL LAND TRUST WE'RE
SUPPORTIVE OF THE PRESERVATION
OF TO EUROPE CONTINUOUSLY
APPROPRIATED FUNDS IN THE
GOVERNOR'S REVISED- INSURES
THAT THERE'S CRITICAL FUNDING
FOR PROGRAMS SUCH AS THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSERVATION
STOCK PROGRAM. WHICH WILL BE-
CONTINUE TO CONSERVE
AGRICULTURAL LAND ALSO ON THE
HAPPENED A NUMBER OF
ORGANIZATIONS INCLUDING THE
ESCONDIDO CREEK CONSERVANCY LOS
ANGELES NEIGHBORHOOD LAND TRUST
NATURE FOR ALL BRENT
AGRICULTURAL LAND TRUSTS THE
CALIFORNIA HABITAT CONSERVATION
MEDICAL. WHEN NUMBER ONE SON
EXPRESS OUR JUST ABOUT THE WITH
THE OF THE UP ON IN THE
GOVERNOR'S. WE HOPE THAT THE
LEGISLATURE'S EFFORTS TOWARD A
NEW FUNDING SOURCE FOR ECONOMIC
STIMULUS INCLUDE SUPPORT FOR
THE MANY CONSERVATION PROGRAMS
THAT CREATE JOBS WHILE THE
TRAINING IMPORTANT CARMICHAELS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU.
BACK WELL THAT'LL LINE EIGHTY
THREE. NINETY THREE. ARE YOU I
MEAN IT AFTER THAT YES CAN YOU
HEAR ME. WE CAN HEAR YOU NOW.
GOOD AFTERNOON CALLING YOUR
THEY'LL BE HAPPEN VINYL DEFENSE
FUND WE AGREE WITH THE COMMENT
THAT ASSEMBLY MEMBERS RARE
THREE THAT TARSIA. AND ARCHAEA
HAVE NEEDS RELATED TO AIR
QUALITY CONCERNS RUNNING
COMMUNITY WE APPRECIATE THE
PARTY STATUS THAT AS OPPOSED TO
EIGHTY SIX AND FUNDING IF I
COULD YOU HEAR AT. HOWEVER THE
UNCERTAINTY. OF THAT FUNDING
STREAM BUT INCREDULOUS LEADER
TO CONTINUE LOOKING FOR MORE
RELIABLE SOURCES TO ADDRESS THE
DISPROPORTIONATE BURDEN OF AIR
POLLUTION AND SOME OF
CALIFORNIA'S MOST VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES. THE MIDDLE
RESPIRATORY CANNOT PICK IS NOT
THE TIME TO LEAVE INVESTMENT IN
CLEAN AIR UP IN THE AIR. I
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO REQUEST
NINETEEN SIX MILLION FROM THE
GENERAL FUND COULD YOU TELL
YOUR FIRST ACTING TO MEET AT A
TORY OBLIGATIONS OBJECT BACK.
TO PORT FOR DRINKING WATER
STOPPING AT WATER RESOURCES
CONTROL BOARD. THE PROPOSED
TOPIC CHRIS HOLDEN P.
MANAGEMENT PROGRAM. EIGHT
MILLION SENATE BUT. I JACK AND
LAST. THE TWENTY FOR NEW RIVER.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. NEXT
WE'LL GO TO LINE. ONE TO TWO.
NINE ONE TWENTY TWO ARE YOU I
MEAN. WHAT ARE THE NEXT ONE
THAT WILL BE A LINE FIFTY ONE.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS THE
FULL METAL I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF COMEDIC AND YOU
COULD INVITE. WHERE TO MY
MANAGER FOR THE STATION AT THE
BUDGET COMMITTEE WE ALSO
RECEIVED A LETTER SO STATEWIDE
SUPPORT ON THIS MATTER- I DON'T
LIKE THE NIGHT THAT WE ALSO
SEVENTY EIGHTY SIX ONE SEVEN-
CO CHAIR WITH THE LOCAL AIR
DISTRICT. WHERE STRONG SUPPORT
OF THE BUDGET APPROPRIATION TO
THE PROPERTY THEN YOU RIVER AND
EIGHTY SIX ONE SEVEN. ALL ALONG
WITH BILL BELICHICK HOT BUTTON
CRITICAL TO OUR HEALTH AND
ECONOMIC RESILIENCE OF THE
CALIFORNIA BORDER REGION. ANY
PUBLIC HEALTH SECURITY TO THE
STATE. SENATE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR SUPPORT. FILL OUT A LINE
FORTY TWO ALL. HI YEAH ALMOST
AFTERNOON- HAIRED MANY MEMBERS
MY NAME IS DEBBIE YOURS YOU
WATER CENTER FROM A DROP FROM
THE UC BERKELEY MORE ACCIDENTS
CALVET THE BEST WE CAN AND
ENERGY. ONE START WE APPRECIATE
THE GUY. I THINK. EIGHT SIX
FOUR FOUR THREE FIVE ON. WE ARE.
YOUR AND FATHER CUTS. TO MAYBE
BY ONE PACK EXCEPT THAT BASS
AND BUT RUBIO READ AN PROGRESS
WE HAVE MADE I JUST. FOR COME.
BACK THE ORDERED DRINKING WATER.
WE HAVE THE FUNDING OF
AVAILABLE TO. THANK MY OUR
REGION GRADE GRANT THE DEED
YOUR PREVIOUS ALLOCATE HELLO
AND- THE- ENGAGEMENT OF
DIFFERENT COMMUNITIES AND OTHER
ARE YOU. FINALLY IN TERMS OF CO
FOR WERE CALIFORNIA. WATER SHUT
OFF PRIOR TO MARK FOURTH WHICH
WOULD NOT BY THE PEOPLE ACTIVE
A- EXECUTIVE. WE NEED FOR ME
REQUIRE PAYMENT PLAN. FOR WHEN
BILLS COME IN ORDER FOR QUE
AWAY OF CHAU OFF. THANK YOU.
NEXT TO GO TO LIE ONE. ONE TWO
ZERO. THE MORNING AT TEN UNDER
THEN WHAT MODEL WITH THE
WIDENING GROUP HERE ON BEHALF
OF TAKING A ENERGY HELLO
SERVING ESTATE THAT PROVIDES
ELECTRICITY CUSTOMERS ACROSS.
ALAMEDA COUNTY. IT'S WITH THE
FORTY INSTRUCTION IF YOU
MILLION DOLLARS THE FIFTY AT
THE END COMMISSION. FOR THE
POINT OF WHAT COULD VEHICLE
INFRASTRUCTURE GOOD HELP MEDIA
PROGRAM. AT WEIRD TO NOT THE
WAY A DOCTOR OF THE BUDGET ITEM
AS- CALLIE THE I. P. CARD THEIR
SHOVEL READY. AND A LOT TYPE
RIGHT NOW. IN EARLY WITH A
FUNDING IF YOU KNOW WE CAN GET
LEVEL KERR ON IT THAT THEY JOBS.
AS THE BED LOOKED SO. NOT A
GOOD COVERAGE THE LARGE SCALE
WELL OUT OF ELECTRIC VEHICLES
AT THIS IS THE HE WAKES BUT
PEOPLE TO WORK. OPPOSITION TO
STATE THE NEXT STRIDES
ENVIRONMENTAL GOALS AT. FIFTH
AND IT. GOLD THE FACT OF YEAH I
THINK THAT INFRASTRUCTURE BUT
AB EIGHT THE PART NUMBER EIGHTY
CALVET HELLO. AT PRIMERICA
PARTNERED. FOR A TELL BE ACTED.
ENVIRONMENTAL BENEFITS THAT'S
GOOD BUT NOT VIABLE UNITY. AT
THE POINT OF. THE GOT PROJECT
WILL SEE JOB INCREASE AND
DECREASE THE AMOUNT THAT THAT
PROBLEM IS CAUGHT THE STATE.
AND THEY WILL HAVE A
DISPROPORTIONATELY BENEFICIAL
IMPACT ON BOTH A LITTLE BEARDED
AT THE CLINIC I LOCTED THEN
THE FREEWAYS STRETCHES THAT ARE
FOUND THROUGHOUT ALAMEDA
COUNTY. WHERE MEMBERS OF THE
WORD SENATOR IF THEY ARE ABLE
TO GET TO THEIR JOBS. WELL THE
REASON WITH SUPPORT THE FIFTY
ONE MILLION DOLLARS. FOR THE
ENERGY NATIONAL CAL IS THE
APPLE OF THAT LIKE BUTTON.
ACTUAL CAROLINE ONE TWENTY
EIGHT. MORNING MISS KEREN
MEMBERS NEAR ME. YES WE CAN.
PLEASE PROCEED WITH YOUR CARE
MEMBERS IN ONLY NOW I'M BACK TO
THE ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA A
FARMER THE CIVIC EGEN CULTURE
AT THE STATION AND CALIFORNIA
GREAT BECAUSE YOU CAN THEY WERE
EXPRESSING CONCERN TO PDF A
BUDGET TRAILER BILL FOR
CONFINEMENT OF LIVESTOCK ALSO
KNOWN AS PROPOSITION WELL OUR
CONCERNS DEPOSE OR THE
FOLLOWING THE PROPOSAL AT WHICH
IS A NEW PROGRAM THE NEW FEE
AND ONCE TOGETHER FOR IT ONE A-
BIG INDUSTRY ALREADY HAD TO
MILK THE ASSESSMENT OF HOLDEN
REQUIREMENTS. THE CONCERN IS
THAT THE AG INDUSTRY WILL BE
PAYING FOR DISPROPORTIONAL
AMOUNT ESPECIALLY SINCE THE
OTHER INDUSTRIES SUCH AS WE
DON'T HAVE NO PROGRAM THERE'S
NO IDENTIFIED VESTED ELECTRIC
UTILITY NOR WELCOME TO CAVE IN
FRONT OF THE WORKING FIELD
PROVISION. DESTROY THERE'LL BE
DUPLICATION THE PROGRAM THE
CURRENT ASHEVILLE A PROGRAM I
WOULDN'T YOU GET PAID TO MORE
THAN JUST FORCE REGULATION FOR
FOOD SAFETY AND HEALTH THEY
EXPECT FOR FOOD PACKAGING
LABELLING IT COMPLIANCE AS
WHATEVER OTHER TECHNICAL ISSUES
FOOD SAFETY ACTION THIS WERE TO
PASS THE ISSUE OF THE SUBJECT
TO FEES THAT HAVE SIMILAR GOALS
AND FINALLY SHOW LIKE GRAHAM
HAD THE DISTINCT FULLY FUNDED
ENFORCEMENT. AND HAS THE
ABILITY TO INCREASE FUNDS FOR
ENFORCEMENT IF YOU DIGITAL SUCH
AS SORTING IT SHOULD BE
PROVIDED TO ENFORCE THE NEW
LIQUID EGG PROVISIONS OF PROP
OF WE'RE OPEN A TRACKING THE
PROVISIONS IN THE EXISTING
STATUTE RATHER THAN CREATING A
NEW PROGRAM. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERING IT TURNS. NEXT LINE
WHY FORTY. MARK ON THE
HAPPENING FOR LYNCH FOR IN
ORDER FINDING. STATION THREE
FROM. IN ORDER TO CONTINUE
FINDING AND SUSTAINABLE LANDS
H. ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIANS
WRITER AND ACTION NETWORK IT'S
A TWENTY ME UNDER WORK THE
INTEGRATED MENTIONED WITH. I'M
OF ALL THREE INFORMATION.
REGARDING YOUR TO FIND
CHANNELING THE CURRENT THE
CREATURES TURNED. MEAN CURSE
MAKING AND- THE ONLY THING
HOLDING AND CLICKING. WHICH YOU
CAN THE FARMERS. THE NEXT THAT
ALIGN FIFTY TWO. GOOD AFTER
ALMOST UNDERTAKEN JOE
AGRICULTURAL CHEMICALS OF HOW
WHAT WHAT ARE SUPPORT FOR THE
GOVERNOR PRIOR TO THE OF THE
AFFORDABLE CARE ACT WATER IN
HIS CARPENTRY CRIER AND BE
ALLOCATION OF THE VEHICLE AND
MISSION REDUCTION BY ALSO KNOWN
AS FAR FIND OUT. WHICH GO
TOWARDS PROTECT AND MISSION
PERFORMANCE. AND ALSO BENEFIT.
QUALITY IN MANY MANY THE
BANKING CAN. FOR TO WORKING
WITH THE CHAIR AND NUMBER ONTHESE AND PROGRAM GOING THANK
YOU. NEXT LEVEL BUT ONLINE. ONE
FIFTY THREE. MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS- THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
TAKING YOUR- PUBLIC COMMENT
TODAY I MUST ADMIT I'M HAVING A
LITTLE BIT OF- TESTIMONY MEDIUM
AND THE AS THE CAPITAL PARK
OPTION IS THEY LOOK BEAUTIFUL-
SPEAKING TODAY ON BEHALF OF
CLEAN POWER LINE MY NAME IS ROB
GROSS WILDER. AND CLEAN POWER
LINE BETWEEN THE CHOICE
AGGREGATOR FOR THIRTY TWO
COMMUNITIES IN LOS ANGELES AND
VENTURA COUNTY BY THE LARGEST
TVA IN THE STATE AND PROVIDE
POWER TO APPROXIMATELY THREE
MILLION PEOPLE WOULD TO THINK
WE COMPORT THE ONE TIME
EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY TO SEE
THE FOUR FIFTY ONE MILLION
DOLLARS FROM THE ALTERNATIVE
AND RENEWABLE FUEL AND VEHICLE
TECHNOLOGY FUND. THE
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR THE NAIL
IN THE LARGEST SOURCE OF
CALIFORNIANS CHICHI MISSION
THANK WE POWER LINE IS WORKING
TO MAKE IT EASIER FOR CUSTOMERS
ARE COMMUNITIES TO SWITCH FROM
INTERNAL GAS COMBUSTION. ENGINE
ELECTRIC VEHICLES. I AM AN
EFFORT WITH THE T. TO BRING
MORE. TRY TO SELLING HOW. AND
SOUTH ARE THE ACTUAL QUOTE. TO
THE VIçT PRO. AND WE CAN THAT
HAPPEN LANE DAHLE AND TO PUT IN
OVER ONE FIVE MILLION OVER THE
NEXT THREE YEARS. THROUGH THE
CAL YOU GET HE PROGRAM. FOR
INCREASED CV CHARGING THE TURK
COUNTY- MORE FUNDING- WOULD
GIVE A MOMENTUM TO SPEND A LOT
THEY LOOKED COUNTY. NOW IF YOU
LET YOUR VEHICLE CHARTER
DIRECTLY LEAD TO AN INCREASED
NUMBER ELECTRIC VEHICLES ON THE
ROAD. THEY ALSO CREATE SHOVEL
READY JOBS AT A TIME WHEN
PEOPLE ARE DESPERATE LOOKING TO
GET BACK TO WORK. AS COMMITTEE
CONSIDER TRANSPORTATION BUDGET
CHANGES WHEN CURFEW TO CONSIDER
FURTHER AND NOTHING IN THE CAL
E. V. I. P. PROGRAM. WHICH IS
WILL HELP THE STATE MAKE A
LUXURY VEHICLE GHG EMISSION
REDUCTION AND CLEANER GOALS ALL
LIKE CREATING IMMEDIATE GREEN.
INTRODUCTORY JOBS THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. NEXT WE WILL GO TO
LINE. SIXTY FIVE. MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS ARMOR KARLSSON CALLING
ON BEHALF OF THE ASSOCIATION OF
CONTRACT COUNTIES THE FIRE
DEPARTMENTS OF KERN LOS ANGELES
MORAN ORANGE SANTA BARBARA AND
VENTURA COUNTIES. IN SUPPORT OF
PROPOSED AUGMENTATIONS FOR CAL
FIRE INCLUDING THE EIGHTY FIVE
POINT SIX MILLION PROPOSAL FOR
RELEASE STAFF. THANK YOU. YOUR
PHONE IS CUTTING OUT WE CAN'T
HEAR YOU. WELL SORRY TO HEAR
THAT BUT. I'M CALLING FOR A
PARTICULAR LINE SO IF I HAVE TO
GO OFF LIKE THIS I WILL WE CAN
HEAR YOU SOMEWHERE NOW PARDON
ME WE CAN HEAR YOU NOW THE GUY
HAD BOUGHT THAT ALTHOUGH COULD
SPELL START OVER OKAY MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS AYMERIC CARLSON
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CONTRACT
COUNTIES THE FIRE DEPARTMENTS
OF KERN LOS ANGELES MARIN
ORANGE SANTA BARBARA. IN TWO
COUNTY. IN SUPPORT OF PROPOSED
AUGMENTATIONS FOR CAL FIRE
INCLUDING THE EIGHTY FIVE POINT
SIX MILLION PROPOSAL FOR RELIEF
STAFFING. THANK YOU DID THAT
GET THROUGH YES IT DID. YEAH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
FOR YOUR COMMENTS. WELL THAT
ALIGN SEVENTY NINE. ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA AIR POLLUTION
CONTROL OFFICERS ASSOCIATION WE
APPRECIATE THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PRIORITIZATION OF THE G.
JACKSON FAN OF FUNDING FOR THE
EIGHTY SIX SEVENTEEN COMMUNITY
ARE PROTECTION PROGRAM AND FOR
AGRICULTURAL DIESEL ENGINE
UPGRADES AND REPLACEMENT
HOWEVER WERE DEEPLY CONCERNED
THERE WILL BE LITTLE TO NO
FUNDING FOR IMPLEMENTATION OF
THE AB SIX SEVENTEEN PROGRAM
INCENTIVES AND IMPLEMENTING CAN
GO HAND IN HAND WITHOUT
SUFFICIENT RESOURCES WORK BEING
DONE BY COMMUNITIES. THEIR
DESTRUCTION CRIED TO CLEAN UP
AIR POLLUTION COMMUNITIES WILL
SLOW DRAMATICALLY OR STOP
ALTOGETHER WE ASSN
IMPLEMENTATION BE FUNDED AT
LAST YEAR'S AMOUNT OF FIFTY
MILLION WELL STILL MUCH LESS
THAN ACTUAL PROGRAM COSTS THAT
WILL AT THE VERY LEAST HELP
ENSURE THE WORK CONTINUES IN
AIR QUALITY IMPROVEMENT I
REALIZED IN COMMUNITIES.
ACTUALLY THE NAME REVISION DOES
NOT PAY FOR TWO MILLION IN
FUNDING FOR LOCAL AIR DISTRICT
PRESCRIBED FIRE GRANT WHILE THE
DOLLAR AMOUNT IS MODERN THE
INVESTMENT PROVIDE SIGNIFICANT
GOOD HEALTH AND SAFETY BENEFIT
AND COST SAVINGS I HELP PREVENT
AND IF THEY BALK. AND WHAT
IMPROPERLY. PRIORITIZE OKAY FOR
SOME APPROVAL CATEGORY WE ARE
THAT PREFER PRESCRIBED GRAN TO
BE INCLUDED IN THAT HAD. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. NEXTBOOK BUT ON
ONE. ONE ONE. GREAT THANKS GOOD
AFTERNOON FINALLY- I'M JENNIFER
APPEAR IN THE GENERAL MANAGER
FOR THE STATE WATER
CONTRACTORS- WE ARE AN
ORGANIZATION OF PUBLIC AGENCIES
TO DELIVER WATER TWENTY SEVEN
MILLION CALIFORNIA RATEPAYERS
AND SEVENTY FIVE HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND ACRES OF FARMLAND.
WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH THE
STATE ADMINISTRATION FOR
SEVERAL YEARS NOW TO DEVELOP
VOLUNTARY AGREEMENT THE UPDATE
STATE REGULATION FIRST AIRED
ABOUT A RIVERS BY ADVANCING A
FIFTEEN YEAR FIVE BILLION THEIR
PLAN TO PROVIDE MORE WATER AND
HABITAT FOR THE ENVIRONMENT.
WHILE PROTECTING THE WATER
RIGHTS OF PUBLIC WATER AGENCIES
WE APPLAUD THE ADMINISTRATION'S
COMMITMENT TO THAT PROCESS. TO
THAT END HOWEVER WE ARE
DISAPPOINTED THAT THE STATE'S
LITIGATION CHALLENGING THE
FEDERAL BIOLOGICAL OPINION
CONTINUE TO MOVE FORWARD. LEFT
UNRESOLVED THERE'S NO CLEAR
PATH TO GET TO VOLUNTARY
AGREEMENT. THE BETTER USE OF
THE ONE MILLION DOLLAR B. C. P.
FROM THE GENERAL FUND WOULD BE
A HIGHER FACILITATION SERVICES
THE FINALLY RESOLVED ISSUES.
THAT COULD HAVE BEEN RESOLVED
IN TWENTY NINETEEN. WE WOULD
ASK THAT THE COMMITTEE SIGNALED
PREFERENCE FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION TO RETURN TO A
COLLABORATIVE APPROACH BY
ABANDONING IT BUT EACH AND
EVERY THIRTY THE VOLUNTARY
AGREEMENT. I ALSO JUST WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONTINUED
LEADERSHIP UNDER THESE TYPICAL
AN UNPRECEDENTED HIGH. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. TECH TALK
ALIGNED ONE SIXTY NINE. GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
MY NAME IS MARYANN WARMER DAM
ON BEHALF OF WORLD COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES THE CALIFORNIA-
WE APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO CALL OUT A COUPLE OF AREAS-
IN PARTICULAR WE WANT TO ALIGN
OUR COMMENTS WITH MISTER BROWN
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
WHERE. WE WOULD ADD THAT YOU
CARE SO THE DO YOU SERVE AS
EMERGENCY OPERATIONS CENTER FOR
BOTH CAL FIRE AND WE ASK DURING
TIMES OF NEED I WOULD REQUEST
THAT THEIR FUNDING THE- WE ALSO
WANT BILL A CONCORD WITH
QUICONQUE COMMENTED RESPECT TO.
IN NUMBER IN A FLOOD AND MOM I
WOULD TO THE WE JUST THAT THE
MONEY FOR DRESS ONE ON A LOCAL
AND IMPLEMENTATION EFFORTS HAVE
BEEN POOR OUR PARTICULARLY
CONCERNED THAT MONEY FORGET
THAT THAT COMMUNITIES AND A
POUND GROUND- THE RESULTING.
CAN EMPLOYMENT. THE BILL CAME
FROM LANDSAT WINGS OUR NOT BE
AT THE ONLY ANCHOR THE CAN TO
BECAUSE THAT. THANK YOU. NEXT
WE WILL GO TO LINE. ONE FOUR.
GET AFTERNOON HERE NUMBERS
AARON RODRIGUEZ TO THE UNION OF
CONCERNED SCIENTISTS I WOULD
LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT AREAS OF
INVESTMENT THAT WE BELIEVE THE
LEGISLATURE SHOULD CONSIDER
HAVE YOU HEARD FROM OTHERS AND
THE CRITICAL YEAR FOR
IMPLEMENTATION OF THAT CLASS IT
IS ESSENTIAL THAT YOU W. ARE
HAVE THE STOCK CAPACITY TO SELL
THEIR STATUTORY OBLIGATION. TO
REVIEW THE THING ABILITY PLAN
FOR MEDI BY THE STATE NOT
CRITICALLY OVER DOCTOR BASIN
BUT THEN THE NEXT YEAR IN ORDER
FOR THE THING I PROCESS TO MOVE
FORWARD. THE GOVERNOR TO PAY
CHECKING SOME PROP THE FUNDS
THAT THEY MIGHT BUT WE
UNDERSTAND THERE MAY BE
LIMITATION TO HOW THIS FUNDING
AND BE USED TO SUPPORT
COMMUNITY PROJECT. FEDERAL
SECOND WE LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT THE
SIGNIFICANCE OF EACH EAR UP
INVESTMENT THAT REDUCE
EMISSIONS IN THE TRANSPORTATION
SECTOR BY SUPPORTING
COMMERCIALIZATION ADOPTION OF
ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES WE CAN'T
PUT TO DEATH MAY PROGRAM TO
HAVE A TRACK RECORD OF CREATING.
JOBS AND THEY- I'M CLEAR SAFER
TRANSPORTATION ALL BLACK. TOXIC
AIR FOR. AND THE- KIND OF.
THANK YOU VERY. NEXT WE WILL
BUT A LINE ONE SEVENTY SIX. THE
SOUTH COAST AIR QUALITY
MANAGEMENT DISTRICT WE'D LIKE
TO EXPRESS OUR APPRECIATION FOR
TWO HUNDRED MILLION IN EIGHTY
SIX SEVENTEEN COMMUNITY HERE
PROTECTION CENTER FUNDING FOR
OFF THEIR DISTRICTS ARE TIED TO
THE MAY BE BIASED HOWEVER WE
HAVE SERIOUS CONCERNS ABOUT THE
LACK OF EIGHTY SIX SEVENTEEN
IMPLEMENTATION FUNDING.
CAPTURED OPTION PROCEEDS WILL
LIKELY NOT BE ENOUGH TO ALLOW
FUNDING FOR IMPLEMENTATION
WHICH WAS GIVEN SECOND PARTY IN
THE BUDGET WITHOUT THIS WORK BY
AIR DISTRICTS WOULD COMMUNITIES
TO CLEAN UP LOCAL AIR POLLUTION
WILL SIGNIFICANTLY SLOW OR STOP
ALL TOGETHER. THIS IS
PROBLEMATIC EXPRESSLY FOR
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES GIVEN
FINDINGS ARE EXPOSURE TO AIR
POLLUTION COMBINED WITH CODE
NINETEEN THEY RESULT IN
INCREASED AND EXACERBATE NECK
HELP IMPACTS FIFTY MILLION IF.
CRITICS OF THE HEALTH. PROTECT
OBJECT TO THE DIVERSE DIVERSION
BUT MONIES FOR NOW AIRPORT
PURPOSE THIS WILL ALSO OF
INCOME TO FUNDING YEAR SHOULD
BE THIS WE LIKE TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER START A RACE AND BECAUSE
FOR THEIR SUPPORT COMICS THANK
YOU. NOT WITHOUT A LINEUP.
FORTY FOUR ZERO. I THANK YOU
THAT PAUL MASON WITH PACIFIC
FOREST TRUST I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE CHAIR THE
OPENING COMMENTS ABOUT THE
HABITAT CONSERVATION FUND- NOW
JUST REITERATE IT'S NOT MERELY
A FACT OF POTENTIALLY LOSING
ABOUT THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS A
YEAR FOR THIS YEAR BUT WE START
LOOKING AT HOW THAT MONEY
LEVERAGES OTHER FEDERAL MONEY
AND PRIVATE MONEY WE'RE LOOKING
AT THE POTENTIAL LOSS OF HALF A
BILLION DOLLARS A CONSERVATION
OPPORTUNITY OVER THE NEXT
DECADE. SO WE STRONGLY AND I'M
GONNA ALIGN MYSELF WITH THE
COMMENTS IN THE FENDERS A
WILDLIFE HERE HEARD IT SHOULD-
THE LEGISLATURE TO REJECT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSED
TRAILER BILL TO SUNSET THE
HABITAT CONSERVATION FUND WE
HAD THIS DEAL LAST YEAR AND I
AGREE WE SHOULD NOT BE
REVISITING AND SO SOON- REJECT
MYSTERIES WAS CLOSE- P. FOR A-
STATE OPERATIONS BUDGET RELIES
ON SOMETHING THE H. THE- BEACH
YEAH. OR APPROPRIATE ATTIC
GENERAL FUND TO FUND THE
DEPARTMENT. AND MAKE SURE THAT
IF THERE IS ANY MONEY SHIFTED
FROM ABOUT HOW TECH
CONSERVATION FUND FOR JUST THIS
YEAR. THIS BACK FILL THAT
NECESSARY TO MAINTAIN THE BEACH
YEAH. SHE'S FINALLY I'D ALSO
LIKE TO EXPRESS THEIR SUPPORT
FOR THE PRIVATIZATION OF THE
FOREST HEALTH AND FIRE
PREVENTION G. G. R. F.
INVESTMENTS CONSISTENT WITH SB
NINE A ONE FOR A COUPLE OF
YEARS AGO. THAT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT MAINTAINED
CONSISTENCY OF THOSE
INVESTMENTS. AND ALSO SUPPORT
THE COMMENTS MADE BY CAPITAL- A
FEW MINUTES AGO ABOUT MAKING
SURE THAT WE ARE PROVIDING
GRANTS TO SUPPORT THE EXPANDED
USE OF PRESCRIBED FIRE. AS A
WAY TO REDUCE OVERALL FIRE
INTENSITY SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME TODAY. NEXT WE WILL GO TO
LINE ONE SEVENTY SEVEN.
AFTERNOON YOU'RE SHARING
MEMBERS WE HAVE STILL
RETIREMENT CALIBRATION BURKE
COMMERCE WE HAVE ENOUGH THE PUT
THE INITIATION PROPOSAL THE
LATE INTO DEEP HERE YOUR
PARTNER WE HAVE CONFIRMED IT
CAN START WITH IMPLEMENTING
INCREASES WITHOUT MOVIE WORK
WITH YOU DID TODAY TIONAL
REGULATORY INSTRUCTIONAL FORGET
THE TEACHING AT THE- END OF
WHICH WERE MENTIONED I CAN
REMEMBER GARCIA AND MY
COLLEAGUES IN PUBLIC COMMENT
TODAY. BUT WE DO LOOK FORWARD
TO GETTING TO WORK WITH THE TO
GET THE ON. THE LEGISLATURE TO
MOVE FOR. APPRECIATE THE TIME.
THANK YOU. NEXT WE WILL
CAROLINE. FORTY NINE. GOOD
AFTERNOON KEREN MEMBERS THIS IS
A MAJOR MAIN ELECTION
CALIFORNIA REPRESENTING A
COALITION THAT ALSO INCLUDES
YEAH CAT TAYLOR'S GONNA BREAK A
LITERACY WE SUPPORT THE TEN
MILLION FUNDING FOR THE
PARTICLE GRANT PROGRAM AND THE
OFFICE OF FARM TO FORK AS
OPPOSED TO THE GOVERNOR'S A
BUDGET WITH VISION. THAT
CRITICAL FUNDING WILL INCREASE
THE RESILIENCY OF LOCAL
COMMUNITIES COULD SUPPLY CHAIN
AND PROVIDE FRESH HEALTHY FOOD
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS WHICH IS
CRITICALLY NEEDED RIGHT NOW.
MORE THAN EVER DURING THE
PANDEMIC. YEAH OF THE FARM TO
AT THE FORGING PART PART. THAT
WILL CAPTURE ACT TO FROM THE
LOOK. I AND DRUG WITH THE TO
MARKET STUDY THEM THE BOX RIGHT
NOW. THANKS COOL THEN
RESTAURANTS AT THE LOWEST
POSSIBLE COST. WE WOULD
ENCOURAGE THE LEGISLATURE AND
THE GOVERNOR. TO APPROVE THE
GOVERNOR'S RECOMMENDATION THANK.
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TIME AND
CONSIDERATION. NEXT WE WILL BUT
A LINE TWENTY THREE. GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
MONO CANNELLA REPRESENTED THE
SANTA CLARA VALLEY WATER
DISTRICT I WANTED TO BUY ONE OF
THE PPP RELATED TO THE ELEMENTS
ON THE WITH THAT- WHICH IS THE-
ONE. AT THE TOP ONE BOND
FUNDING THAT CHECKED WITH
ALLOCATED LAST YEAR ON THAT A
LOT AT LEAST TWELVE DIFFERENT
WATER AGENCIES AND EFFORT TO ON
GET AN ADDITIONAL. DAMPENING ON
PROJECT OFF THE GROUND WITH A
BODY. ON THIS PARTICULAR BGP OF
SUPPORT ON STAFF IN THE
DIVISION. OF WATER RIGHT HELP
EXPEDITE. THE WATER RIGHTS
PERMITTING PROCESS WITH THE ONE
CRIED AND WE REALLY THINK THAT
THIS IS THE HE'S A FUNDING THE
TICKET MY LATE BY FUNDING AND
STAFFING SPECIFIC FOCUS IN. A
BETTER BECAUSE WE FOCUSING ON
THAT EXISTING STAFF. TO WORK
PUTTING BACKGROUND. OCCASION
WITHOUT CALL CREDIT FOR PROJECT
THERE ARE A COUPLE OF THE- AND
WE THINK IT YOUR TIME TODAY AND
YOU CAN. NEXT LEVEL A LINE ONE
TWENTY TWO. I WOULD. ONE TWO.
AVATAR MUTE. ALRIGHT WE WILL GO
TO LINE ONE EIGHTY FOUR. AND
ONE EIGHTY FOUR DO YOU HAVE IT
ON MUTE. I DO NOT I'M SORRY
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE ON
MY NAME IS CHARLIE WILSON
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR AND CEO OF
THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA WATER
COALITION. OUR MEMBERS WHICH
STRETCHES FROM THE MEXICAN
BORDER TO THE SOUTH. YOUR
CURRENT COUNTY IN THE NORTH IS
BROUGHT IT UNLIKE ANY OTHER IN
ITS INCLUSION. FROM BUSINESS
COUNTY. CITY GOVERNMENT
AGRICULTURE LABOR ENVIRONMENTAL
ORGANIZATIONS WATER AGENCIES
AND THE GENERAL PUBLIC. MY
COMMENTS TODAY SPEAK
SPECIFICALLY TO THE CALIFORNIA
NATURAL RESOURCE AGENCY AND CAL
EPA BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSAL TO
DIRECT OVER A MILLION DOLLARS
FOR THE GENERAL FUND FOR THE
ONE TIME LITIGATION COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH THE FEDERAL
BIOLOGICAL OPINIONS. RATHER
THAN PERPETUATING LONG
COURTROOM BATTLES. WE BELIEVE
THE GOAL SHOULD BE TO GET BACK
TO THE NEGOTIATING TABLE AND
RECONCILE THE DIFFERENCES
BETWEEN THE FEDERAL AND STATE
WATER OPERATION PERMITS. AND TO
FACILITATE CONCLUSION. OF THE
VOLUNTARY AGREEMENT PROCESS.
THATPROCESS WAS SHOWING
TREMENDOUS PROMISE. UNTIL
POLITICS TOOK OVER. THAT NUMBER
IT'S GOT TO BE A PLAN WE
BELIEVE THAT GETS THE BALANCE
RIGHT FOR NATIVE FISH AND THE
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE AND ACRES OF
PRODUCTIVE FARMLAND. THE DEPEND
ON THIS CRITICAL RESOURCE. WE
ENCOURAGE YOU TO WORK TOGETHER
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION TO
PROMOTE COLLABORATION AND
RESOLUTION AND NOT LINKED AND
COURTROOM BATTLES. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME. NEXT WE WILL GO
TO LINE NINETY FIVE. GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS ASKING US ON BEHALF OF
THE ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
WATER AGENCIES DON'T SPEAK VERY
QUICKLY ABOUT THREE ITEMS THE
FIRST BEING A CLIMATE
RESILIENCE BOND. WE UNDERSTAND-
THAT THE GOVERNOR HAS HAS
WITHDRAWN HIS PROPOSAL FOR A
BOMB BUT WE WANT TO ENCOURAGE
THE LEGISLATURE TO CONTINUE TO
CONSIDER. ECONOMIC RECOVERY
FUNDING THAT IS FOCUSED ON
CLIMATE RESILIENCE- YOU KNOW WE
BELIEVE THAT NOW MORE THAN EVER
THE STATE NEEDS TO INVEST IN
WATER RESILIENCE AS A MEANS TO
CREATE JOBS AND STIMULATE THE
ECONOMY. AND WE HAVE BEEN
WORKING ON A PROPOSAL- WITHOUT
A BROAD GROUP OF STAKEHOLDERS-
THAT WOULD ACCOMPLISH JUST THAT
SO WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH YOU YOU ALL AS YOU DISCUSS
THAT. PROPOSALS REGARDING THE-
CALLIE P. A. B. C. PETER
LITIGATION WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT RELATED TO THE
BIOLOGICAL OPINIONS. I WANT TO
ECHO THE COMMENTS MADE BY SOME
NUMBER FONG THE STATE WATER
CONTRACTORS. AND ENCOURAGE THE
ADMINISTRATION TO REMAIN
COMMITTED TO THE VOLUNTARY
GRANT PROCESS DESPITE THEIR
BCP. REQUEST FOR ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES FOR MEDICATION. WE
BELIEVE THAT THE VOLUNTARY
AGREEMENT- PROCESS CAN BE
SUCCESSFUL IN OUR MEMBERS ARE
COMMITTED TO MAKING. THE
PROCESS WORK. I'M LACKEY
RELATED TO SIGNUP FUNDING WE
WANT TO CONTINUE TO ENCOURAGE
LEGISLATURE AND THE
ADMINISTRATION TO ENSURE THAT
FUNDING IS DEDICATED TO
SUCCESSFUL SIGMA
IMPLEMENTATION. AND THIS
INCLUDES THE NINE POINT SIX
MILLION DOLLARS TO ENSURE THAT
THE DEPARTMENT OF WATER
RESOURCES. IT'S ADEQUATELY
STAFFED TO PERFORM THEIR
ESSENTIAL FUNCTIONS AS MANDATED
UNDERSTATEMENT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. ACT WE WILL GO TO LINE
ONE EIGHTY NINE. GOOD AFTERNOON
TURN MEMBERS WHICH IS NOT OFTEN
SEEN ON BEHALF OF SMARTER-
FIRST ONE TO REALLY- JUST
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS BY
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE WHO
CHARACTERIZED THE IMPORTANCE OF
ELECTRIC VEHICLE INFRASTRUCTURE
AND- WE TRANSPORTATION FUNDING-
WE ALSO WANTED O SPECIFICALLY
SUPPORT AN ITEM IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. WHICH IS
DEDICATING ADDITIONAL DOLLARS
FOR EACH CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE AT THE CDC AT
YOUR SUPPORT FOR THAT AND-
THANK YOU FOR HOLDING THIS
HEARING FROM THE ATTENTION.
THANK YOU. NEXT WE WILL GO TO
LINE ONE EIGHTY SIX. HELLO THIS
IS- ME HELP YOU GET OR
ASSISTANT CITY MANAGER THIS
IDEA CALEXICO- CHAIRMAN BLOOM
AND MEMBERS OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE- I WANT TO SPEAK
ON BEHALF OF SOME OF THE
SUPPORT FOR THE AB SEVENTEEN
AND STONE SEE MONEY. IN
PARTICULAR THE NEW RIVER
IMPROVEMENT PROJECT. TWENTY
EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS WEBSITE
OR CITY CAN APPROVED AND TODAY
WE SUBMITTED A LETTER OF
SUPPORT TO YOUR SUBCOMMITTEE WE
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME. AND
ATTENTION TO THE PUBLIC HEALTH.
OF CALIFORNIANS SPECIFICALLY
THOSE AFFECTED BY THE NEW RIVER
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AYE
MODERATOR I MY UNDERSTANDING IS
THAT- WE HAVE- SEVEN OR EIGHT
PEOPLE LEFT IN THE QUEUE BUT- A
QUITE A FOR A FEW ADDITIONAL
PEOPLE WHO ARE LISTENING IN ON
THE CALL AND TO. I BELIEVE YOU
HAVE INSTRUCTIONS FOR THEM WHAT
THEY WANT TO GET INTO THE QUEUE
AND I JUST WANT TO BRING THAT
UP SINCE WE ARE. ABOUT FORTY
FIVE MINUTES FROM- ARE HARD
STOP AT ONE PM. FOR THOSE OF
YOU THAT HAVE NOT CUED UP YET I
WOULD LIKE TO MAKE A COMMENT
PRESS THE ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
NEXT WE WILL GO TO LINE NINETY
NINE. ONE MOMENT HERE LINE
NINETY NINE. DO YOU HAVE A
COMMENT. EIGHT AND FOLLOW THE
QUEUE OUR NEXT WE WILL GO TO
LINE ONE NINETY FIVE. NINE ONE
NINETY FIVE GUY HAD. HELLO I
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS ARE HOME TO SLEEP ON
BEHALF OF LOCAL BUT IF YOU LOOK
UP IF YOU KNOW IT OR NOT WE
THANK GOVERNOR SOME FOR KEEPING
THE PROPOSED TWENTY EIGHT
MILLION DOLLAR ALLOCATION FOR
THE NEW EVER IMPROVEMENT
PROJECT THE MAYBE BY I WE ARE
STRONG SUPPORT BECAUSE WE'RE
BOTH PROJECTS WHAT ADDRESS
THERE IS PUBLIC HEALTH ISSUES
PARTICULARLY IN THE CITY OF
COLLECTING. THE NEW RIVERS
REALLY POLLUTED BY DISCHARGES
THE PLACE FROM DOMESTIC
AGRICULTURAL AND INDUSTRIAL
SOURCES IN MEXICO IN THE
GREATER VALUE YOU RIVER
POLLUTION PRINCE PUBLIC HEALTH
AND CONTRIBUTES TO WATER
QUALITY PROBLEMS OF THE BOND
THE- YOU WERE POLLUTION ALSO
HINDERS ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
AND FERAL COME. WE COMMEND THE
PREVIOUS LEADERSHIP OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RECOMMENDED THE DEATH
AND ARE EFFORTS TO REMEDIATE
THE RIVERS WATER QUALITY AB
ANTHONY NINE WHICH ESTABLISHED
TECHNICAL ADVISORY COMMITTEE TO
REPAIR THE RIVER STRATEGIC
PLAN. WE ALSO COMMENDED
WAVERING LEADERSHIP OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER EDUARDO GARCIA FOR
CONTINUE TO MAKE THE RIVER
IMPROVEMENT PROJECT THE
PRIORITY FOR HIS CONSTITUENTS I
THANK COMMUNITY PARTNERS
INCLUDING CALEXICO BILL COPY
AND A- DISTRICT WE'RE COMING
TOGETHER THIS. THANK. YOU YEAH.
YOU NEXT WE WILL CAROLINA. ONE
NINETY. SH HEY I'VE GOOD
MORNING HERE- BLOOM IN NUMBERS
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS RYAN
CLEAN ENERGY. I REPRESENT A
CALL WITHIN A FIFTY THREE WERE
ASKING THAT- AT LEAST 20% OF BY
EACH THAT FUNDS FROM G. OUT BE
ALLOCATED AGAIN FOR LOW NOT BOX
WE KNOW THAT HAVE TO BE LIMITED
TO NOT SURE THAT. WILL BE
AVAILABLE. BUT WE DO BELIEVE
THAT IT SHOULD BE A MARKET
SIGNAL CONTINUE. FUNDING
BECAUSE OTHERWISE PEOPLE TRUCKS
WILL BE ADOPTED AND LOCK BOX OR
THE THIN LINE BETWEEN THE SOUL
AND- CLEAN AIR IN AND THAT YOU
LEFT WE HAVE GOT THE MRS. SO
GIVE ME AT THAT POINT PERCENT
OF- EACH YEAR FUNDING TO EIGHT
THAT ALLOCATED BLOW UP BUT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU
GO TO LINE ONE FORTY SIX. HI
CARE AND MEMBERS THIS IS
JESSICA LITTLE WITH SAVE THE
REDWOODS LEAGUE I JUST WANT TO
RECOGNIZE THE CURRENT FISCAL
SITUATION BUT EVEN MORE
CRITICALLY THAT NUMEROUS AND
EQUITY THAT HAVE BEEN UNDER
SCORED BY THE PANDEMIC. WE ARE
REALLY CONCERNED WITH THAT A
PROPOSED OUT YOUR REDUCTIONS
THAT THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF PARKS AND
RECREATION. AND NOW MORE THAN
EVER ACCESS TO PARKS AND OPEN
SPACE R. RANCHO TO OUR PUBLIC
HEALTH AND ECONOMIC RECOVERY.
AT THE RESOURCE DISTORTED BY
THE DEPARTMENT OF PARKS
RECREATION PROVIDE LOW COST
RELIEF THAT ANDERS UNDER
RESOURCE URBAN AND RURAL
COMMUNITIES. YOU COMMUNITIES
THAT HAVE ALSO EXPERIENCED
DISPROPORTIONATELY THE ECONOMIC
AND EMPLOYMENT AND PUBLIC
HEALTH BURDENS RESULTED FROM
RESULTING FROM THE CO THAT
NINETEEN CRISIS- THE WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING- BUT THE
COMMITTEE. DEVELOPING AND
IMPLEMENTING AN ALTERNATIVE
SOLUTION TO THIS PROPOSED CUTS.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NEXT WE
WILL NOT A LINE ONE TWENTY ONE.
YES HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES
WE CAN. HELLO GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS PARTICULARLY I'M
CALLING FROM A YOUNG TECH WHICH
I LOVE ALLEY A LOCAL NONPROFIT
WORKING ALONGSIDE. THE RESIDENT
AT AND ALSO CALLING AFTER THAT
BUT I'M FROM THAT YOU COULD
TELL ABOUT IT MYSELF. I AM
CALLING IN SUPPORT FOR FUNDING
ALLOCATED TO ADDRESS A QUALITY
OF PUBLIC HEALTH CONCERNS
REGARDING THE PROPERTY. AND
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT THE STATE'S
PROPOSED APPROPRIATIONS WHICH
INCLUDES THE ADDITION OF A
STAFF POSITION CREATED TO
OFFICIALLY EMPLOYMENT. THE
PROPERTY MANAGEMENT PROGRAM
MAJORITY TO BE BASED LOCALLY.
TO PUT PROJECTS AND COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT THAT I CHOOSE OKAY
BENEFIT PROJECTS AND BENEFIT
COMMUNITIES LIVING AROUND FORTY
THREE. MINUTES ESSENTIAL FOR
THE STATE TO CONTINUE TO MAKE
PROGRESS AND ADDRESS PUBLIC
HEALTH CONCERNS. AT THE
RESIDENCE UP YET WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT ADDRESSING ISSUES THAT
IMPACT THEIR CURRENT
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
COMMUNITIES AND THE LIVES OF
OUR KIDS AND THE FUTURE. WE
REALLY APPRECIATE THAT BECAUSE
WHEN I LOOK FORWARD TO
COLLABORATE. OPTICS TWENTY WE
ADDRESS AGAIN PUBLIC HEALTH AND.
OUR QUALITY THANK YOU. NEXT WE
WILL GO TO LINE ONE NINE.
THAT'S ONE NINE ZERO. YES GOOD
AFTERNOON CAN YOU HEAR. YES WE
CAN GO AHEAD. ALL LOCAL I'M
SORRY- YES MY NAME WAS ON THE
WAY AND I'M SPEAKING ON BEHALF
OF OUR NONPROFIT ALL POSITIVE
POSSIBLE BITS AND THE BAY AREA
WE'RE HOPING AND- THAT- WE'RE
HOPING THAT YOU SUPPORT THE
EIGHTY SIX SEVENTEEN AM
PLANTATION WHILE WORKING WITH
OUR- LOCAL AIR DISTRICTS AND
THE STATE- ON EACH. ISSUE THAT
ARE SO VITAL TO OUR COMMUNITY
OUR COMMUNITY AND- A
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITY
PRIMARILY AFRICAN AMERICANS AND
AS YOU KNOW RECALL GROUP THAT
HAS EXPOSED THE RATES- DEATH
AMONG AFRICAN AMERICANS
PARTICULARLY THOSE THAT ARE
LOCATED BY POLLUTING SOURCES IT
IS HORRIBLE. THAT MEANS SUPPORT
THE IMPLEMENTATION THAT IS
NEEDED TO DO REDUCTION OPTION
AND I JUST HAVE TO SAY THAT IT
ALSO JUST FELT JUST TERRIBLE
THAT WE HAVE TO SPEAK TALK.
PRODUCT THAT. IT HOPES THAT ARE
UNDER SCORE HOW AND IT IS TO
SUPPORT THE ISSUE THAT A OUR
NEED. WHEN THE DIE HERE AND WE
DON'T HAVE THE FOR TO THE
COMMISSION AND TO PREVENT
BUDGET CUTS IN. AREA LIKE THE.
MY JOB IS HUNDRED MORE AREAS
THAT I HAVE VERY MY ONES WAY
THE LIMIT RESOURCES THAT WE
HAVE AND WHEN CALL THE THREE
FOUR THIS FAR LIFE AND A BILL
TO A- THESE ISSUES IT IS. A
MATTER LIFE DEATH BUT I SO
WHERE HOPING THAT THE FOUR AB
SEVENTEEN AND PARTICULAR BOTH
DISTRICTS WORK THAT WE HAVE TO
WORK WITH THEM TO GO ON AND
MOST IMPORTANTLY TO SUPPORT OUR
COMMUNITY BEING. ABLE TO STAY
ALIVE THANK YOU. NEXT WE WILL
DRAW A LINE FIFTY THAT FIVE
ZERO. GOOD AFTERNOON CHEN
NUMBERS IS KURT BACHMANN OF
ALISON WILSON AT THE ON BEHALF
OF THE SAN DIEGO ASSOCIATION OF
GOVERNMENTS STANDARD- THE CODE
NINETEEN CRISIS OF DECIMATED
BUDGET A TRANSPORTATION
AGENCIES OF THE NATION. THE
ANTICIPATED FUNDING CHOCOLATE
THAT'S MADE IT THAT'S WHAT THE
JOB OR THE ABILITY TO
TRANSPORTATION WORKERS IN
CALIFORNIA ALONE. AND FUNDING
CONTINUE TO BE PROVIDED FOR
CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS A
CAL U. P. I. T. PROGRAM WILL
HELP THE STATEMENT ITSELF AND
CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE.
CLIMATE CHANGE IN AIR QUALITY
GOALS WELL CREATING CAREER
TRACK QUALITY JOBS ACROSS THE
GREEN ECONOMY SUPPLY CHAIN. IS
ALSO IMPORTANT WE NOT FORGET
CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE
RESILIENCY PROJECTS LIKE THE
DUMB WHAT PLUS STABILIZATION
PROJECT INCENTIVE CHANNEL.
WHICH REMAINS AN URGENT NEED TO
ENSURE THE SAFETY AND
RELIABILITY THE SECOND BUSIEST
INTERCITY RAIL CORRIDOR IN THE
NATION. WE APPRECIATE THE
DIFFICULT. STAYS THE STATE
TODAY AND THEN BACK STANDS
READY TO HELP IN ANY WAY WE CAN
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. WE WILL
GO TO LINE ONE THIRTY TWO. GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
MICHAEL THAT THE PREY AND MY
KAYLEE ON BEHALF OF CHARGE
POINT. THIRTY POINT SUPPORT THE
BGP FOR THE CALIFORNIA ENERGY
COMMISSION THAT WILL SHIP FIFTY
ONE MILLION DOLLARS IN FUNDING
INTO THE CAL THE VIP PROGRAM.
AS WAS POINTED OUT IN THIS
HEARING CREAM TRANSPORTATION
MUST BE CONSIDERED AN INVESTED
APPROPRIATELY AS WE MOVE
FORWARD AND THIS VITAL CALLIE
V. I. P. PROGRAM HAS ALREADY
FUNDED OVER FORTY SEVEN HUNDRED
ELECTRIC VEHICLE CHARGERS 40%
OF WHICH ARE IN THE
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES. THAT
THAT WE ARE GOING. ONE THOUSAND
ELECT VEHICLE CHARGING SHORT OF
OUR TWENTY TWENTY FIVE GOAL OF
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND.
THIS FUNDING WILL HELP TO
BRIDGE THAT GAP OPERATING
ROUGHLY AN ADDITIONAL THIRTY
FIVE HUNDRED LEVEL TWO CHARGERS
AND THREE HUNDRED AND EIGHTY DC
FAST CHARTERS. WE APPRECIATE
YOUR SUPPORT OF THIS PCP AND
CLEAN TRANSPORTATION FUNDING
THANK YOU. NEXT WE WILL THAT
ONLINE FORTY SEVEN. I MEMBERS
ARE OR NOT YOU CAN BALLOT ON
BEHALF OF THE PHONE AUTHORITY
OUT WE ARE SUPPORT OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED INVESTMENTS
FOR THE THOUGHT WITH THE WITH
THE BUTTONS WILL PROVIDE
DESPERATELY NEED YOUR BE
COURSES TO ADDRESS THE
DANGEROUS LEVELS OF POLLUTION
IN THE NEW REPERTOIRE JUST LAST
FALL LEVEL THE FECAL CHLOROFORM
WORK ON THAT SEVEN HUNDRED AND
NINETY HI IN THE FEDERAL LIMIT.
IN ADDITION THE LAWLER ONE THE
NORTH FACE OF THE PERIMETER
LAKE AS OUTLINED IN THE
PROPERTY MANAGEMENT PLAN ON
ECONOMIC GAME CHANGER FOR THE
FROM WHAT HELLO VALLEY AT A
TIME WHEN JOB CREATION IT
DESPERATELY NEEDED WE CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE IT IS THE HIGHER
BUDGET. RENT A RESPECT BUT I
THINK HAVE BEEN NOT RETIRE. AT
THE PUMP THE FOR. THE PEOPLE. I
DO HAVE BEEN DIRE PHONE KEEPER
DECK WE ARE TO MAKING FAMILY
THE BEST THANK YOU. BACK WE
LOOK OUT ONLINE WE SEVEN FOUR.
IT HAPPENED AND CARRIED MY- A
LITTLE CAL STATE OF OKAY IS
REPRESENTING OF THE STATE FIFTY
EIGHT ALEX THE COURT THIS AND
BUDGET AND- IN A BONFIRE
RESOURCES THAT HELP BUT CAL
FIRE AND LET'S SEE IF YOU MAY.
BUT YOU CAN ONLY GIVE THEM A
HIGHER RISK. OF WILDFIRES THE
STAR WATER YEAR. WE LIKE THE
LINER COMMENTS WITH THOSE
AFFAIRS A THE- AND THE ROCK
ROUGH. OF COW BARNEA AND OUR
CONCERN OF THE POTENTIAL FUTURE
CHANGES TO THE STATE AND LOCAL
RELATIONSHIP THAT THERE. WE
RECOGNIZE THE DIVERSITY AFFAIRS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE I WOULD
LIKE TO ENSURE THAT COUNTIES
ARE INCLUDED IN ANY DISCUSSION
ON THE FUTURE OF THE IMPORTANT
RELATION SHIP. THANK. NEXT WE
WILL GO TO LINE. ONE EIGHTEEN
ONE ONE EIGHT. GOOD AFTERNOON
THE SIR ON THE MEMBERS BY
TELEPHONE ON BEHALF OF BEEN
FAIR PUBLIC AFFAIRS IMPERIAL
COUNTY. YOUR TODAY TO AVOID HER
SUPPORT FOR THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSAL FOR THE NEW
RIVER RESTORATION PROJECT WHICH
HAS BEEN A PUBLIC HEALTH
CRISIS. FOR DECADES IN OUR
BORDER OF CALIFORNIA BEING
RAISED IN CALEXICO AND IS A
FORMER CITY COUNCIL MEMBER
CALEXICO WHERE THE POLLUTED
RIVER FLOWS THROUGH THE LAST
THING WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE IS
ANOTHER HEALTH CRISIS FOR
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS.AND MORE
POORLY FOR CHILDREN ALONG THE
BORDER. WITH A THEY RESPECT
REQUEST THAT YOU SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL AND I
RECOGNIZE ASSEMBLY MEMBER WATER
GARCIA'S EFFORTS. TO RESOLVE
OUR CALIFORNIA BORDER PUBLIC
HEALTH CRACK IS ON THIS NEW
RIVER. I THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR
TIME AND I LOOK AND FOR THANK
YOU FOR LOOKING OUT FOR PUBLIC
HEALTH. GOT YES. NEXT LEVEL
THAT ONLINE ONE EIGHTY ONE.
THERE ARE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS BILL
GAINES AND I'M TESTIFYING TODAY
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEAR ASSOCIATION AND THE
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER OF THE WHILE
SHE FOUNDATION AS WELL AS
SEVERAL OTHER WILDLIFE
CONSERVATION ORGANIZATIONS. AND
WE ARE THE CALIFORNIA WATERFOWL
ASSOCIATION IS CONCERNED
REGARDING THE SHIFT IN PROP
NINETY NINE CIGARETTE TAX
MONEY. TO CREATE A LOT OF
FUNDING HERE MARK FOR WATER
FELL IN A WETLAND. WE ALSO URGE
YOU TO REJECT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S HABITAT
CONSERVATION PLAN TRAILER BILL.
AND TO REJECT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
FUND STATE OPERATIONS BUDGET
PCP THAT RELIES ON THE FUNDING
OF THE HABITAT CONSERVATION
FUND WHICH WOULD VOID THE
EXTENSION NEGOTIATED. AUTOMATIC
CONSERVATION FUND JUST LAST
YEAR. FINALLY WE ASK THE
ASSEMBLY TO ENSURE THAT WOULD
BE EIGHTEEN POINT NINE MILLION
BE SHIFTED FROM THE AGENCY
AFTER THE DEPARTMENT OF FISH
AND WILDLIFE THAT THOSE MONIES
P. BACKFIELD TO WCVB UPON
MONIES GENERAL FUND. OR SOME
OTHER MEANS THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NEXT WE WILL THAT ALIGN ONE
SIXTY SIX. YES I GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIRMAN FIRST MY NAME
IS THOMAS OLIVER COUNCIL MEMBER
FOR THE CITY OF ALL CENTRO US
ON BEHALF OF THE COUNCIL THE
RESIDENTS OF THE CITY ABLE
CENTRAL WE ARE. EXPRESS THEIR
SUPPORT FOR THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL TO FUND THE NOVEMBER
AGREEMENT PLAN AND THE SOLVENCY
MANAGEMENT PLAN. AS MANY OF YOU
KNOW WE FACE MANY CHALLENGES
HERE AND IMPERIAL COUNTY. AND
FUNDING THESE PLANS CAN ADDRESS
HERE IS PUBLIC HEALTH ISSUES
THAT WE- I HAVE TO DEAL WITH
EVERY DAY OUT HERE- AN IMPACT
NOT ONLY THE RESIDENTS OF THE
GIRL COUNTY BUT ALSO TO TELL
ABOUT THE AS WELL. I AND I
WOULD GO SO FAR TO SAY THAT IT
ALSO AFFECTS. ALL RESIDENTS OF
THE GREATER SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
YOU FOR YOUR- FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
NEXT WE WILL GO TO LINE ONE
FORTY THREE. MY AND ONE FORTY
THREE DO YOU HAVE IT ON MUTE.
NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE
TWELVE. THAT WOULD LINE ONE
TWELVE. YOU HAVE A TIME YOU
KNOW TO. WHAT A LINE ONE NINETY
TWO. THE CAMERA HI- GOOD
AFTERNOON SURE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK MY NAME IS
AND MY MORE MARTINEZ CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE IMPERIAL
IRRIGATION DISTRICT WHICH SIR
POWER. ABOUT FOREIGN FIFTY
CUSTOMERS AND IMPERIAL COULD
TELL VALLEY'S AND DELIVER WATER
TO BE ABOUT HALF A MILLION
ACRES OF FARMLAND WE APPRECIATE
THE OPEN COMMENT MADE TODAY ARE
REGARDING TURNING ON COME
DIFFERENTIATING COMMITTEE
TAKING PART IN A BURDENS ARE
NOT REGARD IT ABOUT AND- WE
WANT TO EXPRESS OUR STRONG
SUPPORT FOR THE ALLOCATION IN
THE MAYBE PRICE FOR THE
REVEREND OFTEN SEE. HOW TO THE
MOST PRESSING ENVIRONMENTAL
ISSUES FACING THE STATE AT BUT
DIRECTLY IMPACTING SOME OF THE
MOST DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES-
HERE IN THE STATE WHICH ARE
LOCATED IN IMPERIAL AND IS
EASTERN RIVERSIDE COUNTIES. AS
MENTIONED THE NEW RIVERS ONE OF
pSTATE I CARRYING UNTREATED
SEWAGE WATER WATER FROM MEXICO.
AND IN THE TOP TWO THREE. OKAY
HE IS ALSO. TO THE WATER. A
WATER. REDUCING CREE HAVE
EATING. DUST AND EREKLE. IN PER
VALLEY EVERY HAS THE HIGHEST
CHILDHOOD ASTHMA
HOSPITALIZATION RATES IN THE
STATE- AND THE STATE HAS THIRTY
RECOGNIZE ITS RESPONSIBILITY IN
A ROLE. AND IT'S IMPORTANT TO
MOVE THE SALTON SEA MANAGEMENT
PROGRAM FORWARD. BOB HAD
DEMOCRATS ANOTHER LAYER BERNIE
NEED THESE PREDOMINANTLY LATINO
LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES.
THEREFORE WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST THE FUNDING REMAIN IN
THE BUDGET THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY. NEXT WE WILL THAT
ONLINE SEVENTY SIX. GOOD
AFTERNOON SHARON NUMBER ONE MY
NAME IS LILY AND MARCUS THAT
CENTER FOR SUSTAINABLE ENERGY
AND I'M CALLING TO SUPPORT THE
CALIFORNIA ENERGY COMMISSION
REQUEST FOR A ONE TIME
EXPENDITURE OF FIFTY ONE
MILLION DOLLARS FROM THE
ALTERNATE AND UNKNOWABLE
FEELING VEHICLE TECHNOLOGY FUND.
ZERO MISSION VEHICLE CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE. THE CALIFORNIA
LIKE TECHNICAL INFRASTRUCTURE
PROJECT- CALLIE THE EIGHTIES
ACOSTA LAY OVER FOUR THOUSAND
SEVEN HUNDRED AND FIFTY
ELECTRIC VEHICLE CHARGING
STATION. 40% OF WHICH ARE
LOCATED INDEPENDENT COMMUNITY.
THE IS THE FINAL ARE CRUCIAL TO
BOLSTER THE STATE AND MEETING
AND FIFTY ONE MILLION. AS YOUR
MISSION VEHICLE GOAL BY TWENTY
THIRTY WHICH CREATES CLEAN AIR
AND PUBLIC HEALTH BENEFITS FOR
ALL CALIFORNIANS. HOW YANKEE IS
CURRENTLY OVERSUBSCRIBED AND
THEY'RE SHOVEL READY PROJECT
ABOUT ARE ALREADY IN THE
PIPELINE AND READY TO GO ON THE
BILL. IN A FIFTY ONE MILLION
DOLLARS WAS MADE AVAILABLE THE
STUDENT POPCORN IN CONCERT MANY
NEED CLEAN TRANSPORTATION
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECT THIS IS
GOING TO DROP OR- WHAT LOT WE
URGE YOUR SUPPORT. OF THE FIFTY
ONE MILLION DOLLARS. FOR THE
COPY ENERGY COMMISSION THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME. NEXT
WE WILL GO TO LINE TWO HUNDRED.
GOOD AFTERNOON HEARING MEMBERS
ELECTED TO HIGH ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA SPECIAL
DIFFICULT DECISION SPECIAL
DISTRICT MAINTAIN CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE AND PROVIDE
ESSENTIAL COMMUNITY SERVICE
NINE TO CALIFORNIAN THROUGHOUT
THE STATE. SEE IF HE WAS DRUNK
THE CORE OF THE GOVERNOR'S
JANUARY CLIMATE RESILIENT
PEOPLE DON'T THE FOCAL AND CAN
CAN HURT THE LEGISLATURE TO
CONSIDER AN ECONOMIC RECOVERY
BOND FOCUS ON CLIMATE
RESILIENCY WE ACKNOWLEDGE THE
SIGNIFICANT ECONOMIC IMPACT OF
CO THE NINETEEN RESPONSE AND
BELIEVE THIS FUNDING WITH A LOT
SHOVEL READY CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS TO
STIMULATE LOCAL ECONOMIES. BUT
MAN THINK CLIMATE GOLDEN
CREATING RESILIENT COMMUNITIES
THAT CALIFORNIA CAN BE.
PREPARED IN THAT THE DOCTOR
THANK YOU. NEXT WE WILL GO TO
LINE NINETY NINE. HI YEAH OKAY
HI EVERYONE OUT THANKS FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE COMMENTS
OBVIOUSLY A LOT ABOUT THIS ON
THE CHAIR OF THE I HAVE AN
APARTMENT A JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
TASK FORCE IN BOTH IMPERIAL AND
COACHELLA VALLEY AND AGAIN
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PROVIDE INPUT TODAY ON THAT
VERY IS CRITICAL MATTERS- A
PRESENTED TODAY OUT ON THIS-
BUDGET REVISION- YOU KNOW
COMMUNITIES ARE WORKING ON
MULTIPLE WITH MULTIPLE
STAKEHOLDERS TO THE COMMITMENT
MADE BY SB SIX ONE SEVEN TO
REDUCING AIR POLLUTION IN
CALIFORNIA. AND ENSURING THAT
OR BORDER REGION AND. HAVE
ACCESS TO BE UNHEALTHY AIR. ARE
THERE FOR I'M RESPECTFULLY.
THAT YOU FULLY COMMIT
IMPLEMENTATION OF A TO SIX ONE
SEVEN. BY CONTINUALLY GETTING
THE FUNDING- IN THE COMING
FISCAL YEAR. FOR THE ABC FROM
SEVEN TO MAKE PATIENT. ALSO YOU
KNOW THERE'S ALSO- THEY GIGGLED
ISSUE IN A BORDER COMMUNITY.
OUR UNIQUE HAVE TAKEN UPON THE
COMMUNITY TELL US WILL
ACCOMPLISH BEING EXPOSED TO
CANCER CAUSING BACTERIA VIRUSES
AND OTHER PATHOGENS THERE FOUND
ON THE INTERNET WATERS OF THE
RIVER. SO THEREFORE I AM
RESPECTFULLY- IN SUPPORT OF THE
TWENTY EIGHT MILLION OFFER THE
NEW RIVER IMPROVEMENT PROJECT
THAT WERE INCLUDED ON THE
BUDGET MAYBE THIS AND
ADDITIONALLY I'M OFTEN STRONG
SUPPORT FOR THE COMMITMENTS
MADE. ON THIS MAY REPRESENT FOR
THE STATE BUDGET OR NINETEEN
POINT THREE MILLION ALLOCATED
FOR THE PHONE TWO MANAGEMENT
PLAN. THE FUNDING OF THIS
PLANET ABOUT MOST BIRD YOU TO
THE HEALTH AND PROSPERITY OF UP
THE COMMUNITIES LIVING ON FUNKY
TRANS BOUNDARY BUT WATERSHED.
OF THEIR EXPOSED THE PUBLIC
HEALTH RISKS ARISING FROM THE
POLLUTION OF THE RIVER AND THE
EXPOS PLAYER OF THE SONG THE-
MAKING THEM MORE SUSCEPTIBLE SO
THE BURNER BURDENS OF THE
CURRENT. OVER NINETEEN PANDEMIC.
ON TOP OF A CLEAR PUBLIC.
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH BENEFITS
THAT WILL ARISE FROM THIS
BUDGET ALLOCATION. BOTH OF THIS
PROJECT WILL CREATE JOBS. AND
SOME OF THE MOST SOME OF THE
CALIFORNIA'S MOST RURAL UNDER
SERVED AREAS. THAT HAVE BEEN
HIT THE HARDEST BY THE AND THAT
MAKE. ALSO I WANT TO THANK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF OVER HERE.
WHAT WE'RE ASKING AND DINNER.
THANK YOU THANK. NEXT PHOTO
LINE PEOPLE ONE. GOOD AFTERNOON
KEREN MEMBERS THIS IS NINETY
EXPANSION THE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURERS AND TECHNOLOGY IF
THE PATIENT WE WANTED TO
EXPRESS OUR OPPOSITION WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION THE TSC REFORM
PROPOSAL WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH COMMITTEE AND THE
ADMINISTRATION TO DEVELOP A
PROPOSAL WHICH CHEAP
TRANSPARENCY ACCOUNTABILITY AND
RESPONSIBILITY. FROM THE
DEPARTMENT THANK YOU. NEXT
WE'LL THAT ONLINE SEVENTY FIVE.
BUT LINE SEVENTY FIVE ARE YOU
I'M UNIT. WELL. YES WE CAN HEAR
YOU NOW. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT
HANDER EMPLOYEE- WITH CHARTER
INCLUDES ROLES AND LAYING ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES- BUT ALSO ON BEHALF OF
THE PORT OF LOS ANGELES FRANKLY
FOR THIS THE FAMILY OF AGENCIES
WITHIN THE- THE CITY WHAT
ANGERS THAT RELY. ON
EXPENDITURES FROM VARIOUS DDR
OF- FUNDED PROGRAMS WE
ENCOURAGE THIS COMMITTEE THE
SUBCOMMITTEE TO DEFER ACTION
AND NOT TAKEUP BE
ADMINISTRATORS MAY REVISED
PROPOSAL THAT CALLS FOR PAYS
YOU GO- ONCE YOU KNOW- OPTIONS
KAMALA QUARTERLY BASIS WE THINK
THAT THERE IS TIME FOR THE IN
THE LEGISLATURE SHOULD GIVE
THEMSELVES- TO. SEE WHAT
ACTUAL- REVENUES. ARE GOING TO
BE OPTION PROCEEDS. OR MAKING
DECISIONS TOO MUCH THIS BUT
THAT THIS LOOKS. OF FORCED TO.
I BY JUNE FIFTEENTH WITHOUT THE
BENEFIT OF ANY ACTUAL- REVENUES
AND- THIS PRECEDENT FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO CONDUCT. A DELAY
ACTION TO FIGURE OUT WHAT THE
REAL REVENUE PICTURE LOOKS LIKE
WITH RESPECT TO THE G. JEREH
UNTIL WE URGE THE LEGISLATURE
TO DO THAT FOR THE PORT OF LOS
ANGELES PROGRAMS LIKE THE
CLEANER ACTUALLY PLANNED THAT
LIE. THAT RELY ON FUNDING
ESPECIALLY IN THE CATEGORY OF
DEMONSTRATIONS OF PILOTS.
RELIED OF FUNDING THROUGH THE
LOW CARBON TRANSPORTATION
PROGRAMS THAT MINISTERED OF
THEIR RESOURCES OR- THERE'S
OTHER PROGRAMS WITHIN CITY OF
LOS ANGELES LIKE.
TRANSFORMATIVE CLIMATE
COMMUNITIES AND- IT'S NOT
WORKING ALL OF THEM BUT- I
THINK THE POINT TO MAKE IS
THAT- THE CITY OF LA HAS A
STRATEGY THAT. WILL KEEP
PARTNERSHIP WITH MANY OF THESE
FUNDING PROGRAMS AND WE URGE
THE LEGISLATURE TO GIVE HIMSELF
TIME TO GET A CLEARER PICTURE.
OF WHAT AUCTION PROCEEDS ARE
REALLY GONNA LOOK BY IN THE
BUDGET HERE. THANK YOU THANK
YOU. WE JUST LIKE TO REMIND THE-
SAID. I TO LIMIT THEIR TO ABOUT
A MINUTE TO WE HAVE ENOUGH TIME
TO HEAR EVERYONE IN THE QUEUE
THANK YOU. NEXT CALL THAT
ONLINE ONE NINETY EIGHT. I HAVE
NINE ONE NINETY EIGHT. ARE YOU
THERE. WELCOME TO THE NEXT NINE
MONTHS LINE TO THREE. GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS JASON WEBER
MARIN COUNTY FIRE CHIEF
REPRESENTING THE ASSOCIATION OF
CONTRACT COUNTIES WHICH
INCLUDES ORANGE LOS ANGELES
KERN. INTEREST IN A BARBARA AND
RAN CALLING TO FOR UP FROM OUR
SUPPORT OF THE EIGHTY FIVE
POINT SIX MILLION DOLLAR RELIEF
STAFFING BC HE AUGMENTING CAL
FIRE. THANK YOU HAVE A GREAT
DAY. NEXT WE WILL THAT ALIGN TO
VOTE TO NORTH. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME
STANDARD TOLD ME WITH MONTEREY
BAY COMMUNITY POWER- WE ARE
COMMUNITY CHOICE ENERGY PROGRAM
WITH ALMOST THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND CUSTOMERS AND SOON TO
BE OVER FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND
CUSTOMERS THROUGHOUT THE
CENTRAL COAST. ON WERE FOCUSED
ON GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
REDUCTIONS IN ELECTRIFICATION
AND WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS A
CLIMATE AND CLEAN AIR GOAL
SPECIFICALLY AROUND THE
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR- MORE
THAN 80% OF THE GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS ACROSS THE CENTRAL
COAST FROM SANTA CRUZ TO
VENTURA COME FROM
TRANSPORTATION- WITH INCREASING
HOME PRICES AND ECONOMIC
PRESSURES. IT IS PUSHING PEOPLE
FURTHER AND FURTHER FROM THEIR
JOBS- THE OPPORTUNITY- FOR THE
STATE TO CONTINUE ON ITS
MISSION TO TRANSFORM OUR
ECONOMY INTO ONE THAT IS
FOCUSED ON GREEN JOBS IS EVEN
MORE IMPORTANT- DURING THIS
PANDEMIC. FUNDING PROGRAMS
ELECTRIFY CUT ELECTRIFY
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR WILL PUT
CALIFORNIANS BACK TO WORK AND
ASSIST WITH ECONOMIC RECOVERY
SUCH AS THE CAL YOU V. I. P.
PROGRAM WHICH IS INVESTING
SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS INTO THE
LOCAL ECONOMY JUST THIS YEAR-
THIS YEAR'S PROGRAM WAS SO
SUCCESSFUL THERE WAS. NINETEEN
MILLION DOLLARS IN ADDITIONAL
APPLICATIONS FOR DC FAST
CHARGERS- PROGRAMS LIKE THIS
INSPIRED ENCOURAGE FOLKS TO
TAKE ACTION ON CLIMATE CHANGE
WHILE HELPING TO SUPPORT A
VARIETY OF TRADE AND GOOD
PAYING JOBS OF NOW IS THE TIME
THE OPPORTUNITY FOR THE STATE
TO CONTINUE TO LEAD ON. THE
BEST IN A CO PICTURE. MERGING
ECONOMY TAKE YOU. NEXT WE'LL
GET A LINE TO- FOR TWO HUNDRED
AND FOUR. GOOD AFTERNOON
MEMBERS RECALL MONSTER DID NOT
ARE WHAT THE TRUST FOR PUBLIC
LAND I'D LIKE TO SUPPORT
PREVIOUS SPEAKERS COMMENT AND
URGE YOU TO REJECT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL REGARDING
THE HABITAT CONSERVATION FUND
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT TO RESTORE
FUNDING FOR THIS PROGRAM AND
THEN EXPAND THE PLANT THAT A
DOG WHAT BRIDGE ROUGHLY A HALF
A BILLION DOLLARS BETWEEN STATE
AND FEDERAL FUNDS OVER TEN
YEARS IT'S MORE RELIABLE THAN
BOND FUNDING IT'S INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT TO YOU OUR
CONSERVATION PRIORITIES. WANT
TO- THANK THE ADMINISTRATION
QUIRK CELEBRATING SOME OF THE
PROP FIFTY EIGHT FUND TAKE
EARLY THAT THIS THAT- LOCAL
PARK PROGRAM WHICH WAS
OVERSUBSCRIBED BAY 8100% IN THE
LAST ROUND WE HAVE SHOVEL READY
PROJECT THAT COULD- BUT PEOPLE
TO WORK WHILE GREENING OUR-
MOST. UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES.
AND I JUST WANT TO URGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO CONTINUE
EXPLORING THE OPTION AVE CLIMB
AT. SLASH ECONOMIC RECOVERY
BOND- I KNOW IT DIFFICULT TIMES
BUT THAT WOULD BE A JOB THEY
MAIL IT. AND I THINK WE COULD
DO WITHOUT IN A WAY THAT- WOULD
DROP THE BY- OF THE ECONOMIC
THAT WHILE STILL YOU KNOW THE-
THE BOND THE BED AT NIGHT- BUT
PUT MONEY TO WORK THING IS
POSSIBLE TO THANK YOU FOR ALL
YOUR- GREAT WORK. AND I
APPRECIATE VERY MUCH. NEXT WE
WILL THAT A LINE OF FIVE. YES
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MICHAEL
LOCAL DORO ON THE HAVE TO THE
AGRICULTURAL ENERGY CONSUMERS
ASSOCIATION WANT TO FOCUS MY
COMMENTS TODAY ON THE DERRY
METHANE REDUCTION. FUNDING
PROVIDED BUDGET YEAR UP TO
CDSA- WE ARE CONCERNED WITH THE
TWENTY MILLION DOLLAR
ALLOCATION UP FROM THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET FOR THE- AT
THE END REDUCTION PROGRAMS
WHICH INVOLVES BOTH THE
DIGESTIVE PROGRAM AND THE
ALTERNATIVE MINORE MANAGEMENT
PROGRAM. AN ANALYSIS RELEASED
BY A OR B. JUST THIS MORNING-
BUT MANY OF US WERE WATCHING
SHOWED THAT WITH TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN FUNDING THE STATE'S
GOAL BY TWENTY THIRTY OF A 40%
REDUCTION IN. DERRY MANEUVER
MESSING WILL NOT BE ACHIEVED
AND CANNOT BE ACHIEVED IT
SUGGESTED THAT- ALONG THE LINES
OF EIGHTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
OVER THE NEXT SEVERAL YEARS
WOULD NEED TO BE APPROPRIATE TO
ACHIEVE THE STATE'S. GOAL SO I
WANTED TO SHARE THAT. CURRENT
INFORMATION WITH YOU AS YOU
SEEK TO- REVIEW THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSALS AND RECOGNIZE THAT
WITH LIMITED FUNDING THE GOALS
CANNOT BE ACHIEVED THANK YOU.
NEXT WE WILL THAT ONLINE TWENTY
NINE. HI COMMITTEE MEMBERS THIS
IS BILL MCGAVIN WITH THE
COALITION FOR CLEAN AIR AND WE
UNDERSTAND THE STATUS IN A DIRE
FISCAL SITUATION BUT WE OPPOSE
THE DIVERSION OF THE AIR
POLLUTION CONTROL FUND.
PARTICULARLY SINCE THAT FUND IS
RUNNING A STRUCTURAL DEFICIT WE
THINK TAT MONEY SHOULD GO TO
REDUCING AIR POLLUTION. WE DO
SUPPORT THE PROPOSED FIFTY ONE
MILLION DOLLARS FOR A LECTURE
FECAL INFRASTRUCTURE. IT COMES
A GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION FUND
AND THESE COMMENTS ARE JOINED
BY THE AMERICAN LUNG
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA. WE
THINK BECAUSE THE UNCERTAINTY
IN THE FUNDING YOU SHOULD DELAY
THIS DECISION TO AUGUST. AND
WHEN YOU DO CONSIDER IT IF
YOU'RE PRIORITIZE QUEEN
TRANSPORTATION FUNDING AND
COMMUNITY ARE PROTECTION OR SB
SIX SEVENTEEN. THESE PROGRAMS
WILL PROTECT PUBLIC HEALTH AND
PUT PEOPLE BACK TO WORK IN OUR
MOST DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
THAT ARE HIT THE HARDEST BY THE
PANDEMIC AND THE RECESSION AS
WELL AS AIR POLLUTION AND
CLIMATE CHANGE. THANK YOU. NEXT
WE WILL THAT ALIGN TO TEN.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE BOARD
MY NAME IT AFTER THEY HAD I
KNOW I'M A COMMUNITY HEALTH
WORKER FOR IMPERIAL COUNTY.
I'VE WORKED VERY CLOSELY WITH
FAMILIES AND RESIDENT FOR ABOUT
FIFTEEN YEARS NOW I STRONGLY
SUPPORT APPROPRIATION OF FUNDS
FOR THE STOCK AT THE END RIVER
EIGHTY SIX ONE SEVEN. THIS IS A
HIGH URGENCY ON TOP OF ALL
OTHER ISSUES THAT ARE COMMUNITY
FOCUSED ON A DAILY BASIS. AT
THE RATE OF CRIME THAT'S GREAT
OBESITY RATE I THANK YOU SO
MUCH AND I DO STRONGLY SUPPORT
APPROPRIATION OF THE KIND.
AGUIAR-CURRY. ONE THIRTY EIGHT.
LINE ONE THIRTY EIGHT. HELLO
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF MY NAME IS
TRYING TO ENCOURAGEI'M
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF CATHOLIC
CHARITIES DIE IS A STOCK THEN
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE PROGRAM.
WE FIRST WANT TO SUPPORT THE
FUNDING THAT WAS APPROPRIATE
INTO EIGHTY SIX SEVENTEEN. BUT
WE WANT TO URGE THE EMPHASIS ON
FINDING THE AB SIX SEVENTEEN
IMPLEMENTATION. WHICH WILL HELP
BRING CLEAN AIR MEASURES FOR
MOST DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES.
NOW MORE THAN EVER IT IS
IMPORTANT TO CONTINUE TO WORK
HARD WORK AS CITIES RESIDENTS
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE BORK'S
AMBITIOUS BUT INTO THE- NEVER
HAD A CENTRAL VALLEY MAYBE EVEN
THE STATE WHAT IF THE EVEN MORE
ABOUT THE PROGRAM. WHERE BARMAN
TO JUSTICE I THINK FOR FRONT.
SB SIX SEVENTEEN AT THE STEP TO
THE RIGHT DIRECTION. FROM THE
STATE TO REBUILD THE
RELATIONSHIP FROM RESIDENTS
AFTER YEARS OF DISTRUST. I HAVE
PROVIDED RESIDENT AVOID
INCISION MAKING PROCESS ANY
HUGE PARTY FOR WHAT RESIDENTS
WOULD WANT IN THEIR COMMUNITY.
READY FOR FINDING A COMEDIAN
LENT SOLUTION TO IMPROVE
RESPIRATORY HEALTH IS IMPORTANT
ISSUE RIGHT NOW THANK YOU. LA
RIGHT ACT WE WILL GO TO LINE
TWO THIRTEEN. YEAH HI- INGRID
ROSTRON WHAT THE CENTER ON RACE
POVERTY AND THE ENVIRONMENT.
AND WE SUPPORTED MINISTRATION
PROPOSAL TO ESTABLISH. WE NEED
IT. GREAT WE NEED TO
REESTABLISH HAZARDOUS WASTE
REDUCTION AS A GOAL AND
FUNCTION OF THE DEPARTMENT. WE
NEED TO RESTRUCTURE FEE TO
INCENTIVIZE WASTE REDUCTION.
AND WE NEED TO ADOPT HAZARDOUS
WASTE MANAGEMENT PLAN. WE
BELIEVE THAT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL IS AN IMPORTANT FIRST
STEP. HOWEVER WE ALSO BELIEVE
THAT THE BOARD HAD AN
INSTRUMENTAL BOWL AND ADVANCING
OTHER OBJECTIVES. THANK YOU.
ACT WE WILL GO TO LINE TWO
SIXTEEN. YES GOOD AFTERNOON
STATE ASSEMBLY MEMBERS- I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF- GOVERNOR
NUISANCE PROPOSAL TO CUT 10%
PAY FROM STATE WORKERS HEY YOU
KNOW WE'RE HARD WORKING
ESSENTIAL WORKERS EFFORT TO
MANY YEARS- THE STATE EMPLOYEES
HAVE BEEN. MAKING SACRIFICES TO
BENEFIT REDUCTIONS AND COSTS
INCURRED SUCH AS WELL B. B.
THAT PRE RETIREMENT FUND- WE
FEEL THAT- IT REGARDS TO COST
SAVINGS THAT THE GOLDEN
HANDSHAKE WOULD BE BEST SUITED
FOR THE SITUATION. TO TAKE MORE
MONEY FROM STATE WORKERS AT
THIS TIME WHAT INJURY A GREAT
THE- SACRIFICE TO TOO MANY- SO
WE HOPE THAT YOU KEEP US IN
MIND. WHEN IT COMES TO
BALANCING THE BUDGET SPECIALLY
WHEN THERE'S BEEN OTHER.
LEGISLATION THAT HAS BEEN RE
DIRECTED TO. OTHER CAUSES THAT
BEEN MISS MISREPRESENTED. SUCH
AS IMMIGRATION FUNDING. THANK
YOU. BACK WHEN I WILL BUT I
LINE ONE EIGHTY SEVEN. YEAH
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN
CHAIRMAN WOMEN COMMITTEE MEMBER
MY NAME IS DOROTHY THOMPSON
WITH METROPOLITAN WATER
DISTRICT OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
METROPOLITAN SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL RELATD TO
THE CAPITA SPENDING TO SUPPORT
SAFE AND AFFORDABLE DRINKING
WATER. WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
THAT THE LEGISLATURE AND
ADMINISTRATION CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE ADEQUATE FUNDING OPTION
FAILED TO SUPPORT THE STATE BY
PRIORITY. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. ACT WILL THAT ALIGN. TO
FIFTEEN TWO ONE FIVE. HAVE A
SOME UTILIZING TO FIFTEEN.
THERE ARE NO FURTHER COMMENT.
OKAY THEN I THANK YOU EVERYONE
WHO HAS PARTICIPATED TO DAY
THAT WILL CONCLUDE TODAY'S A
COMMITTEE HEARING. WHERE GIANT.